IS NOT A MESSAGE FOR THE ROOM
IT'S A MESSAGE FOR THOSE
WATCHING ON TV THAT IF ANY OF MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES ARE
WATCHING PLEASE COME DOWN. TO
HEARING ROOM WHERE WE FOUR FOUR
FOUR SO WE GET STARTED THANK YOU
.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY
[inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
PRESENT TEMPERATURE OF THE ROOM.
WELCOME DO IT.
THE WEDNESDAY JUNE NINETEENTH
MEETING OF THE ELECTIONS ARE
DISTURBING COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE -- A QUORUM.
SIR MADAM SECRETARY OF WILL CALL
THE ROLL THAT ARE GOING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS [inaudible]
BERMAN HERE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible] ONE WEBER
[inaudible]
WITH.
GREAT WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE
TWO ITEMSON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SB ONE FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
UMBERG IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
AS OUTLINED IN COMMON NUMBER.
ONE OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
AND ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SIX
ANYONE BY SENATOR STERN.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU GOT A MOTION THE
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
BERMAN.
HI BERMAN I GALLAGHER.
HI GALLAGHER AYE CALDERON
CALDERON AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MAYES.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER [inaudible]
THAT'S OUT [inaudible] SEVEN I'M
LOOKING.
FOR GREAT SO WE'LL GET STARTED --
FIRST OF WE HAVE.
THIS ON OUR MCCARTY WITH ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS A SIX READY WHEN
YOU ARE SIR.
ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
CARE TO I PROBABLY PRESENTS ARE
MEASURE -- FREE THE VOTE A CA
SIX WHICH IS A MEASURE TO PUT
THE ISSUE ON THE BALLOT WE'RE
NOT DECIDING HERE TODAY.
THIS POLICY ISSUE SENSUALLY
WOULD GIVE THOSE ON PAROLE THOSE
WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR THEIR
SENTENCE -- A CHANCE TO VOTE
ONCE -- THEY ARE -- FREED AND
FOCUS ON FORMALLY INCARCERATED
AND RE INTEGRATING INDIVIDUALS
BACK INTO SOCIETY WE KNOW OUR
COUNTRY IS THE ENVY OF THE WORLD
WHEN IT COMES TO DEMOCRACY BUT
VOTING HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN THAT
EASY.
FROM RACIALLY BASED POLL TAXES
TO EXCLUDING WOMEN TO VOTE WE'VE
HAD OUR CHALLENGE OF HIS WITH
VOTING JUSTICE IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND AND THIS IS A MEASURE THAT
WHICH ALLOWED CALMLY
INCARCERATED.
A CHANCE TO GET BACK INTO
SOCIETY THEY'VE ALREADY PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY YEAH
THEY'RE PAYING THEIR TAXES AND
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
AS WELL HERE IN A FEW SECONDS.
THIS ISN'T A FRANKLY A RED STATE
ISSUE OR A BLUE STATE ISSUE
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH MANY STATES
LIKE NORTH DAKOTA UTAH AND
FLORIDA.
ARE DOING THIS FLORIDA JUST HAD
A MAJOR ELECTION RECENTLY. TO
RESTORE VOTING RIGHTS FOR THOSE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED -- BELIEVE
IT OR NOT THERE ARE TWO STATES
IN OUR COUNTRY WHICH WILL ALLOW
YOU TO VOTE FROM PRISON.
MAINE AND VERMONT TO ONE
ACTUALLY IS A DEMOCRAT STATE WON
THE REPUBLICAN STATE.
JUST FOR THE RECORD WE'RE NOT
PROPOSING THAT HERE TODAY.
REALLY TALKING ABOUT THOSE WHO
ARE -- HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
CONVICTED AND RELEASED AND ARE
ON PAROLE RESTORING THOSE VOTING
RIGHTS.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT RE
INTEGRATING PEOPLE BACK IN
SOCIETY I THINK IT'S A MORAL
ISSUE.
DON'T YOU THINK ABOUT PEOPLE ON
PAROLE WE'VE TAKEN GREAT STEPS
HERE TO TO BAN THE BOX TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GET BACK INTO
EMPLOYMENT ON ON HOUSING --
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE ARE
RE INTEGRATE INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES THIS IS ANOTHER STEP
ALONG THE WAY.
AND RESTORING VOTING RIGHTS FOR
EVERYBODY SO -- THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY -- WITH ME IS --
TIGHT ENOUGH VARGAS ADMIN
FOUNDER OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND
TERRACE CYPRIAN FOR ALL OF US
ARE NOT.
NOW ALLOW THEM -- TO TO TESTIFY
THIS MORNING.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TIENE OF ARGUS ADMIN I'M
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND
WE'RE AN ORGANIZATION THAT
ACTIVATES THE POLITICAL POWER
PEOPLE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY MASS
INCARCERATION.
WE'RE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF A CA
SIX BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE
VOTING IS A FUNDAMENTAL CIVIL
RIGHT AND THAT ALL OF SOCIETY
SUFFERS WHEN PEOPLE ARE UNABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THE REMOVAL OF THE RIGHT TO VOTE
IS NOT BASED IN AN INTEREST IN
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT IN A PUNITIVE
JUSTICE BELIEF SYSTEM THAT
INTENTIONALLY ATTEMPTS TO A ROB
TO ROB MARGINALIZED PEOPLE THEIR
POLITICAL POWER.
WHILE MOST OTHER DEMOCRATIC
COUNTRIES NEVER REMOVE A
PERSON'S RIGHT TO VOTE DO DO A
FELONY CONVICTION THE UNITED
STATES HAS SOME OF THE QUOTE
HARSHEST FELONY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT LAWS IN THE
WORLD ACCORDING TO HUMAN RIGHTS
WATCH.
AND REMAINS THE ONLY DEMOCRACY
IN THE WORLD WHERE A CITIZEN
COULD POTENTIALLY RECEIVE A
LIFETIME BAN FROM VOTING.
THESE RESTRICTIONS PERSISTS
DESPITE THE FACT THE RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT THE HARSHER VOTING
RESTRICTIONS ARE THE HIGHER ARE
THE RATES OF RECIDIVISM.
A STUDY CONDUCTED BY UC BERKELEY
ARGUE THAT FELONY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT QUOTE RESULT
IN ALIENATION AND ISOLATION
WHICH ONLY SERVES TO INCREASE
FURTHER INCIDENCES OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
IF ONE HAS NO STAKE IN HIS OR
HER COMMUNITY THEN ONE HAS
LITTLE INCENTIVE TO BEHAVE IN A
PRO SOCIAL MANNER OTHER THAN TO
AVOID PUNISHMENT.
A SIMILAR SURVEY CONDUCTED BY
INITIATE JUSTICE LAST YEAR OF
MORE THAN A THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
PRISON ON PAROLE CONFIRMS THIS.
86% OF OUR RESPONDENTS SAID THE
VOTING WOULD HELP THEM FEEL MORE
CONNECTED TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
THREE OUT OF FOUR PEOPLE ON
PAROLE DIRECTLY SAID THE VOTING
WOULD HELP THEM STAY OUT OF JAIL.
MUCH OF THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
IS MOVING TOWARD ENDING FELONY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT AND IT'S TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE PART OF
THIS MOMENTUM.
LAST YEAR ALONE STATES SUCH AS
NEW YORK LOUISIANA AND FLORIDA
COLLECTIVELY RESTORED VOTING
RIGHTS TO ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
THIS YEAR'S SUCH STATES SUCH AS
COLORADO NEVADA RESTORED VOTING
RIGHTS TO PEOPLE ON PAROLE AND
EVEN CONGRESS IS CONSIDERING THE
DEMOCRACY RESTORATION ACT WHICH
WOULD ALLOW FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO VOTE IN
FEDERAL ELECTIONS.
NOW CALIFORNIA'S TURN.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ON
PAROLE WHO ARE SHOT OUT OF THE
POLITICAL PROCESS AND THE TIME
HAS COME TO END THIS EXCLUSION.
DEMOCRACY NEEDS EVERYONE
THEREFOREI URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON A CA SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHEN IS A GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS OF SIMILAR MCCARTY
MY NAME IS DARCY BRAND AND I'M
WITHIN YOUR GONNA EITHER WHAT
ALL OF US AND NOT.
ON FOR MCCARTY RATED AND ARMED
CRIMINAL PEROT.
AND JUST PRETTY FR THOSE WHO
ARE NOT FAMILIAR ALL OF US NINE
WHERE A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED.
GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT FORMED BY A
FULL FORM ACROSS RID OF PEOPLE.
WITH THE WITH THE GOAL OF
UNITING AND STRENGTHENING OUR
VOICES ARE VISIBILITY NOW
LEADERSHIP IN OUR COMMUNITIES --
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THOSE
VOICES.
HAVE THOSE VOICES IN UNITED IN
SUPPORT FOR A CA.
SIX I LIKE SOME IN A VOICE NOT
REPRESENT TODAY I HAVE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE.
HOWEVER THERE WAS SOME THIRTY
THREE YEARS AGO -- I WAS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD I REMEMBER
THE DAY -- VERY VIVIDLY I WENT
TO THE POLLS OF MY FATHER -- WE
CAST OUR BALLOTS AND ON THE WAY
HOME.
ON THE DRIVE HOME I REMEMBER THE
LOOK ON HIS FACE I HAD SEEN THAT
LOOK ON YOU KNOW SEVERAL TIMES
BEFORE.
AND IT WAS A LOOK THAT I HAD
SEEN -- WHEN I WHEN I WHEN I
WHEN I WON A SPELLING BEE IN
FOURTH GRADE ARE WHEN I GOT A IN
SEVENTH GRADE AND IN JUNE HIGHER
WHEN I HIT A HOME RUN?
YOU KNOW HE WAS SPROUT.
HE WAS PROUD OF ME.
YOU KNOW -- I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
IT THEN I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY --
BUT I GET IT TODAY ARM SO.
YOU SEE WHEN MY FATHER WAS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD.
IN THE NINETEEN FIFTIES -- HE
FACED A DIFFERENT KIND OF VOTER
SUPPRESSION HE BASS HE FACED A
DIFFERENT LOOKING.
ARE JIM CROW -- BUT MAKE NO TO
MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS THE SAME
JIM CROW WE SEE TODAY IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WHAT
FELONY DISENFRANCHISEMENT.
STOP NO FELONY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT SERVE NO.
IT SERVES NO LEGITIMATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSE IF THERE'S
NO POLITICAL IF THERE'S NO
PUBLIC POLICY -- IF SERVE NO
PUBLIC POLICY PURPOSE.
ON THE NORMAL -- NERVOUS HERE SO
HE GIVES ME A GREAT DEGREE --
CUTTING DISENFRANCHISEMENT THAT
BE JUST ANOTHER TERM FOR VOTER
SUPPRESSION IT ABSOLUTELY SERVE
NO LEGITIMATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSE NO PUBLIC PURPOSE POLICY
NO PUBLIC SAFETY POLICY WHAT IT
DOES FOR VAST IS A SIGN OF POWER
IN THE PRIMITIVE THAT DERIVE
FROM A STRATEGY TO POLITICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
NOW ACCORDING TO THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
PEROT -- PEROT HAS A THREE FOLD
PURPOSE ONE IS THE FIFTH PEOPLE
ON PAROLE WERE PROBLEMS COULD
START EMPLOYMENT RESIDENTS
FINANCES.
AND OTHER PROBLEMS PEOPLE FACE
COMING HOME FROM PRISON NUMBER
TWO PEROT PROTECT SOCIETY
BECAUSE IT THE FIFTH FORM ACROSS
RATED PEOPLE AND GETTING
ACCLIMATED TO COMMUNITIES.
AND PREVENTING FITS A WHITE SAYS
THAT MAKE CALLS ON RECIDIVISM
AND THREE PEROT PREVENTS
NEEDLESS INCARCERATION OF THOSE
WHO ARE NOT LIKELY TO RECEIVE A
VERY.
SO JUST THINK CLOSE I WANT TO
SAY THIS COMMITTEE HAVE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TODAY.
ACTUALLY I BELIEVE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS AN OBLIGATION
TODAY -- TO PROTECT DEMOCRACY.
AND NOT ALLOW THE VESTED OF JIM
CROW TO CONTINUE PRESS OUR
CITIZENS -- I'M A CITIZEN I'M
YOU KNOW I'M TOLD ON THE SET OF
SAN.
I HAVE ALL THE BURDENS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF A CITIZEN.
I'M A TAX PAYING CITIZEN.
YEAH I DON'T HAVE THE SAME
RIGHTS AS A CITIZEN.
I HAVE NO SAY IN ON HOW MY TAX
DOLLARS ARE SPENT I HAVE NO SAY
IN WHAT ELECTED OFFICIAL
REPRESENTS ME MY ISSUES.
ALL MY FAMILY ARE ISSUES OUR
COMMUNITY.
SO YOU KNOW WE ALL AWARE OF THIS
COUNTRY'S HISTORY YOU KNOW THAT
WHICH IS MARKED BY SUCCESSFUL
STRUGGLES -- TO EXPAND THE BODY
RIGHT FROM -- FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS FOR RACE -- GENDER OR
CLASS.
SO.
WHAT I'M SAYING HERE IS THIS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
ON THAT EXPANSION?
WE CAN CONTAIN A BAN ON
EXPANSION TODAY THIS DEATH
COMMITTEE HAVE AN OPPORTUNIST IN
A MESSAGE TO CALIFORNIA'S
INSTEAD OF FROM ACROSS THE
NATION.
THAT VOTING IS THE CORNERSTONE
OF EVERY DEMOCRACY AND THAT WE
WILL NOT STAND. FOR VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
UNDER ANY THIS GUY'S ON ANY
TERMS I SAW HER HIS PANEL OR HER
JUST COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES --
ACA SIX THANK YOU.
NEXT ONE IS.
I'M JUST HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS CANCER GREAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IF ANY MARK ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY ALEX VIDEO I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR REFERS
LEADERSHIP IN THOSE AND WHO ARE
ALSO CO SPONSORS OF THE
LEGISLATION.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU.
DORSEY NON ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN I'M A PROUD CO FOUNDER
OF ALL OF THIS IS NOT.
AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY INCOME IS FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOUR ROSY GIVEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR VOTING RIGHTS FOR A HUNDRED
YEARS THIS IS THE NEWEST FACE OF
SUFFRAGE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT CO
SPONSORS PLEASE SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DOUG TROUBLE INDIVIDUAL
SACRAMENTO AND INDIVISIBLE --
CALIFORNIA SAY STRONG AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RICHARD MORALIS WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE CROP ORGANIZATION COME
ALIVE FROM PAROLE I WOULD LOVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
RACHEL WALLACE PUBLIC POLICY
GRAD STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M JULIE CHAPMAN REPRESENTING
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND
INDIVISIBLE STATE STRONG
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM WINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SOLIDARITY WITH
THE FORMERLY INCARCERATED IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
IMPACT BACKED BY MASS
INCARCERATION.
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU --
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EVER LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY CALIFORNIA.
WERE SUPPORT BILLS LONG OVERDUE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOHN RIEGER STATE CHAIR FOR
PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY WE ARE
AT YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS.
VERONICA HERNANDEZ I'M WITH ALL
OF US ARE NOT AND I'M A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ADAM CAME ON ON BEHALF OF SECURE
DEMOCRACY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALEX WITH UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANKS.
MICHAEL DOES THE POLICY DIRECTOR
WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COLLISIONS FROM SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
A SPONTANEOUS POLICY CORNER FOR
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANKS.
APRIL GRAYSON LIFE COACH FOR THE
ENTIRE RECIDIVISM COALITION IS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I MEAN ELSTER LEGAL SERVICES TO
PRESERVE THE CHILDREN ALL OF US
IN A STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NATASHA MINSKER ON BEHALF OF
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RICARDO WOMAN MEMBER OF A AT
THEIR CITIZEN COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALTHOUGH ROMERO LIFE COACH AT
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
I'M STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
BOB APPEARS MEMBER OF ANTI
RECIDIVISM COLLATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU --
GLADDEN DIRECTOR FREEDOM DRIVE --
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS.
JEAN DAY A MEMBER OF A R. C. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA SIX THANK
YOU.
CAN MORE WITH YOU W. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A CA SIX THANK YOU.
RODNEY BRIGHT A MEMBER OF A CA.
OKAY I SEE I WAS STRUCK SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
JOSH.
JOSH PRODUCTION MEMBER OF A R.
C. IN STRONG SUPPORT THANKS.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FORD
DEALER BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE BOYD WITH INITIATE
JUSTICE AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF
AC SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PAUL BRILEY A POLICY
FELLOW WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN ALL OF
SAID NINE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MYNAME IS JOHN
BURTON GAY I'M WITH A OR SHE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WELL EARLY BIRDS WITH ALL OF
PERSON ON LEGAL SERVICES STRONG
SUPPORT A SEIZURE THANK YOU.
DAMON SO JOHNSON WHAT ALL OF US
AND NONE OF US AND BLACK MAN
SPEAKS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BETTY MCKAY ALL OF US ARE NONE
OF US AND ALSO AS SUGGESTED
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING RENDON WOODS PUBLIC
DEFENDER ALAMEDA COUNTY IN VERY
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LEE TALK WHILE BONNER FORMALLY
INCARCERATED HOUSING ADVOCATE
YOUTH ORGANIZER PUT ORGANIZATION
ALL THE WAS A NINE AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FLAT SHANK HERE WITH IMPACT
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIC ANDERSON FROM
INITIATE JUSTICE PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
C. NOTICE NOTICES IN SUPPORT ANY
TWEENER IS OR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME'S CRAIG CISCO I'M A
CALIFORNIA STATE CITIZEN.
AND WHEN YOU COMMIT A CRIME YOU
LOSE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
THANK YOU STRONG SUPPORT OF NOT.
DOING THIS THING BUT HE
CRIMINALS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SCOTT BUCKLING
BRITAIN I'M WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
AND I'D LIKE TO RETURN THREE
COME ONCE YOU COME ON UP SO YEAH.
THE REGRET COME ON OUT YEAH THAT
WORKS.
PERFECT.
MY NAME IS SUCKLING BRITAIN I'M
WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA I HAVE A COPY
OF THE POSITION PAPERS TO HAND
OUT TO EVERYBODY.
ON THE COMMITTEE.
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA OPPOSES A CA.
SIX A IT SEEKS TO RESTORE VOTING
RIGHTS TO THE MOST FOR WHICH ARE
THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL INVALUABLE
OF AMERICAN PRIVILEGES TO THOSE
WHO HAVE NOT YET COMPLETED
MAKING FULL RESTITUTION FOR
THEIR CRIMES.
IN BREAKING IN A CONTRACT THE
OFFENDER RELINQUISHES HIS RIGHTS
UNDER THE CONTRACT.
THOSE BREAKING THE SOCIAL
CONTRACT RIGHTFULLY SURRENDER
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE CONTRACT
PHYSICAL LIBERTY AND ALL OTHER
RIGHTS OF FREE PERSON. ONE OF
THOSE RIGHTS IS JOINING THE
FELLOW CITIZENS IN THE DECISION
MAKING ACTIVITIES RELEVANT TO A
SOCIETY.
INCLUDING AND ESPECIALLY VOTING.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE CORNERSTONE OF
AMERICAN SOCIAL CONTRACT IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PAY ONCE DEBT TO
ONE SOCIETY AND THEN TO BE ONCE
AGAIN GRANTED FULL PRIVILEGES.
BUT THE FULL DEBT.
AS DETERMINED BY.
BY THE LEGAL STRUCTURE MUST BE
PAID FIRST.
AC A SIX TO RESTORE THOSE VOTING
RIGHTS TO THEM THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL AND VALUABLE OF
AMERICAN PRIVILEGES. TO THOSE
WHO HAVE NOT YET COMPLETED AND
MAKING FULL RESTITUTION TO THEIR
CRIMES.
WHILE ON PAROLE A FORMER
CRIMINALS LIBERTIES SUCH AS
MOVEMENT ASSOCIATION ACTIVITIES --
EVEN OWNERSHIP OF CERTAIN ITEMS
ARE STILL HEAVILY RESTRICTED AND
REGULARLY MONITORED BY THE
SYSTEM.
ANY MISSTEP RESULTS IN THE MEDIA
RICK RE INCARCERATION.
IN OTHER WORDS AN INDIVIDUAL ON
PEARL HAS NOT REGAINED THE FULL
TRUST OF THE SOCIETY AT LARGE.
NOR THE PRIVILEGE OF TO
PARTICIPATE AS A FULL MEMBER OF
THAT SOCIETY.
IT IS AGREED THAT RESTORING
VOTING RIGHTS DURING A PAROLE
MAY SERVE TO GRANT PAROLEES A
SENSE OF PARTICIPATION AND
BELONGING.
AND THUS REDUCE RECIDIVISM THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE FROM WHICH TO
DRAW THAT CONCLUSION.
THE FACT IS COUNTER INTUITIVE A
PERIOD OF PAROLE GIVES A FORMER
CRIMINAL A POWERFUL REMINDER OF
WHAT TRUE LIBERTY IS BY
WITHHOLDING JUST ENOUGH OF IT.
TO BE AN INCENTIVE TO FURTHER
APPROVED APPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR.
THAT IS TO EARN THE RIGHTS JUST
BEYOND THE FINGER TIPS.
SINCE VOTING IS THE MOST
PRECIOUS OF ALL AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES IT SHOULD BE THE LAST
TO BE REGAINED.
THE GREATEST CARROT FOR FULL
RIEN INTEGRATION AND RE
COMMITMENT TO THE SOCIAL
CONTRACT.
PLEASE DO NOT CHEAPEN EVERY
CITIZENS REINFORCEMENT RIBS --
RIEN FRENCH ENFRANCHISEMENT I'M
SORRY BY -- RESTORING IT TO
THOSE WHO HAVE CARELESSLY THROWN
AWAY AND HAVE NOT FULLY RETURNED
IT. TO DO SO WOULD BE DENIGRATE
THE VALUE AN INSULT THE WHOLE
CIVIL SOCIETY ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
URGES A NO VOTE ON A CA SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YES MY NAME IS ROLE RODRIGUEZ
AND I AM CALIFORNIA COORDINATOR
FOR AMERICA FIRST LATINOS.
AND I OPPOSE.
A SEE A 61100%.
OUR CONSTITUTION STATES THAT WE
LIVE A REPUBLIC AND A DEMOCRACY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DIANA BARBA I'M A
CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA I FEEL
THAT THE CONSTITUTION IS BEING.
OVERLOOKED.
THESE PEOPLE MADE A CHOICE WHEN
THEY CHOSE TO COMMIT A CRIME AND
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE THE SAME
RIGHTS UNTIL THAT DEBT IS FULLY
1100% PAID.
FOR SO I DISAGREE WITH THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND HAVE WITNESSES CAN JUST I'VE
BEEN GIVEN YOUR NAME IF YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AN ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THEY CA I'M GLAD
MYERS I AM A VOTER AND A
CONCERNED CITIZEN AND I'M
AGAINST AC.
A SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ROBIN FITS IN WITH THE
REMEMBRANCE PROJECT AND WE URGE
A NO VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PATRICE LINES WITH THE RIP
MEMBERS PROJECT AND I ARE GENOVA
THANK YOU.
STILL IN MAY AND I'M WITH THE
CONCERNED CITIZEN TO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY DISAPPROVE OF THIS AND
URGE PHONE OUT.
UNTIL THE DEBT IS FULLY PAID
THANK YOU.
GOOD CITIZEN THE ARGENEAU VOTE
UNTIL THE DEBT IS COMPLETELY
PAID.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITIONAL BRING BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR MOTIONS ARE SECONDS
[inaudible]
YEAH VENTURE [inaudible]
SO.
YEAH I THOUGHT ABOUT THIS I
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS A LOT WE HAD
THE BILL -- THE STATUTORY CHANGE
EARLIER IN THIS COMMITTEE --
YEAH I WANNA SAY THIS FIRST OF
ALL I BELIEVE IN REDEMPTION 100%
I BELIEVE IN RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
100% I HAVE FAMILY THAT WAS
INCARCERATED.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
BIGGEST THING THAT HELPED THAT
FAMILY MEMBER WHEN HE GOT OUT
WAS GAIN A GOOD JOB.
A PRODUCTIVE JOB WASN'T A THE
HIGHEST PAYING JOB BUT IT WAS A
STAR -- AND HAVING GOOD POSITIVE
PEOPLE AROUND HIM AND A FAMILY
STRUCTURE TO HELP SUPPORT HIM --
THOSE WERE THE THINGS THAT
HELPED HIM GET BACK INTO A
PRODUCTIVE LIFESTYLE MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE I CAN TELL YOU
WANT THEN THE THING THAT HE
NEVER BROUGHT UP WAS.
HEY I NEED TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE RIGHT NOW IN AS AS A PEARLY.
NEVER -- AND YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE
TALKED TO A TALK TO HIM ABOUT
THIS YOU KNOW -- SO.
BUT THOSE ARE THE TYPE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT RESTORED I WANT TO
SAY THIS ABOUT RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE BECAUSE IT GETS USED A
LOT AROUND HERE.
BUT THERE'S THINGS THAT ACTUALLY
WORK -- AND THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT I JUST TALKED ABOUT HAVING
SUPPORT OF STRUCTURES HAVING THE
ABILITY FOR EMPLOYMENT -- IN
THESE ARE THINGS THAT THE STATE
OF TEXAS ACTUALLY HAS DONE A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF OF STARTING
WITH PEOPLE WHILE THEY ARE IN
INCARCERATED.
BUILDING JOB SKILLS AND THEN
HAVING A JOB THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY GO INTO ONCE YOU GET
OUT [inaudible]
A PRISON.
RIGHT OF OF HAVING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH YOUR KIDS WHILE YOU'RE
INCARCERATED.
SO YOU CAN BE A GOOD FATHER THEM
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T HAVE THAT
FATHER HOME.
WHEN YOU WERE GROWING UP THOSE
ARE THE KIND OF THINGS THAT
REALLY MAKES?
IT REALLY HELP RESTORE SOMEONE'S
LIFE AND GET HIM BACK ON THE
RIGHT TRACK HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHAT I SEE MOSTLY IS A LOT OF NO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND JUST LET PEOPLE OUT WITHOUT
THAT.
LET PEOPLE NOT SERVE THEIR FULL
SENTENCES.
RESTORE RESTORE BENEFITS WITHOUT
HAVING THAT ACCOUNTABILITY. ONE
OH NINE HAS DONE THAT WE'VE
ESSENTIALLY JUST WASHED OUR
HANDS IT'S AN PRIMARILY NOT
BECAUSE WE CARE SO MUCH ABOUT
THE PEOPLE THERE INCARCERATED
BUT BECAUSE IT'S EXPENSIVE TO
HOUSE THEM IN STATE PRISON.
AND BECAUSE WE HAVE LAWSUITS AND
WE BASICALLY JUST WASH THEIR
HANDS AND SAID GO ON OUT
HOPEFULLY YOU DON'T VICTIMIZE
PEOPLE AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE SO DON'T
CALL THAT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
YOU KNOW LET'S TALK ABOUT THINGS
THAT REALLY HELP PEOPLE.
GET BACK ON A PRODUCTIVE TRACK I
HAVE.
YOU HAVE A POWERFUL STORY SIR IN
AND WHAT I HEARD IT LAST TIME IT
TOUCH ME IT REALLY DOES AND I
WANT YOU. TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS DEMOCRACY --
BUT YOU DO HAVE TO FINISH.
YOUR FULL TERM AND I THINK POLL
IS PART OF THAT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THIS RULE.
IN PLACE IN THE FIRST PLACE LET
ME SAY SOMETHING ABOUT RESIDENT
RECIDIVISM -- BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAID -- THIS HELPS REDUCE
RECIDIVISM RATES THE ONLY THING
AND THEY POINT TO AS FLORIDA.
AND IN THAT CASE FLORIDA HAD A
PROCESS WHERE YOU HAD TO
PETITION THE GOVERNOR TO GET
YOUR VOTING RIGHTS RESTORED.
AND OUT OF THE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT PETITIONED.
ONLY A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE
ACTUALLY GOT THEIR RIGHTS
RESTORED AND THEY ESSENTIALLY
RESTORED RISE TO PEOPLE WHO HAD
A LOWER.
RISK OF BEING OF OF RE OFFENDING.
AND SO THAT'S NOT REALLY A GOOD.
PULLED TO TAKE FROM AND SAY HEY
THAT THAT'S PROOF THAT IT
REDUCES RECIDIVISM RATES.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE ONLY STUDY
THAT'S BEEN POINTED TO AS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PROCESS
THAN WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHICH IS THIS FOR RESTORATION.
WITHOUT A PETITION ANYBODY
[inaudible]
AND SO.
LOOK I DON'T WE DON'T.
I SEE I I FEEL LIKE WE A LITTLE
BIT UNDERSCORE THIS BECAUSE VERY
POWERFUL STORY AGAIN I BELIEVE.
IN THE ABILITY TO GET.
YOUR RIGHTS BACK AND TO GET BACK
ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
AFTER YOU'VE COMPLETED PAROLE --
BUT LET'S NOT UNDERSCORE WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THESE ARE FELONIES OKAY THAT
INCLUDES MURDER THAT INCLUDES
RAPE THAT INCLUDES SERIOUS
ASSAULTS ON PEOPLE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
OKAY AND SO LET'S NOT UNDERSCORE
IN THE CASE OF MURDER THAT
PERSON NEVER GETS TO VOTE AGAIN
[inaudible]
THEY'RE GONE.
WE DON'T SEE THEM AGAIN THEY
DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS DEMOCRACY.
THAT WAS TAKEN AWAY BECAUSE
WHOEVER THE OFFENDER WAS.
VIOLATED THEIR RIGHTS VIOLATED
OUR LAWS SHOWED NO RESPECT FOR
OUR DEMOCRACY IN OUR IN THE RULE
OF LAW.
IN VIOLATED THE LAW THEY DID DO
THAT.
OKAY SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN RAPED
THEY HAVE THAT FOR THE REST OF
THEIR LIFE.
DOESN'T GO AWAY.
SO THOSE VICTIMS HAVE TO LIVE
WITH THIS STUFF THE REST OF
THEIR LIFE AND AND US REQUIRING
YOU.
TO REQUIRING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN WHO HAVE COMMITTED THOSE
CRIMES. TO BE ACCOUNTABLE AND
PAY A SENSE FOR THAT AND AND
WHILE YOU'RE PAYING THAT
SENTENCE.
THAT YOUR RIGHTS ARE TAKEN AWAY.
SEEMS TO ME TO BE PRETTY
REASONABLE CONSIDERING THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE CRIMES THAT
IMMIGRATED.
IN THE PROCESS THAT WE HAVEN'T
PRAYED PLACE TODAY. TO ME SEEMS
TO BE A PRETTY REASONABLE.
ONE YOU PAY YOUR SENTENCE.
YOU RELEASED ON PAROLE IT'S A
CONDITIONAL RE RELEASE IT
DOESN'T REALLY MEAN OR SENTENCES
OVER.
YOU'VE BEEN RELEASED ON PAROLE
EARLY WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'VE BEEN
RELEASED ON PAROLE YOU HAVEN'T
FINISHED YOUR FULL SENTENCE A
BODY HAS DECIDED WE'RE GOING TO
RELEASE YOU INTO SIT SIT INTO
SOCIETY BEFORE YOUR SENTENCE IS
COMPLETE.
ON CONDITION ON CONDITIONS.
AND WE'RE SAYING HEY IF YOU CAN
MEET THESE CONDITIONS CONTINUE
TO DO THAT THEN YOU'RE FINALLY
RELEASED FROM PAROLE AND YOU ARE
FULLY FREE CITIZEN YOU DON'T
HAVE TO CHECK IN WITH YOUR
PAROLE OFFICER.
YOU KNOW -- THAT'S NOT FREEDOM
SHOULD WE SAY HEY YOU SHOULD NOT
TO REPORT YOUR PRO OFFICER.
I MEAN NOW WE HAVE THESE
CONDITIONS IN PLACE FOR A REASON.
AND WHEN YOUR SENSES COMPLETE
THEN YOU CAN HAVE YOUR RIGHTS
RESTORED AND YOU CAN BE PART OF
THIS DEMOCRACY AND I WANT YOU TO
BE PART OF THIS DEMOCRACY THING
I'M GLAD YOU HAVE THAT DESIRE.
I JUST BUT I JUST I DON'T WANT
IT SEEMS LIKE WE STE WE SORT OF
UNDERSCORE THIS IS NO BIG DEAL
AND THAT WE SHOULD JUST ARE
OBVIOUSLY WE SHOULD DO THIS.
AND THERE'S SOME VERY GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY REASONS FOR NOT
DOING I THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE TO
EARN YOUR WAY BACK TO EARN YOUR
WAY BACK TO TRUST.
INTO FULL RESTORATION OF YOUR
RIGHTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
KNOW AND THAT AND THAT IS REALLY
TO ME THE CRUX OF THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER MSS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- JUST
GOING THROUGH AND READING SOME
OF THE THE ANALYSIS ON THIS THIS
BILL AND SO IT SEEMS.
THAT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY --
THERE'S SORT OF A MIXED BAG --
BUT LOOKS LIKE.
AND BOTH MAINE AND VERMONT --
THERE IS -- THE WHETHER YOU'RE
INCARCERATED OR NOT YOU STILL
HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO BUT
VOTE CORRECT -- AND THEN IT
LOOKS LIKE -- THAT IN TWENTY TWO
STATES FELONS WHO THEY'RE VOTING
RIGHTS DURING INCARCERATION FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME AFTER THAT
TYPICALLY WHILE ON PRO A PAROLE
OR PROBATION.
I STRUGGLE LITTLE BIT WITH THIS
ALL UP I'LL TELL YA BECAUSE I DO
ALSO BELIEVE IN -- WRIT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE -- AND WHEN
I THINK ABOUT THIS FROM A
LOGICAL PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK
ABOUT.
WHAT WHAT IS THE RIGHT TO VOTE
ACTUALLY MEANS AND THE GENTLEMAN
WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT WE ARE
REPUBLICAN NOT A DEMOCRACY I
THINK WE HAVE TO WE CAN'T FORGET
THAT A REPUBLIC IS ACTUALLY?
A FORM OF OF OF OF DEMOCRACY --
THE BUT IT IS STILL A DEMOCRACY --
THE YOU CAN'T FORGET THAT A SORT
OF THE CORE FOUNDING OF OUR OF
OUR CONSTITUTION IS YOU KNOW WE
THE PEOPLE -- AND IT IS -- WE
THE PEOPLE -- THAT ULTIMATELY
ARE ARE THE DECIDER -- THIS
QUESTION THAT COMES BEFORE US --
IS ONE THAT HAS TO BE ANSWERED
CONSTITUTIONALLY A BECAUSE IN
CALIFORNIA -- IT SAYS THAT -- IF
YOU'RE ON PAROLED YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TO VOTE.
BUT YOU'RE ALSO THOUGH -- IF
YOU'RE ON PROBATION YOU ARE
RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW NOT SURE EXACTLY
BECAUSE I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY AND
I'M NOT IN A CRIMINAL LAW BUT
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PROBATION
AND AND AND AND PAROLE OF MAYBE
ONE OF YOU GUYS WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT.
THE THE THE END THE BILL BEFORE
US DUMB.
IS NOT A VOTE TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO OF THOSE WHO ARE ON
PAROLE TO BE ABLE TO VOTE.
THE BILL BEFORE US IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT
WILL ALLOW THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THAT DECISION -- AND FOR THAT
REASON I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS --
EVEN THOUGH I'M NOT SURE WHEN IT
COMES BEFORE ME AT THE BALLOT --
HOW I'M GOING TO BE ABLE TO VOTE
I WOULD LEAN TOWARDS TOWARDS YES
BUT I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE YET
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T GOTTEN THERE I
THINK THAT BECAUSE THIS QUESTION --
IS IS A MIXED BAG ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND I THINK THAT THE
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO VOTE IS SO
POWERFUL BECAUSE AT SOME MOMENT
IN TIME IN HISTORY.
ANY LEGISLATURE CAN DECIDE
VARIOUS THINGS -- ARE ILLEGAL
AND YOU CAN HAVE TO SERVE A
PRISON SENTENCE AND A STRIP YOU
OF THAT ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO TO
VOTE AND NOT HAVE A VOICE IN
YOUR DEMOCRACY -- IS -- IS IS
TOO MUCH FOR US TO BE ABLE TO TO
GIVE AWAY I THINK THIS QUESTION
I'M SHOULD GO BEFORE OF THE
VOTERS -- AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY.
YOU MUST MAYES.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
DR EMOTION OR SECOND WITH THE
BILL I HAVE A MOTION I HAVE A
SECOND -- ANY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE THANK YOU AT THAT'S
ONE TO RESPOND A COUPLE ISSUES
BUT FIRST I WANT TO THANK.
THE CO AUTHORS OF THIS MEASURE
TO WHICH ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE
MISTER MULLIN.
AND AND DOCTOR WEBER AND I THINK
SOMEONE OR MAKE MAYES NAILED IT
THAT WE ALL HAVE A LOT OF
OPINIONS I HAVE AN OPINION.
OUR VICE CHAIR AS AN OPINION ON
THE PUBLIC HAVE AN OPINION WE'RE
NOT DECIDING WE'RE GOING TO DO
TODAY WE'RE DECIDING TO PUT IT
ON THE BALLOT BECAUSE THE STATE
CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE.
CAN'T MAKE THIS CHANGE WE HAVE
TO GO BEFORE THE ELECTORATE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING IS ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC A WEIGH IN.
ON THAT ON THIS ISSUE AND I
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT COURSE TO
DO AT THIS IS THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE NOT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
I'M NOT A PUBLIC SAFETY EXPERT
EITHER BY THINK WANT TO CLARIFY
ONE THING ABOUT PEARL -- PAROLE.
IS IS NOT PUNISHMENT.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN PAROLED
HAD BEEN DEEMED BY THE PAROLE
BOARD THAT THEY IF THEY'RE SAFE
TO RETURN TO SOCIETY THEY SERVE
A NOT FOR THEIR PRISON SENTENCE.
TO TO WARRANT THE PUNISHMENT
THAT WAS BROUGHT UPON THEM BY
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM A PAROLE IS
ABOUT RE INTEGRATING AND
SUPPORTING PEOPLE BACK INTO
SOCIETY AS YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
DEFINITION OF PAROLE.
THIS FITS PERFECTLY WITH THAT A
RE INTEGRATING INDIVIDUALS BACK
INTO THE MAINSTREAM OF SOCIETY
AND SO I WITH THAT I I I AND
MANY OTHERS THINK THIS IS THE
MORALLY RIGHT THING TO DO.
BUT THIS ALSO IS -- IS A SMART
THING TO DO FOR SALE CALIFORNIA
WITH THAT ASK THE RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- THIS MCCARTY.
SO A CA SIX OFFERS ON I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT FORD AND I
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
AND AND THE PUBLIC FOR THE
COMMENTS AND CONVERSATION THAT
WE HAD TODAY -- THIS IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE PEOPLE ARE
GONNA FALL ON DIFFERENT SIDES OF
IT -- YOU KNOW PAROLE IS IS A
PART OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROCESS AND AND WHEN YOU
RELEASED ON PAROLE YOU GET.
CERTAIN RIGHTS BACK AND IT'S
PERFECTLY JUSTIFIABLE FOR US TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION AND FOR THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA TO WEIGH IN
ON WHETHER OR NOT THE RIGHT TO
VOTE SHOULD BE ONE OF THOSE
RIGHTS THAT YOU GET.
BACK -- WHEN YOU'RE RELEASED ON
PAROLE -- I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION FOR THE
STATE TO HAVE I THINK IT'S GREAT.
THAT CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CALIFORNIA VOTERS
SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
HAVE A SAY IN THAT AND AND MAKE
THEIR VOICE HEARD AND THEN WE'LL
FOLLOW WHATEVER THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS ARE AND THAT'S A MARKER
SEE.
SO HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE ACA
TODAY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
I'D GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE LOW.
WELL I MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
SO THAT.
THE BILL HAS A FIVE TO ONE VOTE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AT BUT IT PASSED THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU -- AND NOW I
THINK WE'RE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS.
SO IF ANYBODY'S WATCHING ON TV.
COME ON DOWN TO THE NEXT
CONTESTANT.
IN ROOM -- FOUR FOUR FOUR IT BUT
WE DO HAVE -- AUTHOR BILLS SO
WHY DON'T WE GO IN ORDER.
ALWAYS A CA -- FOR OUR NUMBER
ONE CUSTOMER MULLIN IF YOU LIKE
YOU I AM GOING TO HAND
[inaudible]
THE GAVEL OVER THE VICE CHAIR
AND GO PRESENT A COUPLE OF BILLS
AND SENATE EDUCATION.
THE BE GOOD
THAT WOULD BE STRATEGIC.
RIGHT MISTER MON YOU HAVE ITEM
NUMBER ONE ACA.
FOR THANK YOU.
BYE SHARE MEMBERS VOTER TURNOUT
IN PRIMARY ELECTIONS IS
CONSISTENTLY LOWER.
THAT OBSERVE TURNOUT LEVELS FOR
GENERAL ELECTIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE APPROXIMATELY 50%
OF ELIGIBLE VOTERS PARTICIPATED
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN GENERAL
ELECTION.
WHILE ONLY TWENTY EIGHT POINT
FOUR THREE PART PERCENT
PARTICIPATED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PRIMARY ELECTION.
RESEARCH ALSO INDICATES THAT THE
YOUTH POPULATION HAS THE LOWEST
VOTER TURNOUT.
OUT OF ANY AGE DEMOGRAPHIC THE
TURNOUT FOR ELIGIBLE YOUTH
VOTERS WAS ONLY TWENTY SEVEN
POINT 5% FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
GENERAL ELECTION IN OUR STATE.
ACA.
FOR WOULD CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE FIRST TIME VOTERS AND
BOOST THE YOUTH VOTER TURNOUT.
BY ALLOWING SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
TO VOTE IN THE PRIMARY ELECTION
PROVIDED THAT THEY WILL BE
EIGHTEEN BY THE TIME OF THE
GENERAL ELECTION.
STUDIES SHOW THAT VOTING IS
HABIT FORMING ONCE A PERSON
VOTES HERE SHE IS MORE LIKELY TO
DO SO AGAIN.
EARLY INVOLVEMENT IN THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS FOR FIRST TIME
VOTERS SHOULD BE A HIGH PRIORITY
FOR THIS REASON.
ACA FOR WOULD LAY THE FOUNDATION
TO BUILD THE VOTING HAVE IT AT
AN EARLY AGE ALLOWING SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PRIMARY ELECTIONS.
WOULD COMPLEMENT THE CIVIC
EDUCATION MANY RECEIVE IN HIGH
SCHOOL INCREASING THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THE STUDENTS BECOME A LIFE
LONG VOTERS.
THE IDEA IS NOT A NEW ONE NEARLY
HALF OF STATES IN THE U. S.
ALREADY ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO PARTICIPATE.
IN PRIMARIES AND CAUCUSES FIRST
TIME VOTERS SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT FULL ELECTION CYCLE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE ON STRONG
LEGAL AND CONSTITUTIONAL FOOTING
WITH THIS APPROACH LINKING THE
PRIMARY.
WITH THE GENERAL WITH ME TODAY
TO OFFER ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT.
IT'S BEEN HERE.
OKAY MANY WERE MANY ROMERO
DOCTOR MINDY ROMERO I BELIEVE IS
IN ROUTE -- SHE IS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
PROJECT BASED AT USC HI THERE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE TO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
NAOMI PIPER PAL AND ELLA YET
SAKE TO PROVIDE THE YOUTH
PERSPECTIVE.
OKAY.
WITNESSES A POOR GO AHEAD -- HI
MY NAME'S AMY PIPER PAL AND I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME HERE TO TESTIFY
TODAY ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT TOPIC --
I AM A STUDENT IN THE REAR
AMERICAN OF SABOTAGE PROGRAM
WHICH IS HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE YOUTH COMMISSION.
AND AS A STUDENTS OF TOSSED ICE
STUDY THE POLITICAL PROCESS
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE I'M GLAD I CAN BE HERE
TODAY TO APPLY THE SKILLS
KNOWLEDGE I'VE LEARNED IN THAT
PROGRAM TO PROMOTE YOUTH CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
THE LAST FEW YEARS YOUNG PEOPLE
INCLUDING MYSELF NOT YET OLD
ENOUGH TO VOTE HAVE BECOME
ACTIVE IN THE POLITICAL SCENE.
IF LOBBIED IN TESTIFIED ON
CRITICAL ISSUES INCLUDING
CLIMATE CHANGE HEALTH CARE GUN
CONTROL IN COLLEGE AT THE
MILLIONS AMERICAN YOUTH HAVE
COME TOGETHER TO INFLUENCE THE
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE.
MANY ARE RESTRICTED FROM FOR
PARTICIPATING IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THE MARCH FOR OUR LIVES TO CON
ANTI GUN CONTROL POLITICIANS IN
ORGANIZATIONS OF MANY OF THE
YOUNG ORGANIZER'S AND SPEAKERS
WERE UNABLE TO TAKE THE POLICE
TO THE BALLOT BOX.
IN RESPONSE MANY STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA HAVE
PROPOSED LOWERING THE VOTING AGE
TO SEVENTEEN OR EVEN SIXTEEN
WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF
ASSEMBLY A CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT.
FOR CALIFORNIA COULD JOIN A
GROWING LIST OF STATES THAT
ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS WILL
BE EIGHTEEN BY THE NEXT GENERAL
ELECTION.
IN PRIMARIES IN SPECIAL
ELECTIONS TWENTY THREE STATES
THAT SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS CAN
VOTE IN PRIMARIES AND CAUCUSES
WHETHER THE STATE'S DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLICAN OR SWING THE STATE
LEGISLATURES UNDERSTAND VOTING.
YOUNG HELPS FORM A LIFELONG
HABIT CORNER FAIRVOTE DOT ORG
QUOTE THIS POLICY INCREASES YOU
THINK AGE MEN IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS BY CREATING AN ETHOS OF
PARTICIPATION FROM YOUNGER AGE.
WHAT'S A PERSON VOTES THAT
PERSON IS LIKELY TO VOTE AGAIN.
FOR THE MORE AGE SEVENTEEN MANY
STUDENTS ARE IN THE MIDST OF
STUDYING GOVERNMENTS THEY CAN
APPLY WHAT THEY'VE LEARNED OF
THE POLITICAL PROCESS IN THE
VOTING BOOTH.
WE MUST IMPAIR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF VOTERS FROM
POLITICAL BATTLES THAT LIE AHEAD
AND GIVEN THE POWER OF THE VOTE.
CALIFORNIA USERS ON THE MOST
ENGAGE IN THE COUNTRY AND THEY
DESERVE TO BE ABLE TO EXERCISE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO VOTE.
PASSAGE OF ACA FOR WOULD BE A
GIANT STEP TOWARDS INCREASING
YOUTH CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND
CURRENT EVENTS AND GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE AND I URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELLIOTT SAKE
AND I'M A RISING HIGH SCHOOL
SENIOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS SUMMER I'M WORKING AS AN
INTERN FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND CONGRESSWOMAN JACKIE
SPEAR.
I'VE ALSO WORKED AS AN AS AN
ELECTIONS AMBASSADOR WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF
ELECTIONS -- SO I WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED TO POLITICS IN FIFTH
GRADE -- THE TWENTY TWELVE
ELECTION WAS THE FIRST
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION I COULD
ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND I WAS
COMPLETELY ADDICTED TO
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT I WAS
ADDICTED TO THE DEBATES.
THE CAMPAIGN SPEECHES IN THE
NEWS ABOUT THE CANDIDATES. ONE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ROLLED AROUND MY
LOVE FOR POLITICS ONLY INCREASED
THIS TIME I WASN'T JUST WATCHING
I WAS FORMING MY OWN OPINIONS ON
POLITICS.
I WASN'T JUST HEARING CANDIDATES
TALK ABOUT THE FORD WILL CARE
ACT I WAS FORMING MY OWN STANCE
ON IT.
I WASN'T JUST LISTENING TO
CANDIDATES DEBATE THE PLANTS
TACKLE IMMIGRATION I WAS GETTING
MY OWN PLANTS.
I REACH THIS LEVEL OF INTEREST
IN POLITICS I COULDN'T WAIT TO
GET THE CHANCE TO PROPEL MY
CIVIC DUTY ABOUT.
I ASSUME AT THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY I WOULD GET TO VOTE
IN A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION WOULD
BE IN THE PRIMARY.
I ASSUME THIS I SEND OUT BECAUSE
I WILL BE EIGHTEEN BY THE
GENERAL ELECTION.
I WOULD AUTOMATICALLY BE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE IN THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY I WAS WRONG.
SINCE EIGHTH GRADE I'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING THIS ISSUE
CONNECTING WITH LEGISLATORS ON
IT AND CHATTING WITH DOZENS OF
MY OWN FRIENDS ABOUT HOW THIS
ISSUE AFFECTS SO MANY OF US.
I WAS ABLE TO LEARN THAT AROUND
HALF THE COUNTRY IS ALREADY
PASSED THIS INTO LAW THAT FEW
LEGISLATORS OPPOSE IT AND THAT
MANY OF MY FRIENDS AND
CLASSMATES ARE JUST AS
FRUSTRATED AS I AM ABOUT IT.
NOW IS A RISING SENIOR I HOPE
THAT STUDENTS AFTER ME WILL GET
THE CHANCE TO VOTE IN THE
PRIMARY REGARDLESS OF THE
SPECIFIC MONTH AIRBORNE AND WE
AS A STATE SHOULD ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO VOTE
ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE.
IN ORDER TO INSTILL THE VALUE OF
VOTING IN THE NEXT GENERATION WE
MUST ALLOW THEM TO HAVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO LET THEIR VOICES
BE HEARD.
THIS IS WHY I ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER STUDENTS ARE FIGHTING FOR
AC.
FOUR WE'RE NOT FIGHTING TO
CHANGE THE VOTING AGE PER SE BUT
RATHER TO ADJUST THE VOTING
SYSTEM TO BE MORE FAIR AND
COMPREHENSIVE FOR STATE'S NEWEST
MOTORS.
THANK YOU.
WELL I DON'T KNOW WHEN I CAN
REALLY ADD BEYOND THAT.
YOU BOTH THAT AT ALL AND THE
WELL I'M SO I MEAN YOU REMEMBER
ON THE DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA
THAT THEY CAN GET YOUR PROJECT
AND NOW YOU WITH THE IN
SACRAMENTO -- I THINK WHAT ALL
ADDED FIRST OF ALL AT THE OUT
THAT SAY THAT -- MY RESEARCH
CENTER WE DON'T FORMALLY TAKE
POSITIONS ON BILLS BUT I'M HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
RESEARCH IN THE FIELD ARE
RESEARCH.
I SAID THAT -- ON THIS TOPIC IN
IN IN IN WITH THE HELP THAT'LL
HELP INFORM YOUR DECISIONS TODAY.
SO -- YOU'VE HEARD THE NUMBERS
THE STATE OF CIVIC -- ACTUALLY
VOTER PARTICIPATION SPECIFICALLY
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IS LOW I WILL
GO OVER THOSE AGAIN BUT WHAT WE
DO KNOW IS THAT.
THERE ARE THERE ARE WAYS TO
REMEDY THAT -- A KEY PREDICTOR
KEY SOLUTION TO GETTING YOUNG
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE HELPING
THEM TO TO PARTICIPATE.
IS TO HELP HEM MAKE THAT
CONNECTION TO WHY VOTING MATTERS
TO FOR THEMSELVES FOR THEIR
LIVES THEIR COMMUNITIES.
MY THE ACTUAL ACT OF VOTING WHAT
THE OUTCOME OF THAT REALLY IS
WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS RIGHT
WITH ISSUE WHEN YOU'RE
COMPLETELY NEW TO THE TO THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS.
AND SO -- RESEARCHED AS
SUGGESTED NOT DIRECTLY LEAST
INDIRECTLY THAT -- A BILL LIKE A
CA FOR VOTING IN THE PRIMARY --
CAN HELP MAKE THAT CONNECTION.
RIGHT SO IT FOR ALL THE REASONS
OVER THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DISCUSSED -- BOTH IN THE PRIMARY
BUT IN THE GENERAL WHEN YOU KNOW
VOTING IN GENERAL WHEN YOU KNOW
THAT YOU'VE HAD -- A SE -- AND
THERE IS BY AND AND IN THAT
INCOMPLETE ELECTION CYCLE CAN
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE.
ALSO.
AS LONG AS THERE ARE PROPERLY
IDENTIFIED -- AS AS THE ELIGIBLE
VOTERS IN THAT PRIMARY ROUTE WE
CAN ASSUME THAT THEY'RE GONNA
GET CONTACTED BY CANDIDATES AND
GET CAMPAIGN MATERIALS AND
THAT'LL REALLY MATTERS BECAUSE
SPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE.
GAINING FAMILIARITY WITH THE
PROCESS.
MAYBE THE FIRST TIME MAYBE IT
THE SECOND TIME YOU GET THOSE
MATERIALS AND YOU GET THAT
CONTACT IS OUT WHICH IS ALWAYS
VERY VERY LOW TO YOUNG PEOPLE --
BACK ALSO CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
TO MAKING IT FAMILY AND ALSO
JUST REMIND THEM THAT THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS IS IMPORTANT.
LASTLY ALL ADD.
I IN CALIFORNIA ALREADY THE LAW
IS PRE REGISTRATION OF SIXTEEN
AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS RIGHT AS
YOU ALL KNOW.
AND I THINK THERE'S A REAL
POTENTIAL HERE THAT THIS LAW
COULD SUPPORT BE KEY SUPPORT. TO
PRE REGISTRATION EFFORTS SO IT'S
ALREADY BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
HUNDRED THAT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PRINTER SECRETARY
STATE OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
THAT HAVE REGISTERED -- BUT WE
KNOW THAT THERE STILL IS THE
QUESTION.
BY THE TIME THEY TURN EIGHTEEN I
WILL THEY WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE STILL MOTIVATED AND
THAT THERE THAT TO PARTICIPATE
THAT THEIR WHERE REMEMBER THAT
THEY WERE REGISTERED.
AND POTENTIALLY VOTING IN THAT
PRIMARY COULDBE A KEY CONNECTOR
IF YOU WILL -- AND BE AN
ADDITIONAL MOTIVATING FACTOR FOR
VOTING BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY FOR
REGISTERING -- ESPECIALLY GIVEN
OF MAYBE REGISTER JUST BEFORE
THE PRIMARY RIGHT INTO BECAUSE
YOU'RE ELIGIBLE OR SOMEWHERE
NEAR AROUND THAT PRIMARY.
SO -- I THINK THERE'S A REAL
POSSIBILITY HERE NOT ONLY IN
TERMS OF INCREASING.
POTENTIAL INCREASING PROTECT.
JUST ABOUT PARTICIPATION IN
VOTER TURNOUT LEVELS BUT ALSO
JUST MAKING THE VOTING PROCESS
MORE SALIENT VOTING IS HABIT
FORMING WE WANT TO MAKE THAT A
SOLID RELEVANT.
PROCESS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AS
EARLY AS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KAELIN DEAN WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AND POLICY LINK IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A CA.
FOR DOOR ROSALIE GIVEN VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEX BEFORE WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CITY WHEREVER SACRAMENTO IT IS
INDIVIDUAL AND SUPPORT IN
REGISTERED SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS LATELY FOR YEARS SO
LONG AS IT'S NO GENERAL ELECTION.
JOHN RIEGER STATE CHAIR FOR
PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY OUR
PARTY HAS NOT TAKEN A POSITION
ON THIS BUT WE'VE ALWAYS
SUPPORTED YOUNGER VOTERS.
AND I'M SPEAKING FOR MYSELF
URGING YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY.
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION.
MY NAME'S GREG GALLON I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF CHILDREN VOTING.
WHO DON'T HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF RENT FOOD?
AND PAYING TAXES.
ROLL RODRIGUEZ AMERICA FIRST
LATINO COORDINATOR FOR
CALIFORNIA.
IN OPPOSITION.
THESE ARE IN MATURE [inaudible]
STUDENTS YOUNG.
INDIVIDUALS THAT DON'T.
HAVE ANY ABILITY TO VOTE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE VOTING POWER?
THANK YOU.
I'M OPPOSED I UNDERSTAND THESE
WOMEN ARE THESE YOUNG WOMEN HAVE
PRESENTED THEMSELVES VERY WELL
BUT THEY HAVE LEARNED HOW TO
VOTE IN HIGH SCHOOL AND LESS THE
TEACHERS AREN'T DOING THEIR JOB.
SO NAY NO -- CAN I GO UP TO THE
TAPE YEAH YOU CAN YOU CAN
APPROACH IF.
AGAIN MY NAME IS A COALING
BRITAIN I'M WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
AND WE OPPOSE BOTH A CA FOR AN
A. C. A..
EIGHT ACA FOR SIX TO ALLOW
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO CAST A
VOTE IN THE PRIMARY ELECTION IF
THEY WILL BE EIGHTEEN BY THE
FOLLOWING GENERAL ELECTION.
ACA BUT ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO VOTE PERIOD.
OF THEY ARE LEGALLY MINORS OF
ADD TO THAT TO THE FACT THAT OF
THAT EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS ARE
ALMOST ALWAYS IN HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATING.
BY NOVEMBER OF OKAY LET ME START
OVER AGAIN I LET'S TRY THIS
AGAIN HERE.
OKAY A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD OUR
LEGAL MINORS AND THAT DEFINITION
AND THEY ARE STILL CONSIDERED
CHILDREN.
THEY ARE ALMOST ALWAYS STILL
LIVING AT HOME WITH UNDER THE
STRONG INFLUENCE OF THEIR
PARENTS AND THIS IS NOT
CONDUCTIVE TO INDEPENDENT
THOUGHT.
AND VOTING WITHOUT UNDUE
PRESSURE FROM THEIR IMMEDIATE
SUPERIORS.
SITUATION IS EXACERBATED BY THE
FACT THAT OVER 75% OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS ARE VOTING
WITH MAIL IN BALLOTS.
AND THAT THE SAME PERCENTAGE
WOULD LOGICALLY APPLY TO
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS WOULD BE
VOTERS.
THEREFORE THESE CHILDREN WITH
THE MAKING THEIR BALLOTS AT
MARKING YOUR BALLOTS AND HOME
WHAT PLATE PROBABLY UNDER THE
DIRECT ASSISTANCE OF ADULTS.
AND THEIR ENVIRONMENT AND THEY
WOULD BE GUARANTEED.
AND THAT WOULD NOT BE GUARANTEED
THE FREEDOM TO VOTE
INDEPENDENTLY AND EXPRESS THEIR
OWN CONSCIENCE.
THE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS WILL
ALMOST ALWAYS BE A STILL IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND UNDER STRONG
INFLUENCE OF THEIR TEACHERS.
THIS WILL AGAIN MAKE IT LESS
LIKELY THAT THEY WOULD BE
EXPRESSING THEIR OWN
INDEPENDENTLY THOUGHT OUT
CHOICES.
THAT THEY WILL.
BE ALLOWED TO VOTE.
NOW THAT CALIFORNIA HAS MOVED
ITS PRIMARY DATE TO EARLY MARCH
THERE ARE EIGHT MONTHS BETWEEN
THE PRIMARY AND THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
CONSIDERING MATURATION THAT CAN
BE PLACED CAN TAKE PLACE IN THAT
AMOUNT OF TIME FOR PEOPLE IN
THEIR LATE TEENS.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
CAN BE ASTONISHING ANY PARENT OF
A HIGH SCHOOL OR HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER CAN VERIFY THAT TRUTH.
ADDING TO THE STRING OF
OPPOSITION TO A CA.
FOR ADD TO THAT THE FACT THAT
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS WILL ALMOST
ALWAYS BE IN HIGH SCHOOL THE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES BY THE BY
NOVEMBER.
EITHER BEGINNING THEIR TWO TO
EARN THEIR WAY IN THE WORLD ARE
BEGINNING TO PREPARE FOR A
FUTURE CAREER BI VOCATIONAL
TRAINING OR ENROLLMENT IN AN
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER LEARNING.
THIS ENTRANCE INTO REAL LIFE
CREATES A SOBERING AND MATURING
AFFECT THAT SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
WILL NOT HAVE EXPERIENCED.
MOST WILL SEE THE WORLD
DIFFERENTLY MORE RESPONSIBLY AND
WILL FEEL MORE EXPERIENCED.
MOST WILL SEE THE WORLD OF OKAY
WHAT MORE OWNERSHIP OF THEIR OWN
LIVES AND THEIR POLITICAL
DECISIONS THAT AFFECT THEM.
ONLY WHEN PEOPLE REACH THAT
STAGE CAN NAY CAST AN EDUCATED
VOTE.
THERE ARE NO LEGITIMATE REASONS
TO EXTEND THE VOTING RIGHT TO
LEGALLY TO MINORS AND MANY
SCIENTIFIC AND LOGICAL REGION'S
REASONS NOT.
TO I WOULD LIKE TO ADD A COUPLE
PERSONAL THOUGHTS OF I
REGISTERED TO VOTE.
OF IN THE DAYS OF THE ALBATROSS
WHEN I WAS.
TWENTY ONE THAT WAS THE VOTING
AGE THEN -- DURING THE VIETNAM
WAR THEY LOWERED THE VOTING AGE.
TO EIGHTEEN AND THE REASON FOR
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS THAT WERE
DRAFTED INTO THE ARMY -- M. WERE
RISKING THEIR LIFE AND LIMB FOR
OUR COUNTRY SO OF COURSE THEY
THEY DESERVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
AFTER THE WAR THAT THAT EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD AGE SO STOOD.
BUT NAY EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS NOW
ARE MOSTLY LIVING AT HOME
THEY'RE GOING TO SCHOOL THEY'RE
NOT EARNING A LIVING.
PAYING TAXES AND AND ASSIDUOUS
FULL CITIZENSHIP SO I'VE I THINK
IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE TO GO EVEN
LOWER AND WE JUST RECENTLY.
OF RAISE THE AGE FROM. EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY ONE FOUR OF THE
PURCHASE OF TOBACCO AN OF LIQUOR
AND OTHER THINGS SO I I YOU KNOW
WE'RE SAYING WE'RE SAYING TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS HERE.
ARE THEY ARE THEY OF RESPONSIBLE
ENOUGH TO TO VOTE OR THEY WOULD
NOT IT RESPONSIBLE ENOUGH TO
TAKE.
OF CARE OF THEIR YOU KNOW OF
PURCHASES OF TOBACCO AND THINGS
SO I JUST YOU KNOW WE JUST WEIRD.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE SUB THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM -- ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION JUST NAME AND AND
POSITION AND OUT AND WATCH THAT
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
YES MY NAME STAFF COMPANION
EVERYTHING THE CALLING JOE SAYS.
I HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH.
WHERE WE LIVE IN A STATE?
WHERE THEY DON'T WANT CHILDREN?
A LOT OF COLLEGE HE ALSO A YOUNG
ADULTS THE DRINK UNTIL THEY'RE
TWENTY ONE YOU CAN'T GET MARRIED
TILL YOU'RE EIGHTEEN OKAY WHY
WOULD YOU ALLOW SOMEONE THAT IS
OVER OPPOSITION [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE YOUNG ADULT.
NUMBER ONE I GOT A JOB ALL THE
CAR REALLY OLD ANYTHING OF THE
ROLE OKAY YEP THEY'RE GOING TO
MAKE DECISIONS FOR THE TAXPAYERS
WITH PEOPLE AFTER WORK AND RAISE
A FAMILY.
I DON'T THINK SO OKAY THANK YOU
SIR.
SO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY MAY
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS.
WE'VE ALREADY DONE TESTIMONY
FROM BOTH SIDES SO NOW WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET UP YOU TO
STATE YOUR NAME AND THAT YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL OKAY.
ROBIN VETS DONE THE REMEMBRANCE
PROJECT ORIGINAL VOTE.
PATRICE LINE'S PARENT HIGHER
GENOVA.
STELLAR MAY STRONGLY.
OF AGREE WITH ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CAN STRONGLY OPPOSE SO
VOTE NO PLACE.
TIM MCMANUS STRONG OPPOSITION.
QUINN MIRED IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
LEE MEANT TO BURY A RESOUNDING
NO.
AVERAGE CITIZEN JUST SAY NO.
OKAY.
OF SCENE OF FURTHER OPPOSITION --
BRING IT BACK COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS -- YES MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER MALL AND FOR AUTHORING
THIS A CA I WANNA THINK STUDENTS
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I THINK YOUR
PROFESSED TO WHY YOU'RE CAPABLE
OF DOING THIS.
AND I REALLY IT REALLY
FRUSTRATES ME WHEN I HEAR
ARGUMENTS THAT WE'RE BECAUSE OF
OUR AGE BECAUSE OF YOU BEING
YOUNG YOU'RE INCAPABLE OF MAKING
A DECISION.
LIKE THIS IT IS -- AN ACCURATE --
YOU KNOW.
I HEN I GOT WHEN I DECIDED RUN
FOR OFFICE I WAS -- TWENTY FIVE
WHEN I START MY CAMPAIGN I GOT
ELECTED JUST AFTER I TURNED
TWENTY SEVEN AS A PERSONAL ANY
OVER LIKE TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
APPARENTLY ONLINE I WAS.
ABOUT MY OWN HISTORY.
I WAS THE FIRST MILLENNIAL EVER
ELECTED TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE
AND I CURRENTLY SERVE AS YOUNG
AS MAJORITY LEADER IN HISTORY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA EVEN
THEN WHEN I RAN ICE I RECEIVED
THE SAME ARGUMENTS THAT I WAS
TOO YOUNG AND CAPABLE OF SERVING
IN THE POSITION.
THAT I AM IN BUT YET THAT HASN'T
STOPPED ME FROM CONTINUING TO BE
REELECTED NOW SERVING.
IN MY SEVENTH YEAR IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE I GREW UP WITH A
FAMILY THAT WAS POLITICALLY
ACTIVE IT WAS.
AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO REGISTER
TO VOTE I VOTED IN EVERY SINGLE
ELECTION EVER SINCE THEN AND IT
HAS MOTIVATED TO STAY ENGAGED TO
PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT'S GOING ON
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D EVER RUN FOR
POLITICAL OFFICE BUT THE MORE I
LEARN THE MORE I WAS ENGAGED TO
MORE AYE VOTE IN.
THE MORE I KNEW THAT MY
PERSPECTIVE IN MY GENERATIONS
VIEW WAS NOT BEING REPRESENTED
IN GOVERNMENT AND IT IS BECAUSE
OF THAT.
LACK OF PARTICIPATION BY OUR
GENERATION IS THE REASON WHY
WE'RE IN REALLY IN MY OPINION
SUCH A TERRIBLE POSITION TODAY
LOOK AT OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
LOOK AT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
RUNNING OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IT'S A DISASTER AN ABSOLUTE
DISASTER.
AND IT ISN'T AND IT ISN'T
BECAUSE OF ANYTHING ELSE OTHER
THAN THE FACT THAT THESE PEOPLE
HAVE JUST BEEN THERE FOR TOO
LONG AND THEY THINK THAT THEY'RE
THE ONLY ONES THAT MATTER
THEY'RE THE ONLY VOICES THAT
MATTER.
WHEN WE'RE GENERATION AS COSTLY
BEEN TOLD YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT
SMART ENOUGH YOU CAN PARTICIPATE
YOU JUST LISTENING TO WHAT
YOU'RE TOLD?
AND I DISAGREE WITH THAT I THINK
THAT THAT IS WHY WE ARE SUCH AN
IN SUCH A TOUGH PLACE AS A
COUNTRY THE ONLY WORK WAY WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE THAT.
AND RECTIFY THE RECTIFY THE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN THIS
COUNTRY IS BY HAVING A
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE NEXT
GENERATION THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GONNA BE FORCED TO LIVE UNDER
THAT THE POLICIES.
THAT ARE BEING PASSED TODAY
BECAUSE WE ON THOUGH IN THIS
BUILDING.
THE ONLY PASS SOMETHING THE
IMPACT IS AND ALWAYS IMMEDIATE
THE IMPACT THIS FIVE TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS DOWN THE THAT WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A VOICE.
IN THAT AND THE IDEA THAT WE
DON'T PAY TAXES APPARENTLY
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS
ARE WORKING ALL THE TIME AND
AGAIN THE PERMISSIVE SCHOOL
AGAIN -- OKAY BY THE MOTHER THAT
THEIR PARENTS IN ORDER TO WORK
ACTUALLY NO. FIFTEEN A SIX YEAR
OLDS ARE WORKING THEY'RE PAYING
PAYROLL TAXES THIS IS WHY YOU'RE
TRUMP OR THEY'RE PAYING PAYROLL
TAXES.
AND THEY'RE PAYING SALES TAXES
AND SO THIS IS ABSOLUTE NONSENSE.
THIS IS.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING
THIS IS THIS IS THE BOTTOM.
THERE'S ABSOLUTE LONGBOTTOM THE
GALLERY FOR OUR COUNTRY AND IT
ALL STARTS HERE THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO CHANGE IT
WAS BY GETTING A NEW PERSPECTIVE
FROM A NEW GENERATION. TO GET IN
THERE AND VOTE AND SO I AM PROUD
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS I AM
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF ACA.
EIGHT AND LOOK FORWARD TO MAKING
SURE THAT THIS GETS TO WHERE IT
NEEDS TO GO TO GET PAST THANK
YOU RESPECT LAST NIGHT BUT THANK
YOU MISTER CALDERON OKAY.
WE ALL SAY THINGS IN HERE THAT
OUR OPINIONS SOMETIMES WE DON'T
LIKE WHAT THE OTHER PERSON IS
SAYING WE WE CAN BE UPSET ABOUT
THAT BUT WE RESPECT PEOPLE'S
RIGHT TO SPEAK.
AND SO.
EVERYBODY'S BEEN GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY GIVE TESTIMONY TO
GET UP.
YOU KNOW AND SO WHEN OTHER
MEMBERS ARE GIVING THEIR
OPINIONS ON THE BILL.
I ASKED YOU GIVE THEM THE THE
EQUAL RESPECT THAT EVERYBODY
ELSE HERE GAVE.
YOU IN THE AUDIENCE AS WELL.
MR MAYES.
ABOUT WELL THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR -- I MEAN.
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS TODAY -- AND
BEN ALL GIVE THE REASONS WHY I
ACTUALLY WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE MISTER CALDERON --
HE WAS -- OUT MUCH MORE TALENTED
THAN HI HE GOT ELECTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE AT TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SEVEN I WAS
ELECTED -- TO THE CITY COUNCIL
WHEN I WAS A TWENTY FIVE AND SO
I GOT I WAS VERY YOUNG AND VERY
ENGAGED IN.
THE PROCESS -- EARLY ON ACTUALLY
A GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL A
MONTH AFTER MY SIXTEENTH
BIRTHDAY SKIPPED A COUPLE OF
GRADES -- SO I WAS DONE I WAS IN
COLLEGE -- AT SIXTEEN YEARS OLD
AMID FINISHED ON MY FIRST TWO
YEARS BEFORE I HAD -- BECOME
EIGHTEEN I THINK I HAD WHEN I
WAS SIXTEEN OR SEVENTEEN YEARS
OLD I THINK I HAD THE SMARTS --
TO BE ABLE TO A TO VOTE AND YET
I WASN'T -- EIGHTEEN THE REASON
I'M NOT SUPPORTED THIS TODAY
FACT I'VE BEEN DEBATING BACK AND
FORTH IN MY IN MY HEAD ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE THIS IDEA OF OF THE
PRIMARY AND THE PRIMARY --
KNOWING THAT YOU'RE GOING INTO
THE GENERAL -- AND YET I THINK
THERE MIGHT BE A BIT OF A
SLIPPERY SLOPE -- THAT'S THAT'S
THERE BECAUSE ONCE YOU'RE
BEGINNING TO VOTE IN A IN A
PRIMARY AT SEVENTEEN WILL THEN
WHY NOT BE ABLE TO VOTE IN THE
GENERAL -- AT AT SEVENTEEN AND I
THINK I STRUGGLE WITH A LOT OF
OUR ARE THESE THE THE THIS
QUESTION OF OF THE AGE OF OF
MAJORITY -- AND WHEN YOU ARE
ABLE TO SIGN A CONTRACT AND IT'S
LEGALLY BINDING -- WHEN YOU'RE
ABLE TO GO INTO THE MILITARY --
YOU KNOW WITHIN SAID -- WHEN YOU
CAN BUY A PACK OF CIGARETTES?
WHEN YOU CAN A DRINK ALCOHOL ALL
OF THAT IS AT THE AGE OF?
TWENTY ONE I THINK IN THIS
COUNTRY WE NEED TO HAVE A A A A
A REAL DEBATE ABOUT WHAT IS THE
AGE OF MAJORITY I'M NOT SURE
THAT THAT AGES -- EIGHTEEN MAYBE
IT'S TWENTY ONE BUT YET WE ARE
PRETTY SCHIZOPHRENIC AND HOW WE
THAT WE WE DECIDE WHEN YOU CAN
DO ONE THING OR OR THE OTHER --
AND FOR THAT REASON -- I AM NOT
GOING TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS --
THE TODAY -- I THINK EIGHTEEN IS
WHAT THE FEDERAL RULES ARE I
THINK WE TO BE PRETTY CONSISTENT --
A WITH THAT -- I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE SOME BUT SIXTEEN YEAR
OLDS -- SOME FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS --
THAT HAVE THE CAPACITY AND THE
THOUGHT TO BE ABLE TO DEVOTE AND
YET THEY HAVEN'T YET READ THE
REACH THAT AGE DID THAT LEGAL
AGE OF OF MAJORITY.
AND I THINK UNTIL YOU GET THERE --
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE -- TO TO BE ABLE TO BE OF
TO VOTE.
HELLO.
YES THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
HAD A QUESTION IF IF I MIGHT GO
THROUGH THE CHAIR YEAH -- TO IS
IS IT LINDA THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT WELL I'M
CALLING BRITAIN THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WAS JUST --
I WANTED TO ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
A WITH RESPECT TO THE LETTER IN
YOUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY WITH THE
PRESENTS BUT WITH RESPECT TO
TAXATION.
ABOUT TEENS NOT PAYING TAXES IT
WAS THAT WAS THAT PART OF THAT
STATEMENT THAT YOU HAD MADE AS
WELL.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I DON'T THINK
THAT WAS IN OUR STATEMENT.
OKAY DO IT THERE I USED TO TEACH
A AMERICAN GOVERNMENT DOES THIS
NOTION ABOUT AND NO TAXATION
WITHOUT REPRESENTATION DO YOU
BELIEVE IN THAT SIMILAR KIND OF
PHILOSOPHY YES ABSOLUTELY ENDS
SINCE -- AT SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD
AND SEVEN YEAR OLDS -- ARGUABLY
PAY PAYROLL TAXES -- THEY'RE
WORKING AT MCDONALDS OR YEAH
YEAH JOSH SHARED IMPROPERLY IN
FACT ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
RESEARCH BROWN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS.
A PAGE FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN PAYROLL TAXES A SIMILE SUCH
THEY WOULD GO TO FILL UP AT THE
PUMP JUST AS WE ALL DO IMPAIR
GAS TAX OR IF THEY GO TO A STORE.
THERE'S A SALES TAX PHONE NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT VARIETY OF ISSUES.
TAXATION WITHOUT REPRESENTATION
YOU INDICATED THAT YOU BELIEVE
IN THAT PHILOSOPHY WHY THAT
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT IN THE STINGS
DISTINCTION HERE AS WE'VE
ARTICULATED.
ALL WELL FOR ONE THING OF
CHILDREN ARE YOUNG YOUNGER THAN
EIGHTEEN ARE USUALLY LIVING AT
HOME OKAY OUT SO THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF HOME
OWNERSHIP OR MONTHLY FRENCH AND
ALL THOSE THINGS THEY'RE THEY'RE
WORRIED ABOUT JUST.
YOU KNOW -- OF WHAT HE COLLEGE
DEBT OF DISCRETIONARY INCOME
THAT THEY MAKE IT.
A PART TIME JOB WHETHER IN
SCHOOL SO IT'S NOT SAME
RESPONSIBILITY.
AS OF AS THE HEAD OF A FAMILY OR
HOUSEHOLD ARE LIVING ON THEIR
OWN EVEN WHEN THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR RENT.
FOOD AND CLOTHING AND AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES WITH
IT HEALTH CARE.
ALL THOSE THINGS SO THAT'S IS
VERY LIMITED IT WHEN YOU'RE WHEN
YOU'RE EIGHTEEN SO DOES A LOT OF
INDICATIONS THAT THE IN YOUR
MIND AS YOU'VE TESTIFIED SO I
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
POSITION THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
REPRESENTING THE ORGANIZATION.
IS SUCH THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
THE THRESHOLD SHOULD BE THAT OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR EXAMPLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP SHOULD BE
ADDITIONAL QUALIFICATION NOW I'M
NOT SAYING I'M NOT SAYING THAT
BUT IS CERTAINLY IT YOU KNOW OF
BEING A HEAD OF A HOUSEHOLD YOU
HAVE.
OTHER RESPONSIBILITIES EVEN IF
YOU'RE LIVING ON YOUR OWN YOU
HAVE MORE.
REAL LIFE RESPONSIBILITIES
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR YOURSELF.
AND UP SO THE SHORT END THIS IN
THIS ENVIRONMENT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN EIGHTEEN IT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO HAVE OWN
HOMEOWNERSHIP AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN IN FACT I FIND MYSELF
AT THE AGE OF THIRTY SIX IN
WHICH I SERVED AS MAYOR FOR CITY
I CANNOT AFFORD.
A SINGLE FAMILY HOME IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT I GREW UP IN --
SO I DO NOT THERE I AM NOT
THERE'S NO HOME OWNERSHIP FROM
MY END AND I'M THIRTY SIX LITTLE
INCHING.
RAN YES EMIGRATE EVER SO SO SO
IN THAT CASE AGAIN I'M JUST
TRYING TO BEST UNDERSTAND THE
VANTAGE POINT THAT YOU'RE HAVING
A SUGGESTING WITH RESPECT.
TO THE DEFINITION OF ONE THAT
HAS THE QUALIFICATIONS TO
EXERCISE THE RIGHT TO VOTE EVEN
THOUGH THE PAYING TAXES SO AGAIN
NO TAXATION WITHOUT RESERVATION
IS SOMETHING THAT YOU A BOOK
BELIEVED IN RATS ONE PART OF IT
THAT'S CERTAINLY ONE PART OF IT
I THINK THE AGE OF JUST.
OF DISCRETION OR WHERE THEY CALL
THAT WERE IN YOUR DEFINITION OF
DEFINITION OF BEING A LIKE
ALTURAS ALTA YEAH THERE I THINK
THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF DELTA
FOR YOU THAN FOR FROM THE
ORGANIZATION IS A SHOULD BE WHAT
AGE NOW I WE HAVE NO DEFINITION
OF ADULTHOOD.
YOU KNOW OKAY SO IT IN OTHER
WORDS I'M JUST TRYING TO BEST US
UNDERSTAND THE POSITION THAT
YOU'RE IN THAT YOU'RE PRETTY
THAT YOU'RE PRESENTING TO BEST.
ARTICULATE THAN WE'VE HEARD THAT
THESE ARE CHILDREN AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE TYPE OF ABILITIES
ARE VERY WONDERFUL CHILDREN AND
VERY ENGAGE CHILDREN I WON'T
ARGUE THAT -- AND AND I I ADMIRE
ALL THAT THEY'RE DOING AND THERE
AND INVOLVEMENT IN THIS.
I AM THRILLED TO DEATH THAT
THEY'RE EXCITED ABOUT POLITICS
AND THEY WANT TO GET INVOLVED IN
GOVERNMENT I THINK THAT'S THE
BEST THING EVER I'M I'M THRILLED
TO DEATH ABOUT THAT.
BUT BE PATIENT.
UP BE PATIENT JUST A LITTLE BIT
FEW MORE MONTHS AND YOU'LL BE
THERE AT EIGHTEEN AND GO FOR IT.
MISTER IF I JUST MIGHT SUMMARIZE
THEN OUT.
I'VE I PRESS ONE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT BECAUSE WILL WILL MEET WE
HAVE THIS NOTION WE HEARD ON
MUCH TESTIMONY THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
DO NOT PAY TAXES BUT LET'S JUST
BE FACTUAL GOT A SEVEN YEAR OLD
SHOULD PAY PAY TAX THEY WORK.
AND IN FACT IN MY COMMUNITY I
HAVE SEEN FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN
YEAR OLDS.
WHO HAVE PATENTS PENDING NOT
BECAUSE OF THEIR ABILITY?
TO ARTICULATE AN ISSUE AND HAVE
A SENSE OF THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
SO I JUST THINK THAT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
INDIVIDUALS AT A YOUNGER AGE TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE THE
PROCESS AND HAVE A SAY.
A SPECIFICALLY BUT AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD
THE FAX.
DISCUSSED WITH RESPECT TO THE
TYPE OF ENGAGEMENT IN THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
MAY BUT I APPRECIATE THE TEST
PLAN THAT YOU HAVE ON THERE A
LOT OF WAYS THEY CAN ENGAGE.
THANK WITHOUT LOW -- OTHER COUNT
YET MISS WEBER.
DOC I WANNA I WANNA THANK ALL OF
YOU CAME NOW I'M SORRY I WAS
LATE RUNNING IN BUT IT'S NOT
JUST FOR THIS ISSUE I I WAS IN.
COMMITTEES HE PRESENTING BILLS
ALL MORNING LONG SO I WILL LET
HIM I THANK AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT I'M SORRY I MISSED
YOU YOUR YOUR YOUR TESTIMONIES --
I'VE HEARD THEM BEFORE AND AND
DAD I THINKS.
AS ALWAYS THIS IS THIS BECOMES
THE ISSUE OF WHAT PEOPLE THINK
IS THE BEST APPROPRIATE WAY TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF VOTING.
AND WHAT AND WHERE THE AGE IS
AND IS NOT BECAUSE THAT OUT THAT
IS ALWAYS OPEN FOR A VARIETY OF
CONVERSATIONS -- YOU KNOW I CAN
GO IN ONE COMMUNITY AND AND
WHICH I HAPPEN TALK TO YOUNG
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY
PARTICULARLY -- AND AND THEY
DON'T THEY THEY THEY DON'T THINK
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
ARE READY TO VOTE THAT'S JUST
AND THESE ARE SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS WERE TELLING
ME THIS.
OP AND THERE'S ALWAYS A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE INAPPROPRIATE WHAT
ARE THE STANDARDS THAT WE USE --
I THINK WE CAN FIND VERY SHARP
AND SMART YOUNG PEOPLE AT EVERY
AGE.
OF THAT'S THERE ALL THAT OF
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND THEN AT THE
SAME TIME I CAN FIND VERY
RESPONSIBLE TEENAGERS AT
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN
AND TWENTY ALSO IT'S ALWAYS THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE -- IT'S NOT
ISSUE WHO PAYS TAXES -- BECAUSE
AS SOON AS A KID EARNS A COUPLE
DOLLARS SELLING PAPERS OR
WHATEVER THEY DO NOWADAYS THEY
PAY TAXES SO THAT OBVIOUSLY IS
NOT AND YET WE PROBABLY I DON'T
THINK WE WOULD STAND HERE AND
ASK FOR EIGHT YEAR OLDS.
HAD TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE
ARE A WEEK SOME MIGHT BUT I
DOUBT IF WE WOULD SO I AT I'M A
I'M A PERSON STRONGLY BELIEVES
THAT THAT THERE'S A TIME FRAME
AND WE HAVE TO IDENTIFY THE TIME
FRAME IN EIGHTEEN IS A TIME
FRAME.
AND YOU KEEP IF WE KEEP GOING
BACKWARDS AND BACKWARDS AND
BACKWARDS THEN ADVICE A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS CAN VOTE
THEN OBVIOUSLY SXTEEN YEAR OLDS
COMPATIBLE BECAUSE THEY GET.
PROBABLY GET WAS AS GOOD AN
ARGUMENT FOR IT IS THAT AND
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS COULD VOTE SO
I THINK IT CONTINUES TO MOVE
IT'S IT'S A MOVING TARGET AND
AND UNTIL WE HAVE REAL SERIOUS
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT MATURITY
WHICH IS DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY.
A MINUTES DIFFICULT WE HAVE NO
TEST WITH MATURITY THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY WHO SHOULD
NEVER VOTE OF BUT BUT THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE WE KNOW THAT.
AND SO SO I THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S
A BIT AND WE'VE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION BEFORE SO MY POSITION
IS NOT A SURPRISE ANYBODY WITH
HIS IN THIS COMMITTEE ON THE
FLOOR -- THAT I I THINK THERE'S
A TIME AND EIGHTEEN IS A TIME
WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE WILL WE'VE
IDENTIFIED IT -- HAVING BEEN A
PART OF AS OLD AS I AM HAVING
BEEN A PART OF THE DIALOGUE AND
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD VOTING.
OUT THAT CAME INTO BEING BECAUSE
THERE WAS SOME REAL TANGIBLE
ISSUES IN THE SOCIETY THAT THAT
PUSHED US FORWARD TO THAT NUMBER
AND NOT JUST BECAUSE WE THOUGHT
FOLKS WILL MATURE.
BUT WE WERE DRAFTING YOUNG MEN
INTO WAR PEOPLE WERE BEING ASKED
TO FIGHT FOR THEIR COUNTRY THEY
HAD ACCESS TO CIGARETTES AT THE
TIME NOW WE'VE MOVED ON FROM
THAT.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT BEEN IDENTIFIED THIS
IS THE AGE IN WHICH YOU COULD BE
TRIED AS AN ADULT.
YOU GO TO ADULT PRISON YOU CAN
PUT FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE IN
PRISON.
AND SO YOU WERE TREATED AS AN
ADULT -- THERE WERE FEW BECAME
EMANCIPATED MINORS EARLY IN LIFE
BECAUSE OF SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
SITUATIONS BUT WE IN MY
GENERATION LOOKED AND SAW THAT
AND I'D COULD NOT VOTED --
EIGHTEEN LOOKED AND SAW THAT
WAITING TO TWENTY ONE BY THAT
TIME YOU HAD ALREADY MADE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
COUNTRY THERE WAS A DRAFT THAT
OCCURRED FOR EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS.
AND AND SO IT LOOK AT THE
SITUATION AND SAID YOU KNOW
WE'RE ASKING THESE YOUNG MEN TO
DIE FOR THEIR COUNTRY TO BE
INVOLVED IN WARS AND CONFLICTS
AND YET THEY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO SAY ABOUT IT.
OKAY THEY HAVE A WORD TO SAY
ABOUT WHY THEY SHOULD BE THERE
AND SO THAT PUSH THEN BECAME AS
A RESULT OF ALL THE WOULD BE
ADULT RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT WE GAVE
TO YOUNG PEOPLE WAS THERE.
EIGHTEEN A ONCE YOU BECAME
EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW ANYTHING COULD
HAPPEN BUT YOU WERE CONSIDERED
AN ADULT.
AND YOU HAD CONSEQUENCES FOR
YOUR BEHAVIOR AS AN ADULT AND SO
I I THINK IT'S A IT'S A LARGER
CONVERSATION -- THAT'S THERE BUT
I KIND OF HONOR THE EIGHTEEN
BECAUSE I WAS THERE FOR THE
CONVERSATION AND KNOW WHY CAME
INTO EXISTENCE AND NOT JUST
BECAUSE THOSE WERE EIGHTEEN
THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE MATURE
ENOUGH.
BUT BUT THE SOCIETY FELT THEY
WERE MATURE ENOUGH TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR SOME SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES OF LIFE AND DEATH.
AND AND AS A RESULT THEY GOT THE
RIGHT TO VOTE SO -- I THANK YOU
FOR FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND AND
WHAT YOU ARE AND I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
REALLY ACTIVELY ENGAGED AND
COMMITTED TO IT HOPE.
IT STAYS THERE WE ARE STRUGGLING
NOW TRY TO GET EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO VOTE I MEAN YOU KNOW SO --
THAT'S A THAT'S A CHALLENGE AS
THE AND I'M NOT SURE OF LEADING
WITH VOTED SEVENTEEN SOLVE THE
ISSUE THAT WILL FACE.
BUT IT TRULY IS A A DISCUSSION
THAT THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE AND
AND MAKE SOME FINAL DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT.
OF THE ISSUE OF WHAT WE IDENTIFY
AS THE QUALIFIERS THE PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE WHERE IS
IT WHERE DOES THE LINE FALL WHAT
IT WAS AGE GROUPING THAT'S THERE.
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT AND I DON'T
THINK WE'VE HAD ENOUGH OF THAT
CONVERSATION YET -- TO DEFY WITH
THEIR TRUE CONSEQUENCES ADULT
CONSEQUENCES FOR THOSE FOLKS WHO
AT DIFFERENT AGES AND THAT'S
WHAT'S REALLY.
DRIVING ME IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
IT SO I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR FOR
WHAT OF WHAT YOU SAID TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER AND IT
AGAIN I THINK YOU SUMMARIZE A
LOT OF MY THOUGHTS.
YOU KNOW AS WE WE TEND TO AGREE
AND THIS COMMITTEE -- THAT YOU
KNOW FIRST OF ALL I DO DISAGREE
WITH THE RATIONALE BEHIND THE
OPPOSITION.
I THINK YOU ARE MORE THAN
CAPABLE OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO COME HERE TODAY AND I HAVE
TESTIFIED.
I THINK YOU ARE MORE THAN MORE
THAN CAPABLE OF BEING ABLE TO
VOTE AND TO AND TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS -- YOU KNOW.
MY THIRTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER.
THE OF BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT THE
OF WHAT I'M INVOLVED IN IN HER
OWN INTEREST.
KNOWS A LOT ABOUT POLITICS AND
TALKS ABOUT THESE ISSUES ALL THE
TIME I THINK SHE WOULD BE MORE
THAN CAPABLE OF VOTING AND
MAKING GOOD DECISIONS.
ON BEHALF OF OUR OF OF OUR
REPUBLIC -- IT'S JUST THAT WE
HAVE MADE A SOCIETAL DECISION
THAT EIGHTEEN IS THE AGE OF
MAJORITY -- AND THAT APPLIES TO
EVERYBODY ACROSS YOU KNOW ALL
LINES EIGHTEEN IS IS IS IS THE
AGE OF MAJORITY -- I AND I THINK
THAT IN ORDER TO MOVETHAT
NUMBER THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME.
REASONABLE AND LOGICAL REASON
FOR DOING SO RIGHT -- AND THERE
BEEN ARGUMENTS MADE IN THIS BODY.
NOT BY MY PARTY.
THE BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARGUE FOR OLDER AGES.
THEY SAY THAT YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT TO BUY TO BUY TOBACCO
PRODUCTS FOR INSTANCE.
YOU GOT TO BE -- TWENTY ONE THEY
MAKE ARGUMENTS IS SAY YOU SHOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO BUY A GUN.
UNTIL YOU'RE TWENTY ONE BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T MAKE.
YOU CAN'T BE SO YOU CAN'T
POSSIBLY BE SAFE WITH THAT GUN
YOU CAN'T MAKE THAT DECISION.
AT EIGHTEEN THOSE ARGUMENTS MADE
BY THE MAJORITY PARTY HERE.
THERE WE WERE LECTURED TO YEARS
AGO ABOUT HOW WE CAN'T POSSIBLY
HOLD -- PEOPLE WHO COMMIT CRIMES
WHEN THEY'RE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE TO AN ADULT STANDARD.
BECAUSE QUOTE RECENT NEERAJ
NEUROLOGICAL RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
COGNITIVE BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
CONTINUES WELL BEYOND AGE
EIGHTEEN AND INTO EARLY
ADULTHOOD FOR BOYS AND YOUNG MEN
IN PARTICULAR WERE TOLD.
THIS PROCESS CONTINUES INTO THE
MID TWENTIES THE PARTS OF THE
BRAIN THAT ARE STILL DEVELOPING
DURING THIS PROCESS AFFECT
JUDGMENT.
AND DECISION MAKING AND SO THEY
THEREFORE CAN'T BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR DECISION
SO IT'S IT'S NOT MY PARTY.
IT'S ARGUING THAT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE.
EIGHTEEN OR YOUNGER AREN'T ABLE
TO MAKE GOOD JUDGMENT DECISIONS
IS ACTUALLY THE MAJORITY PARTY
THAT CONTINUES TO MAKE THOSE
KIND OF ARGUMENTS -- I THINK
THAT WE COULD HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT OUR OUR MINERS.
IF WE'RE GOING TO SAY THE HEY
MINERS WHO ARE AFFECTED BY
POLICY.
SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO VOTE
LET'S HAVE THAT DISCUSSION WHY
ARE WE STOPPING AT SEVENTEEN AS
HAS BEEN POINTED OUT BY MANY
PEOPLE.
MY THIRTEEN YEAR OLD AGAIN PAYS
TAXES.
SHE HAS HER OWN ALLOWANCE SHE
HAS HER OWN MONEY WHEN HE
DOESN'T BUY SOMETHING AT A STORE
SHE PAYS SALES TAX.
YOU CAN'T THE JUSTIFICATION CAM
ALONE BE.
NO TAXATION WITHOUT WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION [inaudible]
RIGHT.
AND SHE'S JUST AS AFFECTED BY
POLICY AND SHE'S CAPABLE OF
MAKING JUDGEMENT DECISIONS TO
WHY STOP AT SEVENTEEN RIGHT WHY
NOT WHY NOT ALLOW ALL YOU KNOW
IN IN MANY TRADITIONS.
THIRTEEN IS THE AGE OF MAJORITY.
IN THE JEWISH TRADITION FOR
EXAMPLE -- YOU KNOW SO.
YOU COULD MAKE IS AS AS DOCTOR
WEBER I THINK REALLY LAID OUT
YOU KNOW YOU COULD MAKE
ARGUMENTS.
ALL AROUND BUT WE'VE DECIDED
EIGHTEEN IS THE AGE OF MAJORITY.
AND UNLESS THERE'S A REALLY GOOD
REASON FOR DOING SO WHY SHOULD
WE DO THIS.
A VERY ARBITRARILY MOVEMENT I
MEAN.
IF WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT ALL
MINOR SHOULD VOTE LET'S MOVE TO
THIRTEEN THEN.
RIGHT IF WE DO BELIEVE AS HAS
BEEN.
ARGUED IN THIS BODY THAT NO EVEN
AT EIGHTEEN AND UP.
TO TWENTY FIVE YOU CAN'T MAKE
GOOD JUDGMENT CALLS MAYBE
THERE'S AN ARGUMENT FOR MOVING
IT UP.
RIGHT BUT TO JUST SAY ALL WELL
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT SEVENTEEN
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE WITH A
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
WHEN A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD.
AND A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD.
IT JUST SEEMS COMPLETELY
ARBITRARY AND IT DOESN'T HAVE.
THE STRONG JUSTIFICATION FOR FOR
MOVING THAT AGE LIMIT -- AND SO
I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE END UP
IS NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU ARE VERY CAPABLE AND
THAT.
DECISIONS THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE A
VOICE AND YOU DO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE INVOLVED IN
POLITICS AND I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL BE -- IT'D GET INVOLVED IN
CAMPAIGNS I WAS VERY ACTIVE
MYSELF.
YOU KNOW I GOT ELECTED THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AT TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD.
COURSE ALL THESE EXAMPLES OF THE
USE OF US CAN ELECTED ROLL OVER.
EIGHTEEN RIGHT.
AND I WAS VERY ACTIVE
POLITICALLY AS YOU ARE IN HIGH
SCHOOL I I COULDN'T WAIT TO VOTE
I WANTED TO BUT I KNEW THE
EIGHTEEN WAS THE H. NOW.
AND THAT IS IT WASN'T I DIDN'T
FEEL IT WAS UNFAIR.
IT'S WHAT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED.
AND SO -- THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
I WILL ALLOW -- MR MULLIN TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION IT'S ACTUALLY AN
INTERESTINGJUMPING OFF POINT
TALKING ABOUT.
THE ARBITRARY NATURE OF MOVING.
THE VOTING AGE.
ACTUALLY WE ARE GROUNDED.
IN BECOMING EIGHTEEN BY THE
GENERAL ELECTION WE ARE LEGALLY
[inaudible]
CONNECTED.
TO THE AGE OF OF MAJORITY.
AND SO.
THIS APPROACH IS AN INCREMENTAL
ONE RIGHT.
THE TURNING SEVENTEEN FOR THE
PRIMARY SO FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
BOB WILL BE EIGHTEEN BY THE
GENERAL.
IF THESE KIDS IF THEY IF THESE
VOTERS ARE GOING TO BE
PARTICIPATING IN SELECTING FROM
A POOL OF CANDIDATES TO THE
GENERAL ELECTION WHEN THEY'RE
EIGHTEEN THE GET WHEN THEY'RE
EIGHTEEN THE GENERAL ELECTION.
THEY OUGHT TO HAVE A CHANCE TO
SHAPE THAT POOL OF CANDIDATES.
IN THE PRIMARY ELECTION WE ARE
LEGALLY LINKING. TO TO BECOMING
EIGHTEEN AND PARTICIPATING IN
THE PRIMARY IN FACT.
NEARLY HALF OF STATES IN THE
COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE LAW IN HAVE NEARLY
HALF THE STATES.
ILLINOIS INDIANA KENTUCKY.
MISSISSIPPI OHIO SOUTH CAROLINA.
JUST TO NAME A HANDFUL.
ALREADY THE LAW CALIFORNIA'S
BEHIND THE CURVE ON THIS ISSUE.
SO WE ARE DOING GREAT ON PRE
REGISTRATION AND ALL SORTS OF
EFFORTS THAT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE IS INVOLVED IN.
BUT WE ARE TRULY BEHIND.
ON THIS ISSUE WHEN WE SHOULD BE
LEADING ON THE ISSUE SO BOB EAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A DISCUSSION
ON A MISTER LOS AMENDMENT AND
APPROACH I ALSO SUPPORT.
BY THE WAY.
BUT THERE WILL BE A CONVERSATION
THAT ENSUES MY HOPE IS THAT BOTHOF OUR A. C. A.'S.
MAKE IT THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY TO
THE SENATE WE WILL HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT JOINING
FORCES I'M SURE BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT COMPETING.
PROPOSALS GOING TO THE BALLOT
THAT DOESN'T MAKE MUCH SENSE MY
INTEREST IS UP.
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE CATCH
CALIFORNIA UP WITH WITH THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY HOW DO WE COME UP
WITH AN APPROACH THAT'S VIABLE
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DOES THIS
REQUIRE TWO THIRDS VOTE IN BOTH
HOUSES.
THIS REQUIRES A MAJORITY VOTE OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
PROBABLY AT THE OF MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY A PRIMARY ELECTION YOU
HEARD.
A RAGE OF THE ARGUMENTS HERE BUT
I WOULD JUST LEAVE YOU WITH THE
THOUGHT THAT ALTHOUGH MY
APPROACH -- IS INCREMENTAL.
IT'S NOT QUITE AS ASPIRATIONAL --
AS AS MISTER LOWS I DO THINK WE
ARE A STRONG LEGAL FOOTING I
THINK THIS THIS OB INCREMENTAL
APPROACH WOULD BE EMBRACED BY
THE VOTERS.
OF CALIFORNIA SO WE CAN CATCH UP
WITH THE OHIO SINCE SOUTH
CAROLINA'S OF THE WORLD.
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ENTERTAINING THE CONVERSATION AT
FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
SURFACE US SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS
THAT WE ARE SURE TO HEAR -- OVER
THE NEXT DOT NINE MONTHS OR SO
AND WITH THAT -- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE.
I THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN AND I
APPRECIATE THAT DON'T OFTEN HEAR
US.
AT USING SOUTH CAROLINA AS THE
MA AS A MODEL IN THIS BODY BUT A
FAIR POINT A FAIR POINT -- ALL
RIGHT.
MATT INCLUDE PLEASE CALL OF
THERE IS A MOTION AND SECONDLY
BY MISTER LOWE AND MISTER
CALDERON.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN.
GALLAGHER.
NOBODY GALLAGHER NOT VOTING
CALDERON.
CALDERON I LOW.
LOW MAYES.
MAYES NOT PHONY MULLIN.
AYE MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER NOT VOTING.
OKAY THE BILLS ON CALL -- AND WE
WILL.
AWAITFOR OTHER MEMBERS TO GET
HERE.
ONE BRING THAT BACK UP AGAIN I
DO SEE THAT WE HAVE SENATOR
UMBERG HERE SO WHY DON'T WE TAKE
HIM -- I KNOW HE'S BEEN WAITING
PATIENTLY OVER THE AND THANK YOU
TO ALL THE WITNESSES WHO CAME
HERE AND AN INVOICE THERE.
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SENATOR.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
SO -- A COUPLE COMMENTS BEFORE
WE BEGIN PRESENTATION OF COMING
NUMBER ONE YOUR CHIEF CONSULTANT
ESTHER JONES INFORMS THE THAT
WHEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN RETURNS
WILL BE FOR FORMER CHEERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE -- CURRENT FORMER
TEACHERS IS.
PRESENT.
YEAH AND I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
REFLECTION -- WITH RESPECT TO
MISTER JONES AND HIS INABILITY
TO ACTUALLY KEEP A CHAIR.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S ONE
OBSERVATION THE SECOND
OBSERVATION IS THIS IS SORT OF
LIKE VISUAL LOOKING AT TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MISTER CALDERON.
AND MR MULLIN WHOSE FATHERS I
SERVED WITH BACK IN THE DAY SO
PLEASE GIVE THEM MY REGARD MAYBE
IT'S JUST THAT NOBODY WANTS TO
SERVE WITH MISTER JOHN THAT'S
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HAVE HIM YOU
KNOW THAT'S THE THE GLASS IS
HALF FULL ISN'T IT.
YES.
THANK YOU -- SO BEFORE YOU --
MEMBERS IS -- SB -- SEVENTY TWO
SB -- SEVENTY TWO MARKS THE THE
LAST YEAR MARKED THE FIRST TIME
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF SAME DAY
VOTER REGISTRATION WAS AVAILABLE --
FOR STATEWIDE ELECTIONS -- THE
LAW REQUIRES.
THESE VOTERS WHO WISH TO VOTE OF
INVESTORS SAME DAY TO COMPLETE
AN AFFIDAVIT OF CONDITIONAL
VOTER REGISTRATION AND CAST
PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
THE PROVISIONAL BALLOTS
TABULATED ONLY.
AFTER THE REGISTRATION IS
CHECKED FOR VALIDITY AGAIN SO
SECURITY AND DMV RECORDS IN THE
STATEWIDE VOTER DATABASE TO
ENSURE THE VOTER DID NOT ALREADY
RECEIVE ABOUT ELSEWHERE.
IN SOME WAYS THE SYSTEM WORK
VERY WELL FOR INSTANCE OVER
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND SAME DAY
BALLOTS WERE CAST IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION ALONE.
THE SECTORS STATE REPORTS THAT
THERE WERE NO REPORTED INSTANCES
OF FRAUD ASSOCIATED WITH THEM
ANYWHERE.
THE THE GLARING PROBLEM HOWEVER
IS THAT THE SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION SIMPLY WASN'T
OFFERED ENOUGH LOCATIONS I KNOW
FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
YOU COULD SEE THAT FOLKS WERE
INTERESTED IN VOTING IN WERE
LINED UP IN REMAIN FOR HOURS AT
THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS OFFICE
IN SANTA ANA LONG LONG AFTER THE
POLLS HAD CLOSED AT EIGHT PM.
OUR CURRENT LAW REQUIRES ONLY
THAT THE SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION -- BE OFFERED IN
PERMANENT OFFICES THE COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND IT VOTE
CENTERS AND COUNTIES
PARTICIPATING IN THE VOTERS
CHOICE ACT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN LA COUNTY THAT
MAY MEAN YOU'D HAVE TO GO FROM
LANCASTER TO DOWNEY TO BE ABLE
TO REGISTER TO VOTE ON THE SAME
DAY.
ONLY FIVE NON.
VOTER CHOICE ACT COUNTIES CHOSE
TO OFFER SAME DAY REGISTRATION
AND VOTING ON ELECTION DAY AWAY
FROM THE PERMANENT OFFICES AS
RESULT THOUSANDS OF THOSE WERE
FORCED TO WAIT.
AN HOURS LONG LINES OR NOT VOTE
AT ALL -- SOLD -- BEFORE YOU IS
SB SEVENTY TWO WHICH BOB PERMITS
COUNTIES CHOOSE FROM CELLS
REALLY WANT TO GO HIGH TECH WITH
THE LOOKED EXCUSE ME.
WHETHER THEY THEY WANT -- TO
PROVIDE FOR SAME DAY.
VOTER REGISTRATION AT THE
POLLING PLACES AS WELL AS IT OF
BOTH CENTERS -- WITH ME HERE ARE
SEVERAL FOLKS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MISS MICHELLE
**** A UC BERKELEY STUDENT WHO
WHO VOTED -- ON SAME DAY WITH
SAME DAY REGISTRATION UBER AND
RUBBLE MISIA'S WITH THE ACLU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE SECOND MOVED AND SECONDED BY
MISTER LOW IN CALDERON AGAIN.
YES GO AHEAD.
PLEASE PROCEED WITNESSES.
GET MEMBERS THE MANY ROMANS YES.
I'M HAVE A SO YOU HAVE
CALIFORNIA.
SO SB SEVENTY TWO WOULD.
GIVE VOTERS THE OPPORTUNITY
COULD MANAGE OF ELECTION DAY
REGISTRATION.
AT ANY POLLING SITE.
ELECTION RICK ELECTION DAY
REGISTRATION HAS BEEN SHOWN.
IN OTHER STATES TO SIGNIFICANTLY
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED VOTER
TURNOUT PARTICULARLY AMONG STE
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED VOTERS
INCLUDING VOTERS OF COLOR YOUNG
VOTERS AND LOW INCOME VOTERS.
LAST YEAR WE ARE EXCITED THAT
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVERY COUNTY
WOULD.
WOULD PROVIDE ELECTION DAY
REGISTRATION AT THERE CAN
ELECTIONS OFFICE AND THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE THE OPTION OF
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SATELLITE
LOCATIONS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY -- THE
REGULATIONS IMPLEMENT THE BILL
WERE DEVELOPED AND AND THE
WEIGHT IT WAS ROLL ROLLED OUT IT
WAS DIFFICULT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SATELLITE LOCATIONS.
AND AS WAS MENTIONED ONLY A
HANDFUL OF COUNTIES ACTUALLY
PROVIDED MORE THAN A SINGLE SITE
ON ELECTION DAY -- SO AS A
RESULT WE DIDN'T SEE AS MANY
VOTERS TAKE ADVANTAGE.
AS SHE HAS BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ELECTION DAY
REGISTRATION AS WE WOULD HAVE
HOPED -- AND AS WAS MENTIONED
THAT WE SAW LINES ALL AROUND THE
STATE.
IN SOME COUNTIES THE REPORTS OF
LINES UP TO THREE OR FOUR HOURS.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS KIND IS ONLY
A SINGLE SITE TO ANOTHER WAS
RELATIVELY LOW NUMBER VOTERS
USING IT THAT REALLY BACKED UP
THE SYSTEM.
SO.
I'M AN ADULT SAID ACCORDING TO
DATA WE WE RECEIVED FROM.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CORRECT ELECTIONS OFFICIALS THEY
WERE FIFTY THOUSAND VOTES CAST
ON ELECTION DAY IN NOVEMBER AT
POLLING SITES AND THESE BALLOTS
I'M COULD BE COUNTED BECAUSE
THEY WERE.
THOSE VOTERS WENT RICHARD ABOUT
TEN TO THE SYSTEM THESE ARE --
THESE VOTERS WOULD BE NAY THEIR
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO COUNT BECAUSE UNDER
SB.
SEVENTY TWO SO SB SIX SEVENTY
TWO WOULD EXPAND ACCESS TO
ACCESS -- TO TO ELECTION DAY
REGISTRATION EVERY POLLING SITE.
AND IT ALSO GIVES ELECTION
OFFICIALS AND THE FLEXIBILITY IN
HOW THEY WANT TO IMPLEMENT THIS
SO THEY CAN GO FOR THE HIGH TECH
RIP RAP HERE WITH WITH -- WITH
AGAIN ELECTRONIC -- BOOKS AND
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE EVERY
EVERY BALLOT TYPE IF THEY HAVE
THAT TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE WHERE
THEY COULD JUST SIMPLY PROVIDE
VOTERS A PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
IN THERE -- AT THAT PULLING SITE
TO THE BALLOT TYPE THAT IS
AVAILABLE.
AND BY USING A POLLING SITE A
PROVISIONAL BALLOT HE WOULD
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE VOTE
STATEMENT AS WAS MENTIONED THAT.
THE ELECTION OFFICIALS WILL BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT ONLY WANT
ONE THAT WAS KEPT SPEECH VOTER.
SO -- FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WE
URGE AND I VOTE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHELLE
WEIGHING FIRST OFF THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY.
I'M A SOPHOMORE AT UC BERKELEY
STUDYING ECONOMICS AND I'M ALSO
AN INTERN ON CALPERS NEW BUT
THIS PROJECT.
THIS PAST MEDINA ELECTION
CALPERS REGISTERED OVER SIX
THOUSAND NEWSTUDENT VOTERS.
AND MADE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND GET OUT THE VOTE.
EFFORTS LEADING UP TO THE
ELECTION DESPITE ALL THESE
EFFORTS.
THERE ARE STILL MANY BARRIERS
FACING STUDENTS IN THE VOTING
PROCESS I MYSELF AM FROM INDIANA.
WAS ORIGINALLY PLANNING TO VOTE
VIA MAIL IN BALLOT UNFORTUNATELY.
MY BALLOTS NOT ARRIVE IN TIME SO
I FACE THE DILEMMA THAT STUDENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BASED EVERY
ELECTION WHETHER TO SACRIFICE
THE ADDITIONAL TIME AND EFFORT
NEEDED TO CONDITIONALLY REGISTER.
OR TO SACRIFICE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
I ULTIMATELY WENT TO DOWNTOWN
OAKLAND TO CONDITIONALLY
REGISTER AND IN THE END ALL THE
PROCESS TOOK OVER THREE HOURS.
THIS IS AN ASK THAT WE CANNOT IN
GOOD CONSCIOUS MAINTAIN OF
PEOPLE WHO FACE VERY COMMON
ISSUES WITH THEIR VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS.
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO VOTE ON ELECTION DAY.
AND INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
POLLING PLACES THE OFFER SAME
DAY VOTER REGISTRATION WOULD
REMOVE MANY OF THE BARRIERS THAT
BASE VOTERS TODAY.
SB SUNNY TO PASSING WOULD
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY POTENTIAL
VOTER HAS OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE.
IN AN ELECTION.
ON ELECTION DAY AND THIS WOULD
EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND REINVIGORATE OUR DEMOCRACY
THAT WORKS BEST WHEN EVERY
PERSON IS ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
VOICE HEARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU --
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA.
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
YOUR ROSE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
TO CALIFORNIA WHERE CO SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL AND STRONG SUPPORT.
BECAUSE I DON'T REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE ALSO CO
SPONSOR OLSON VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE SPONSORING
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MERRY WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL
STATE SINICIZATION IN SUPPORT.
ALEX BEFORE WITH THE UC STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THE CITY WHEREVER US BEGINS
INDIVIDUAL SACRAMENTO.
SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
RE TO WALLACE PUBLIC POLICY GRAD
STUDENT UC BERKELEY AND SUPPORT.
RIGHT RUN GO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS LIKE TO APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE WERE TARDY WITH OUR
LETTER BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
JIM WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU -- AND THEN
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND YOU
KNOW IF THERE'S ANOTHER
WITNESSES WANT TO TESTIFY WOULD
BE FINE TOO BUT GO AHEAD SIR.
THANK YOU SIR -- MY NAME IS ROLE
RODRIGUEZ JUNIOR FOR ANOTHER
WITNESS YET COME ON UP.
GO AHEAD SIR [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
BACK.
WHICH IS A PERSON.
HAVE SOMEONE.
ELSE ON THE HEAD SO GO AHEAD SIR
GO YOU GO AHEAD AND TESTIFY OKAY
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ROLE
RODRIGUEZ JR AND I HAVE --
WORKED ELECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THE PAST -- EIGHTEEN YEARS I
ALSO RAN FOR SECRETARY OF STATE
AND IN THE LAST ELECTION.
I CAME IN THIRD.
AND THE REASON WHY I AM SITTING
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
TO SB SEVENTY TWO IS BECAUSE
YOUR AS I WORKED ELECTIONS ALL
THESE YEARS I'VE LEARNED THE
PROCESS I'VE LEARNED EVERY JOB.
THAT REQUIRED TO BE PART OF THE
BOARDING PROCESS -- IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE ARE ABLE TO
GIVE UP.
PROVISIONAL BALLOT TO SOMEONE.
FOR WHATEVER REASON AND THERE'S
A PROCESS FOR RECEIVING UP OF
PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
AND THE POINT THAT I'M TRYING TO
MAKE HIS SAID -- THE VOTERS HAVE
AMPLE TIME TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
IF THEY DON'T REGISTERED TO VOTE
THAN WHEN THEY GO TO VOTING TO
AVOID HIM -- PROCESS OR THERE
WILL VOTING SITE THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTER PER OF VOTE BY A
PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
SO ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS FILL
OUT A FORM AND THE SUPERVISOR
WILL HELP THAT PERSON FILL OUT
THAT FORM SO THAT.
HE OR SHE GOES TO THE PROPER
PROCESS.
SO I AM OPPOSED TO SB SEVENTY
TWO BECAUSE THERE'S A PROCESS
THERE ALREADY.
FOR WHAT.
WE CAN DO TO HELP A PERSON.
ABOUT IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR AND SMITH AND I
WOULD US IF YOU HAVE THE IF
YOU'RE GONNA READ THE LETTER OUT
WE HAVE THE LETTER SO WE DON'T
NEED TO READ THE LETTER IF YOU
HAVE PERSONAL TESTIMONY WANNA
GIVE AS TO WHY YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL.
THAT WOULD BE MORE BENEFICIAL TO
THE COMMITTEE I THINK.
YOU'VE GOT THE RED LETTER -- IF
YOU HAVE TIME TO READ IT --
MAINLY THE THE THE MAIN POINT IS
THAT OF THE TERM WELL.
HEAD COACH.
OF THE ROLE OF POLL WORKERS IS
IS TERRIBLY DEMANDING AND
EXHAUSTING AND EXPECTING
THOUSANDS OF POLL WORKERS TO ADD
TO THE RESPONSIBILITIES.
OF WITH THE PROPER REGISTRATION
AND PROCESSING OF NEW VOTERS.
IS ASKING FOR DISASTER AND WE'VE
GOT LOTS OF EXAMPLES.
OF THE ISSUES THAT THAT HAPPENED
BUT IT THAT'S IN THE LETTER SO
IF YOU DON'T WANT ME TO READ
THAT I A LONG SO ANYWAY --
THAT'S IT THAT WILL LET YOU READ
THE LETTER I GUESS A FEW.
YEAH I MEAN IF YOU WANT TO READ
EXCERPTS IS FINE IT'S JUST THAT
WE HAVE THE THE WHOLE INTERVIEW
HABIT YEAH I JUST.
WOULD LIKE TO GET IT ON THE
RECORD SO.
BASICALLY THE THE CHALLENGES OF
PROPER ELECTION MANAGEMENT ARE
ALREADY MONUMENTAL AND MOVING
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
TO LOCAL POLLING POLLING SITES.
A WILL GUARANTEE SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF VOTES WILL BE
MISHANDLED AND OF THAT DILUTES
EVERY MISHANDLED VOTE CANCELS A
VOTE OF A LEGITIMATE VOTER.
SO THAT'S THAT'S OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN WITH THIS -- AND THEN
PEOPLE THAT ARE GIVEN.
OF THE WRONG BALLOTS THAT'S ALSO
AN ISSUE SO IT IT'S ALL LISTED
IN THERE SO I WON'T [inaudible]
BOB GALE.
YEAH YOU'RE NOT BUGGING ME ANY
AND THEN YOU DO THAT IF YOU HAD
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO ADD.
PLEASE DO.
ALL RIGHT I'M TIRED OF READING
GO AHEAD. FOR ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS GWEN MYERS AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME STAFF KATANA ADAM HUNGER
PERCENT OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
DIANA BARBA OPPOSED.
STELLA MAY.
CONCERNED CITIZENS THE
CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE
FOREIGN INTERFERENCE BUT BY
ELECTRONICS.
OF YOU TALK ABOUT RUSSIA RUSSIA
CHINA THIS OPENS UP AT ALL
BECAUSE THREE MONTHS AGO. TWO
THIRTEEN YEAR OLDS WERE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE THE ELECT.
THE ELECTRONIC VOTE AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO FLIP THE VOTE SO
THIS IS OPEN UP A CAN OF WORMS
THANK YOU.
THE TREES FIND SUPPOSED TO THIS
VOTE.
WE MEANT TO BURY NO.
GRACE IS GOOD NO.
TYPICAL LEGAL VOTER AGAINST RAMP
IT AND CHECK VOTER FRAUD JUST
SAY NO.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER OKAY -- SEE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SPEECHES.
IN OUR CHAIRMAN IS BACKS
ALTERNATE BACK OVER HIM.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE SURPLUS IS
A GREAT JOB.
IN MY ABSENCE WE HAVE A MOTION.
DO WE HAVE A SECOND.
WE HAVE A SECOND -- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR MANY
COLLEAGUES I WOULD JUST SAY VERY
QUICKLY AND WE'VE HAD YOU KNOW
HAD A LOT OF THIS DISCUSSION BUT
YOU KNOW I I THINK THE ISSUE
HERE IS REALLY THAT THERE STILL
ARE ISSUES WITH.
ENSURING THAT.
YOUR THIS IS AN ELIGIBLE VOTER --
AND WE HAVE HAD SOME ISSUES WITH
THE SYSTEM.
AS I'VE SAID THIS IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS.
AND YOU KNOW COUNTIES ARE
OVERWHELMED I THINK THAT WAS ONE
OF THE POINTS THAT WAS BROUGHT
UP IN THIS LETTER -- IS YOU KNOW
IT'S VERY HARD FOR OUR POLL
WORKERS ALREADY DEAL WITH A LOT
OF DIFFERENT ISSUES TO REQUIRE
EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD POLLING PLACE --
TO PROVIDE FOR THAT -- WE DO WE
ALREADY PROVIDE THIS BY THE WAY
I MEAN IT'S JUST BE POINTED OUT
WE HAVE VOTING CENTERS FOR
FOURTEEN DAYS PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO AND
DO SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION.
YOU WE CAN GO TO THE REGISTRAR'S
OFFICE DO THE SAME THING FOR
FOURTEEN DAYS PRIOR TO THE
ELECTION -- AND AND EVEN ON THE
SAME DAY.
ON THE ELECTION DAY YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT AS WELL IT'S
JUST THAT IF YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
THAT AT EVERY SINGLE POINT
LOCATION THIS CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT I THINK WE ALL KNOW
THIS.
WE ALL GO TO THESE POLLING
LOCATIONS -- YOU KNOW IT IT'S
HARD TO GET VOLUNTEERS THERE.
IT'S IT IS NOT EASY.
TO YEAH I MEAN TO ENSURE THAT
YOU'RE GIVING THE PERSON THE
RIGHT.
ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE AT THE
REGISTRAR'S OFFICE WERE AT THE
VOTING CENTERS THEY HAVE THOSE
MORE OF THOSE RESOURCES SO --
YOU KNOW TO ME I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW.
WE SHOULD BE FIRST OF ALL ENSURE
THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
BE.
REASONABLE -- FOR COUNTIES WHO
ARE WHO ARE CARRYING OUT THESE
ELECTIONS AND THEN SECONDLY.
AT AND I WAS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY ENSURE THAT IT'S YOU
KNOW THAT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
PROCESS OF THIS IS AN ELIGIBLE
VOTER.
THAT THEY ARE IN FACT RESIDING
IN THIS DISTRICT IN.
AN ELIGIBLE TO VOTE IN THE
ELECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER RESTER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
COLLEAGUES BRING BACK TO THE
SENDER TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A TWO
COMMENTS OF THE FIRST AT AT THE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ IS THAT.
YOUR COMMENTS WITH RESPECT -- TO
SAME DAY VOTING THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES -- SECOND IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO VOTE AND
AND REGISTER ON THE SAME DAY --
SOME COUNTIES DON'T HAVE.
OF VOTE CENTERS AND SO THOSE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE VOTE
CENTERS THIS BILL PROVIDES FOR
SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION.
AT POLLING PLACES IT DOES
REQUIRE THAT WE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING BUT YOUR
POINT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER
IS THAT AS WE EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES THE VOTE I DO
EXPECT THAT THEY'LL BE.
FEWER INSTANCES OF OF SAME DAY
VOTER REGISTRATION -- AND IN IN
MY VIEW OF THE MORE WE EXPAND
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE -- WHO ARE CITIZENS TO VOTE
THE BETTER WE ARE WE ARE AS A
DEMOCRACY JUST TO UNDERLINE A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT ONE IS
THAT?
BEFORE -- A VOTE IS TABULATED IT
IS CHECKED FOR VALIDITY AGAINST
SO SECURITY IN DMV RECORDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS VOTER HAS
NOT VOTED SOMEWHERE ELSE OR IS
NOT HEAD.
OF RECEIVE TO BALANCE SO HAVING
SAID THAT I WOULD ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG.
CONDITIONALLY VOTER REGISTRATION
WAS ROLLED OUT IN STATEWIDE
ELECTIONS FOR THE FIRST TIME
LAST YEAR -- NEARLY SIXTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THAT POLICY TO VOTE
AND LOST A MEMBER STATEWIDE
GENERAL ELECTION.
CONDITIONALLY VOTER REGISTRATION
IS MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
SUCCESSFULLY USED IN COUNTIES
WHERE WAS MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE.
SO SPENDING THE AVAILABILITY OF
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
IS A LOGICAL NEXT STEP.
I'M HAPPY TO CO AUTHOR THIS BILL
AND I'M RECOMMENDING AND I VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
REFER RE REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN HI.
BERMAN I'D GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON.
CALDERON I LOW.
LITTLE I MAYES MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
SO THE BILL PASSES -- WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
AND I SEE CENTER AMBERG THAT WE
HAVE -- IT SB FIVE OH FIVE I SEE
THE COMMITTEE GOT. TWO BILLS
WALL IS GONE FOR AN HOUR THAT'S
VERY EFFICIENT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT.
BUT WE'LL KEEP CHUGGING ALONG
AND MAYBE ORDER LUNCH.
MR HERE MAY MASSIVE IN A QUERY
PLEASE UP WITH RESPECT TO THE
BILL BEFORE US WHICH IS SB FIVE
OH FIVE THAT IS THERE'S A
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE IS THAT
CORRECT.
IS THAT CORRECT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE REPUBLICAN
RECOMMENDATIONS -- IS THAT IS IT
IT YES I SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
THAT THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU.
FOR LETTING US KNOW.
WITH THE FACT THAT WE'RE MOTION
AND SECOND.
SHALL I CLOSE YES SIR ALL RIGHT
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA ORIGINAL VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I WORK AT SB ONE FIFTY ONE YES
IS THE GOVERNMENT BETTER LEVEL
FIVE OH FIVE FIVE OH BY THE WILL
OF THE ONE FIFTY ONE WAS PASSED
ON CONSENT -- I WAS WONDERING.
YEAH BUT THE BOB WILL GET TO IT.
ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS CITY WEBER ON THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR HE
SUFFERED A PART OF CALIFORNIA --
WE'VE BEEN [inaudible]
WORKING. TO TRY TO MAKE THIS
BILL SOMETHING THAT WE CAN LIVE
WITH.
THAT THE BILLS IN CHANGED -- IN
MANY POSITIVE WAYS -- HOWEVER WE
STILL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
AND I THINK THAT FIRST OF ALL I
DON'T THINK IT'S AN EMERGENCY --
WE WERE TOLD THAT THERE ARE TWO
MAIN ISSUES -- WHY THEY WANTED?
TO HAVE THIS BILL.
IT WAS -- TO CLARIFY -- THE
DEFINITION OF A GENERALLY
RECOGNIZED CANDIDATE. TO PEACE
AND FREEDOM PARTY AGENERALLY
RECOGNIZED CANDIDATE IS ONE IS
FILED.
WITH THE FEDERAL ELECTION
COMMISSION.
AND THE SO THAT THAT'S MAKE SURE
RECOGNIZED -- ONCE YOU'VE DONE
THAT.
I THINK THIS IS THE SORT OF A
REACH TOO FAR -- BUT SECTORS
STATE. TWO REASONS THAT WERE
GIVEN WAS -- ONE THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY I GUESS PUT A
A NUMBER OF CANDIDATES ON THE
BALLOT THAT THEY HAD NOT --
CONTACTED AND GET ITS DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT.
THE SOLUTION THAT WE SUGGESTED
WAS THAT.
AT CANDIDATES SUBMIT THE REQUEST
TO THE PARTIES.
AND THEN THE PARTY WILL DECIDE
WHICH CANDIDATE THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE ONE IT'S BALLOT.
AND THEY SUBMIT THAT LIST TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE ALONG WITH
THE A LETTERS IN THE CANDIDATES.
WE THINK THAT WOULD TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION THE OTHER --
PROBLEM.
WAS THAT -- THE CASE WITH PEACE
AND FREEDOM PARTY THE GREEN
PARTY -- WE OFTEN HAVE
CANDIDATES.
THE SAME CANDIDATE RUNNING FOR
THE SAME OFFICE ON BOTH BOTH
BALLOTS [inaudible]
AND IN THE PAST THE SOME
SECRETARY OF STATE'S THE STEP
THAT.
AND WE HAVE THE PRIMARY BALLOT.
KITTENS IN A GREEN BAR WE HAVE
THE SAME CANDIDATE.
CURRENT SECURITY STATUS REFUSED
TO DO THAT A ROOF -- HAD A
CANDIDATE -- GOING SO FAR AS TO
PLEAD THE CASE OF WHY SHE WANTED.
ON OUR BALLOT.
SHE WAS NOT PUT OUR BALLOT
ISSUES FROM THE GREEN BALLOT.
SO.
IT'S SINCE BEEN ISSUE AND AND
PART OF THE BILL THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT -- DEALS WITH.
WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT?
BUYING FIND THE WORDING -- BUT
IT'S TALKS ABOUT.
SUBMIT A FORM AND THAT FORM.
THE WAY IT'S WORDED SOUNDS LIKE
IT CAN ONLY BE.
US.
SUBMITTED FOUR ONE ONE CANDIDATE
FOR ONE PARTY ONLY.
AND IF THAT'S THE INTENT THEN
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE.
A DUTCH MEMBER WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IN OUR PARTY.
THANK YOU THE MAIN DISHES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING ABOUT HOPE
PLEASE COME ON OBSERVE.
DOES NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION WOULD BE GREAT.
JOHN RIEGER STATE CHAIR FOR
PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY I JUST
WANT TO SECOND WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
HAS SAID.
OF WE FEEL THAT THIS IS AN OVER
REACH AND FOR A SALUTE OF
SOLUTION LOOKING FOR A PROBLEM
AND THERE IS NO PROBLEM.
WE WOULD STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ONE OF THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WOULD NOW LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
WITH.
A LOT YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OUT ON THAT WE GO BACK AND YEAH
I DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT YESTERDAY
IN THE SENATE YEAH RIGHT YES IT.
THIS MOCK WAS YOUR BOSS IT WAS
SHE WHAT RIGHT. TWENTY YEARS AGO
AND I SCHOOL.
JUST WANTED TO CLEAR BY TIFFANY
MOCK ON BEHALF OF THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE THAT THE
EXAMPLE FOR THE CLARIFICATION
THAT WAS GIVEN OF THE THE
SECRETARY STATES UP THIS BILL
AND IS PROUD SPONSORED. TO
ENSURE CLARITY IN THE PROCESS
AND TO PROVIDE THAT -- IN THE
CASE THAT WAS NOTED THAT IT'S
REGARDLESS OF PARTY THAT WE
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT CANDIDATES
HAD AN INTEREST IN BEING ON THE
BALLOT AND IN SEARCHING FOR SOME
CANDIDATES WE HAD.
MUCH STE DEATH TIME DEVOTED TO
THAT BECAUSE WE COULD NOT LOCATE
THEM DUE TO THE PROCESS BEFORE
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
PROVIDED AN OF THE FORD. FOR
DRIVER.
YOU STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT MARK.
THE CENTER I'M IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE IT UP.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
AMAZINGLY THE CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES THE SECTORS STATED HIS
OR HER DISCRETION TO DECIDE WHO
GOES ON THE PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
BALLOT -- IN THEORY THE CURRENT
SECRETARY OF STATE COULD DECIDE
THAT THE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT
A VIABLE CANDIDATE THAT'S NOT
GONNA HAPPEN.
BUT IT IS IT IS THEORETICALLY
POSSIBLE OTHER THRESHOLD IS
FAIRLY LOW AND IS MISS MOCK
POINTS OUT THERE.
THE OKAY WE WE WE PASSED THAT AS
I'M SORRY IS.
MISS MOCK POINTS OUT -- IN THE
PAST YOU YOU COULD BE PLACED ON
THE BALLOT WITHOUT EVEN YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OF AND SO FOR EXAMPLE
A MANY OF US WOULD NOT WANT TO
BE THE INVOLUNTARY CANDIDATE ON
THE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY.
OF OF BALLOT SO OF FOR THOSE
RESERVES AND I WILL THANK YOU
SENATOR.
THIS BILL INCREASES TRANSPARENCY
TO CANDIDATES AND THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THE STANDARD STANDARDS
USED BY THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO DETERMINE WHICH CANDIDATES
ARE PLACED ON THE BALLOT AT
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY ELECTIONS.
AND IT DOES SO IN A WAY THAT
DOES NOT IMPOSE UNREASONABLE
BARRIERS TO THE BALLOT FOR
CANDIDATES OF COURSE OR IS THE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
SO HAPPY TO RECOMMEND SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN HI BERMAN AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE CALDERON.
CALDERON I'D LOW.%
NO I MAYES.
MULLIN [inaudible]
WEBER.
THAT BILLS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OF FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTER [inaudible]
THANKS.
NEXT UP WALL -- GO THE SOME
NUMBER LOW'S THEY SEE A EIGHT
ITEM NUMBER.
THREE WHILE WE WAIT.
FOR OTHER AUTHORS [inaudible]
TO GET HERE.
WE CAN FIX
[inaudible]
EXACTLY.
AND HAVE TO CONFIRM HERE.
WE HAD TESTAMENT EARLIER SO JUST
PERFECT AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO
YOU.
MR LOEHMANN READY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE CHAIR MEMBERS OUT
BECAUSE WE I JUST PREVIOUSLY
HEARD -- SIMILAR TO RATIONS OF
THIS -- LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
I'LL JUST BE VERY BRIEF -- THIS
IT ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WITH OVER FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS A
CO AUTHOR IN SPONSORING THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AGAIN WITH
OVER A TWENTY FIVE CO AUTHORS
AGAIN MULTIPLE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD BE AN
INCREASED EFFORT TO INCREASE
VOTER PARTICIPATION AND OF HIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT GREAT.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
GOOD MORNING SIR CHAIRED MEMBERS
MY NAME IS EMMA GARSON I'M
SEVENTEEN AND I WORK IN
GRASSROOTS EFFORTS TO EMPOWER
YOUTH THROUGH POLITICAL ADVOCACY.
I SERVED AS A YOUTH DELEGATE TO
THE UNITED NATIONS AND I
LAUNCHED THE HASHTAG PRE REG
SIXTEEN CAMPAIGN.
I'M SPEAKING BEFORE YOU TODAY
JUST WEEKS AFTER THE HUNDRED
YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT
GUARANTEEING WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE TO CONTINUE THE EXPANSION
OF REPRESENTATION IN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
I'M SPEAKING BECAUSE THE FUTURE
DEPENDS ON YOUNG PEOPLE TO SAVE
IT AND TODAY WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENABLE THEM TO DO
SO BY TURNING STUDENTS INTO
VOTERS.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT YOUTH ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED IN OUR COUNTRY.
THE LOWEST PERCENTAGES OF
REGISTERED AN ACTIVE VOTERS ARE
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE AND THIS
ISN'T BECAUSE WE'RE IN DIFFERENT
WHEN IT COMES TO WASHINGTON.
IT'S BECAUSE AT AGE EIGHTEEN THE
WEIGHT OF UPROOTING ONESELF FROM
FAMILY BALANCING CLASSES WITH
WORK AND PAYING OFF STUDENT
LOANS IS ENOUGH TO KEEP ANY
STUDENT FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THE POLITICAL PROCESS.
AS A RESULT MANY OF OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS FAILED TO REFLECT THE
VALUES OF OUR YOUTH.
AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE THE
FUTURE AREN'T HAVING A SAY IN
WHAT THAT FUTURE LOOKS LIKE.
BUT AZ EIGHT WOULD GIVE
POLITICAL POWER TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INFORMED ENGAGED
INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE WHILE THEY'RE
STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
GRADUATE CITIZENS PREPARED TO
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN OUR SOCIETY.
THE REALITY IS THAT CHEN Z. HAD
TO GROW UP FAST.
MY FRIENDS AND I HAVE NO
RECOLLECTION OF A WORLD WAR MASS
SHOOTINGS ARE NOT CONSTANT IN
EVERY DAY LIFE.
AND INSTEAD OF BEING DRAFTED
INTO WARS AND DYING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD WE'RE DYING ON OUR
OWN SOIL IN OUR OWN SCHOOLS.
THIS IS OUR LIFE AND OUR DEATH
AND PEOPLE SAY THAT WE NEED TO
BE PATIENT BUT FRANKLY I HAVE A
PROBLEM BEING PATIENT WILL
PEOPLE WHO LOOKED JUST LIKE ME
ARE BEING KILLED.
JUST LIKE VIETNAM WE WILL
INHERIT A WAR ON TERROR THAT
STARTED BEFORE WE WERE BORN.
WE HAD TO GROW UP FAST BECAUSE
WE HAD TO SEE MORE THROUGH OUR
SCREENS ADOPTING TO PACE OF
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE THAT IS
FLOOD MAKES OUR PARENTS.
THIS SPEED OF CHANGE MEANS THAT
DECISIONS BEING MADE TODAY ABOUT
PRIVACY AND PROTECTION ABOUT
JOBS AND HEALTH CARE AND
IMMIGRATION AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
WE'LL ALL HAVE A PROFOUND EFFECT
ON THE WORLD THAT OUR GENERATION
LIVES IN.
WE AMERICA'S YOUTH HAVE FOUNDER
VOICES AND WE ARE READY TO BE
HEARD THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON A CA EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
MY NAME IS EIGHT AND LANDED ON
THE NEWLY ELECTED YOU'VE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ALL PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA YMCA YOUTH IN
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM.
I CAME HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
MY FELLOW YOU CAN GOVERNMENT
DELEGATES TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT
FOR AC.
EIGHT AND INVESTMENT IN THE
YOUTH OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT THE YOUNG
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA HAD THE
LOWEST TURNOUT ALL DEMOGRAPHICS
AND LOCAL AND STATE ELECTIONS.
WE BELIEVE THAT SOMETHING NEEDS
TO CHANGE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT A CH IS THAT
CHANGE THAT WE SO DESPERATELY
NEED.
IN OUR DEMOCRACY THE IMPORTANCE
OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT FAR EXCEEDS
PARTY LINES.
WITH DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
BOTH CO SPONSORING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
WE'VE BEEN SHOWN THAT CREATING A
GENERATION OF FUTURE VOTERS THAT
PLAY THEIR ROLE IN SOCIETY IS
SOMETHING THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN
CAN GET BEHIND.
WE ARE THE GENERATION THAT WILL
BE VOTING TO SOLVE THE PRESSING
ISSUES OF OUR STATE.
BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
AND THE MASS SHOOTING EPIDEMIC.
AS CALIFORNIANS WE MUST TAKE
THAT LEAD.
I LOWER THE VOTING AGE TO
SEVENTEEN SO DEMOCRATIC
PARTICIPATION.
COULD BECOME A HABIT FROM A
YOUNG AGE.
BY PASSING A C. EIGHT WE WILL
PRESENT THE YOUTH WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF BECOMING
ENGAGED IN THE POLITICAL PROCESS.
AT A TIME WHEN THEY'RE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THE GOVERNMENT CLASS
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL.
THIS WILL TURN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INTO A PRIORITY OF OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEMS.
I SCHOOLS WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO NEGLECT ITS RELEVANCE.
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS ARE ALREADY
ENTRUSTED WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF ENLISTING IN
THE MILITARY AND PAYING TAXES.
SO VOTING IS THE NEXT STEP.
LOWERING THE VOTING AGE WILL
TURN MY GENERATION INTO HABITUAL
LIFELONG VOTERS.
WHO VOTE IN EVERY SINGLE
ELECTION?
SOMETHING CAME HERE TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF MY THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED FELLOW DELEGATES TO
SUPPORT ACA AIDS.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT EVERY
GENERATION MUST IMPROVE THE
WORLD AROUND THEM WITH THEIR
VOTES.
AND IT ALL STARTS BY LOWERING
THE VOTING AGE.
TO SEVENTEEN THIS IS NOT AN
ARBITRARY TIME TO MAKE THIS
DECISION.
AS WE ARE IN A CRISIS AS OUR
STATE FACES EMBARRASSINGLY LOW
VOTER TURNOUT THAT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO DAMAGE OUR
DEMOCRACY FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS
AND WE MUST NOT SIT IDLY BY AND
LET THIS HAPPEN.
WE SUPPORT ACA AIDS.
AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE HI.
UNLIKE THE CALIFORNIA ELECTORATE
DECIDE ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS PROUD
SPONSORS OF AC.
EIGHT AS THE POLITICAL ARM OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT CLTV
RECOGNIZES THAT EXPANDING ACCESS
TO DEMOCRACY IS AN ESSENTIAL AND
POWERFUL WAY TO CHANGE WHAT IS
POSSIBLE AND POLICY.
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A GREAT DEAL
INCREASING VOTER ACCESS BUT WHAT
WE CAN DO A WEEK WE CAN DO MORE
TO INSTILL CONFIDENCE IN OUR
YOUTH.
THAT THEIR VOTE VOICE MATTERS
AND IS VALUABLE.
AND TO REVERSE THAT HISTORICAL
TREND OF YOUNGER GENERATIONS
HAVING LOWER VOTER TURN OUT. FOR
MANY YOUNG ADULTS THEIR FIRST
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT POLITICAL
PROCESS STARTS IN THAT HIGH
SCHOOL GOVERNMENT CLASS AT A
TIME WHEN MANY STUDENTS ARE
STILL.
SEVENTEEN YOUNG PEOPLE WILL BE
AFFECTED MOST BY ISSUES SUCH AS
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DESERVE TO
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD IN
UPCOMING ELECTIONS.
THEY'RE THE LEADERS ELECTED INTO
OFFICE OVER THE NEXT DECADE WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CLIMATE
POLICIES THAT WILL AFFECT THE
NEXT GENERATION'S FUTURE THE
MOST.
AND SHOULD PROPERLY REPRESENT
THEM.
CATASTROPHIC WILD PRIVATE BUYERS
DROUGHTS FLOODING.
RECORD BREAKING HEAT WAVES
HAZARDOUS AIR QUALITY AND MORE
EXTREME AND FREQUENT WEATHER
EVENTS HAVE BECOME THE NEW
NORMAL FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR YOUNG CALIFORNIANS TODAY
CLIMATE CHANGE ISN'T A DISTANT
CONCEPT IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
THE LIVES AT OR THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF YOUNG PEOPLE MAKE
THEM MORE THAN QUALIFIED TO
PARTICIPATE IN ELECTIONS BECAUSE
ELECTIONS HAVE VERY REAL AND
TANGIBLE EFFECTS ON THEIR LIVES.
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE OUT FRONT AND
THEIR LEADING ON CLIMATE ACTION.
YOUTH ORGANIZATION LIKE THE SUN
RISE WITH YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE SUNRISE MOVEMENT.
HAVE ORGANIZED THEMSELVES TO
HOLD GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE IN
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE.
ON MARCH FIFTEENTH YOUNG PEOPLE
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA JOINT USE
ALL OVER THE GLOBE TO GO ON
STRIKE IN THE NAME OF URGENT
CLIMATE ACTION.
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE ORGANIZED THEIR
MARCHING AND THEY'RE LEADING AND
NOW IT'S TIME TO EXTEND TO THEM
THE RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN
DEMOCRACY.
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF A CA
TO LOWER THE VOTING AGE
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible] THIRTY TOROS LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI I'M SO FEE IS A SKIN FROM
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH IN GOVERNMENT
AND I AM A TEAM VOTER
ORGANIZATION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT A CA AND I URGE YOU TO
AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER COMPUTER LOW ON BEHALF
OF THE MODERATE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANKS.
HI ANYTHING REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF YOUTH ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WITH MARCH FOR LIFE
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR WE TURNED
OUT MILLIONS OF THESE VOTERS AND
HOPEFULLY WITH YOUR I. BUT WE
CAN DO MORE THAT THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE NEED TO PUT A WALL FROM
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KELLY GROWTH SECTION CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KILL ANDY VOTE SIXTEEN AS MC IN
ABBY SANDERS ALSO VOTE SIXTEEN
IT'S MC IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
NEAR THE TASIA FROM THE NATIONAL
YOUTH RIGHTS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
C. NOTICE NOTICES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SO WAS.
START RIGHT HERE AND THEN WE'LL
COME TO IT TO FOLKS NOT PLEASE
PLEASE COME.
YEAH COME ON OVER.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
MY NAME IS ROLE RODRIGUEZ AND I
LIKE I POINTED OUT BEFORE.
I AM.
OPPOSED.
TO A. C. A. A..
N. BASICALLY I ENLISTED IN THE
ARMY WHEN I WAS.
EIGHTEEN I WAS ACTUALLY DRAFTED.
SO IT'S NO LONGER SEVENTEEN IS
WHAT YOU QUOTED IT'S ACTUALLY
SET.
EIGHTEEN AND ALSO LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT ARTICLE [inaudible]
FOR SECTION.
FOUR DECLARES IN OUR
CONSTITUTION THAT THIS IS A
REPUBLIC NOT A DEMOCRACY.
PEOPLE KEEP MAKING THAT MISTAKE
READ THE CONSTITUTION SO YOU
KNOW EXACTLY.
WHAT IT IS THAT MERITS OF THE
BILLS -- I AM.
THAT'S WHY I'M.
I AM I'M I'M AGAINST THIS BILL
SIMPLY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IT
ISN'T THE A GOOD IDEA TO LET
YOUNG.
TEENAGERS.
DETERMINE WHETHER WE THE PEOPLE.
SHOULD DO CERTAIN THINGS BECAUSE
THEY THINK IT'S RIGHT THERE TOO
YOUNG TO BE VOTING.
AT SEVENTEEN I THINK YOU SHOULD
BE LET THAT A TEAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME'S GREG CISCO I AM AN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHAT IN THE WORLD ARE THEY
TEACHING OUR KIDS SINCE NAME IT
MAY THE BILL?
AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE THANK YOU I AM 1100% OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE CALL CALLING BRITAIN
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AGAINST TOLOMEI CONCERNED
CITIZENS A CALIFORNIA -- WITH IN
STRONGLY OBJECT TO THIS WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT THE LATITUDE THAT
YOU GIVE TO THE OTHER PEOPLE YOU
DO NOT EXTEND TO US SO I ASK YOU
TO GIVE US TO DUE PROCESS
HUNTING AT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
RANDAL NELSON I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DEMOCRATS STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE MET TO BURY OPPOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
COUSIN OF A VIETNAM [inaudible]
VETERAN.
WHO WAS KILLED ON THE
BATTLEFIELD VIETNAM?
EQUATING YOURSELF TO THAT.
NO NOPE NAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PICTURES FINANCED IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH C. NOTICE NO OE THIS
IS IN OPPOSITION BRING BACK TO
CALL.
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MOTION SECONDS MISTER ROYSTER WE
HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A SECOND.
SO ONE THING I'D SAY THE YOU
KNOW I DON'T LIKE THIS -- AND I
THINK IT HAPPENS A LOT.
IN OUR CURRENT SOCIETY LIKE
COMPARING GENERATIONS AND LIKE
PETTING GENERATIONS AGAINST EACH
OTHER YOU KNOW YEAH WE'RE ALL
COME FROM DIFFERENT GENERATIONS
MISTER KALRA AN IRON MILLENNIALS.
HEY YOU KNOW -- AND MISTER
BERMAN ARE YOU QUITE.
A LOT.
CARE MEMBER IF YOU'RE IN THEIR
LAN FATHER OF THE MILLENNIAL HE
HE MENTIONED HE ALLUDED TO THIS
MONEY ON THIS EARLIER.
BUT YOU KNOW WE ALL COME FROM
DIFFERENT GENERATIONS I HAVE
RESPECT FOR EVERY GENERATION MY
GRANDFATHER WAS IN WORLD WAR --
TWO YOU KNOW HE'S NINETY FOUR
THIS YEAR AGAIN A LOT OF WISDOM
FROM HIM -- YOU KNOW MY FATHER
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR AND MY
MOTHER AS WELL.
YOUR BABY BOOMER GENERATION.
LOT OF CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS
COUNTRY TO SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW ONE HAS BETTER OR WORSE
LIKE WE ALL HAVE HAD DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE DIFFERENCE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES AND EVERY GENERATION --
SO I REALLY DON'T THINK THIS IS
ABOUT LIKE A GENERATIONAL.
BATTLE AND I THINK REALLY GOT TO
PUT THAT AWAY YOU KNOW -- WHAT I
WOULD ASK THOSE JUST IS THIS IS
QUESTION IS?
IF THE ARGUMENT IS.
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S A RATIONAL
ARGUMENT TO MAKE IF THE ARGUMENT
IS THAT.
HIGH SCHOOLERS.
YOUNG.
YOUNG PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE.
THEN SEVENTEEN IS AN ARBITRARY
NUMBER.
BECAUSE WHY NOT GIVE IT TO ALL
HIGH SCHOOLERS.
WHO ARE WHO ARE FACING THESE
ISSUES WHO ARE?
YOU KNOW WHO CARE ABOUT ALL
THESE DIFFERENT ISSUES A AND AND
REALLY ARE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
EQUATION.
YOU KNOW BOTH SIDES OF ISSUES
THEY'RE THEY'RE CONSERVATIVES OR
LIBERALS THERE AND MAYBE THEY
DON'T CARE.
YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW SO.
YOU KNOW SEVENTEEN IS ARBITRARY.
AND AND IF THE ARGUMENT TRULY IS
THAT WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
THOSE PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOICE IN THIS REPUBLIC YOU'RE
CORRECT SIR IT IS REPUBLIC --
BECAUSE WE ELECT OUR
REPRESENTATIVES WHO THEN VOTE ON
THESE ISSUES FOR US.
WHY NOT THIRTEEN MIGHT LIKE I
SAID MY DAUGHTER'S?
THIRTEEN I HAVE FIVE CHILDREN I
KNOW THAT WHEN THEY'RE THIRTEEN
THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO BE
ABLE THEY'LL BE READY TO VOTE.
YOU KNOW -- AND SO WHY NOT.
NOT ALL THE WAY UP IF THAT'S THE
ARGUMENT ONE OF OPEN ALL THE WAY
UP.
THIS CHAIR MAYBE MY THROUGH YOU --
I HAVE TO TWO SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS THAT WOULD LIKE TO PLEASE
IF THE IF THROUGH.
YOU'RE SO WHY WHY SHOULD YOU BE
ON TITLE AND NOT A FRESH MISTER
VICE CHAIR I THINK WE HEARD THE
QUESTION YET THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER AND I'M ACTUALLY HAPPY
THAT YOU ASKED THAT QUESTION
BECAUSE THERE ARE VERY GOOD
REASONS WHY SEVENTEEN SHOULD BE
THE AGE.
FIRST IS THAT WE'RE TAKING OUR
CIVICS CLASSES IN THEIR SENIOR
YEARS WERE ACTUALLY LEARNING
ABOUT GOVERNMENT AND I WE
ACTUALLY I DID A PRE
REGISTRATION DRIVE AT MY SCHOOL
TO KIND OF FINISH UP OUR AP GOV.
AND THAT WAS A REALLY GOOD WAY
TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET MORE
INVOLVED IN CIVICS AND I THINK
THAT IF WE COULD AND THE YEAR OF
SENIOR YEAR WITH -- REGISTERING
STUDENTS TO VOTE ON THAT WOULD
BE A GREAT WAY TO SEND THEM OFF
INTO OUR SOCIETY IN A WAY WHERE
THEY CAN PARTICIPATE FULLY.
THE SECOND IS THAT SEVENTEEN YOU
CAN BE TRIED AS AN ADULT AND I
PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT IF YOU
CAN BE TRIED AS AN ADULT -- THAT
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE AS
WELL.
THIRD IS THAT WHEN YOU'RE
SEVENTEEN YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
OPERATE HEAVY DANGEROUS
MACHINERY AND YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
DRIVE WITH OTHER PEOPLE IN YOUR
CAR AND SO YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
OTHER PEOPLE'S LIVES IN YOUR
HANDS WE ARE SIXTEEN ALSO KNOW
AT SIXTEEN YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
DRIVE OTHER PEOPLE IN YOUR CAR.
YOU'RE ONLY A DRY ALLOWED YOU
LIVE ALONE IN YOUR CAR YES SIR.
YEAH AND TO KIND OF ADD ON TO
THAT GREAT POINTS.
AS A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD YOUR
YOUR TAKING AN AP GOVERNMENT
CLASS OR SOME SORT OF GOVERNMENT
CLASS SO.
IT IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM RIGHT
NOW IT IN IN MY PERSONAL OPINION.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND CIVIC
EDUCATION IS NOT PLACED AS A
PRIORITY BUT IF VOTING AGE OF
SEVENTEEN AND HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR
FOR VOTING IN OUR ELECTIONS THAT
WOULD GO TO THE TOP OF THE
PRIORITY LIST OF OUR GOVERNMENT
CLASSES.
AND THIS WOULD GIVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WHO ARE SEVENTEEN YEARS
OLD INVALUABLE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME ENGAGED OUR DEMOCRACY AND
EVENTUALLY BECOME LIFELONG
VOTERS BECAUSE ONCE YOU VOTE.
AS A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD YOUR
FIRST SELECTION YOU ARE MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO VOTE IN FUTURE
ELECTIONS AND BECOME A LIFELONG
VOTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
HOW WOULD YOU SAY IN THE EIGHTH
GRADE.
WE STUDY THE U. S. CONSTITUTION
AND SO EIGHTH GRADERS BY THE
TIME THEY'VE GRADUATED GRADING
GOING INTO HIGH SCHOOL HAVE
STUDIED R. U. S.
CONSTITUTIONALLY SIR SUPPOSED --
TO AND HAVE THAT BACKGROUND IN
OUR GOVERNMENT SO.
SO THERE I MEAN IT'S NOT JUST
SEVENTEEN THAT WE LEARNED CIVICS
WE LEARN IT THROUGHOUT OUR
EDUCATION SO YOU CAN MAKE THE
ARGUMENT FOR FOURTEEN YEAR OLDS
ALL -- AGAIN IT TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT -- NOW WHAT WAS THE WHAT
WAS YOUR SECOND POINT GO AHEAD.
YEAH KNOW YOUR SECOND POINT ONE
WAS ABOUT CIVIC CENTER RIGHT --
ONE WAS ABOUT CIVICS -- ABOUT
BEING TRIED AS AN ADULT BUT WE
ALSO OF THIS BODY AGAIN I YOU
MAY BE HEARD ME EARLIER.
THIS BODY IS SAID WE DON'T HOLD
YOU TO THE SAME ACCOUNT IF YOU
COMMIT A CRIME BETWEEN THE AGES
OF EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE
BECAUSE THE JUSTIFICATION IS YOU
DON'T HAVE GOOD ENOUGH JUDGMENT.
IN THAT TIME YOUR BRAINS HAVE
NOT DEVELOPED.
WELL ENOUGH SO THE ARGUMENT
WOULD SEEM TO BE AGAINST.
GIVING YOU THE RIGHT TO VOTE I
MEAN.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS A POWERFUL
THING RIGHT IT'S IT YOU DO HAVE
LIFE AND DEATH AND HANDS YOU
VOTE ON JUDGES WHO WILL MAKE THE
DECISION TO SEND SOMEONE TO THE
DEATH PENALTY YOU VOTE ON A
GOVERNOR WHO HAS THE ABILITY TO
PARDON.
YES IT IS A SERIOUS OBLIGATION
WAS HE LIKE YOU COULD MAKE.
THAT THAT ARGUMENT. TO SAY THAT
IT SHOULD BE OLDER.
UNDER THAT LOGIC RIGHT I CAN
ALSO UNDER THE SAME LOGIC SAY
COULD BE. THIRTEEN SO WHY ARE
YOU DEPRIVE IN THE REST OF YOUR
HIGH SCHOOL.
PIERS OTHER RIGHT TO VOTE THANK
THEN ONLY GIVEN IF.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO INTRODUCE THE
AC IT EITHER I MEAN I I ACTUALLY
RULES WHEN I WILL ACTUALLY MAKE
YOU A I WILL ACTUALLY MAKE THAT
AS A AS OF IF YOU'LL TAKE THAT
AS A FRIENDLY AMENDMENT.
IS IT FRIENDLY YEAH.
BUT IT.
WHY NOT IF IF WE'RE GOING TO
AGAIN THESE ARE ACA'S THEY ARE
THESE ARE ACA'S WERE ASKING THE
PUBLIC YES SIR RIGHT THAT THEIR
ARGUMENT GETS MIDDLE TIME WE'RE
JUST ASKING THE PUBLIC?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THIS
RIGHT TO VOTE SHOULD WE CHANGE
IT.
IF WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT MR
MULLIN ALREADY HAS A BILL THAT
IS AN INCREMENTAL CHANGE YOU CAN
VOTE SEVENTEEN THE PRIMARY FOR
GOING TO BE EIGHTEEN THE GENERAL
RIGHT.
WHY NOT GIVE THE VOTERS TO
DIFFERENT CHOICES ON HIS
INCREMENTAL CHANGE?
AND THEN HAD A A CHOICE ABOUT
SHOULD BE TRULY IN FRANCHISE.
ALL THE USE.
NOT JUST SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS BUT
THOSE WHO ARE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
IF THAT'S REALLY THE ARGUMENT.
PUT THAT BEFORE THE VOTERS AND
ALLOW THEM TO MAKE THAT CHOICE I
WOULD MAKE DOES A FORMAL MEMON
IF YOU WOULD TAKE IT.
WE WILL ALL AT THE AUTHOR
RESPONDED AS CLOSE THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE -- MR LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU JUST
VERY BRIEFLY BECAUSE WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THIS CONVERSATION AT
IN THIS COMMITTEE TODAY BUT I
THINK.
OUR SEVEN KILLED HAVE SPOKEN
VERY CLEARLY AS TO THE AMAZING
POTENTIAL.
OUR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS IN FACT
WILL BE NOT ONE TO EXPAND THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE POOL OF
OPPORTUNITY TO THESE YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS.
JUST IMAGINE THE TRAJECTORY AND
THE TYPE OF CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
THEY'LL MAKE OUR SOCIETY.
THESE TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
COME OUT OF THEIR DAILY LIVES
SCHEDULED TO COME IN STATE
CAPITOL AND TO ADVOCATE FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSUME THE BE
ENGAGED THIS IS EXACTLY THE TYPE
OF ELECTORATE AND CITIZENRY THAT
WE WANT TO SEE.
AND AGAIN PART OF THAT OTHER
CONVERSATION AS THAT THIS ENJOYS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WELL WITH
pSIDES OUT IN FACT OUR JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS A VIETNAM VETERAN
HIMSELF.
WHO ARTICULATES BUT THE REASON
WHY HE SUPPORTING THIS BECAUSE
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN WITH
PARENTAL CONSENT YOU CAN STILL
SERVE FOR YOUR COUNTRY?
IN THE SERVICE SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WE WANT TO PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE OUR
ELECTORATE AND OUR CITIZENRY AND
WITH RESPECT OF TWENTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WITH OVER FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING
THIS MEASURE -- WHICH I
SUPPORTED LAST SAYS IN THE LAST
SESSION WHEN IT WAS A CA -- TEN
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE WITNESSES --
FOR THEIR VERY ELOQUENT -- AND
POISE PRESENTATIONS MUCH MORE
ELOQUENT POISE THAN ANY OF US ON
THE DAIS OTHER THAN DOCTOR WEBER.
WORK WHEN WE WERE YOUR AGE.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THE
EARLIER IT HERE YEAH I'VE SEEN
YOUR BASEBALL CARDS WHEN YOU'RE
SEVENTEENTH RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT THE EARLIER IN LIFE ONE
VOTES.
THE MORE THAN LIKELY THEY ARE TO
FORMULATE LIFELONG HABIT VOTING.
THIS MEASURE GET WILL GIVE YOUTH
A VOICE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
WILL WORK WITH THE AUTHOR OF A
C.. FOR TO ENSURE THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE CONFLICTING MEASURES ON THE
BALLOT I'M HAPPY TO RECOMMEND.
AN AYE VOTE TODAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN AYE GALLAGHER NO
GALLAGHER NO CALDERON.
HI LOW HI LOW AYE MAYES
[inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
WEBER.
WEBER NOT PHONING.
WE'LL KEEP THAT -- THAT THAT
BILLS LONGER THAT A CA IS ON
CALL -- WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
CHORUS [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible] SEVEN YEAH.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR AUTHORS I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE CALL
ON ITEM NUMBER ONE A CA.
FOR BY SOMEONE OR BY SOMEONE
NUMBERMULLIN THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE TWO ZERO I THINK I WAS
ONLY ONE GONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE THAT BILL
IS NOW OUT ON A FOUR TWO ZERO
VOTES.
THAT WAS I'M NUMBER -- ONE RIGHT
NOW.
HE WAS VERY HELPFUL [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH.
WE'RE WAITING FOR HIM.
OKAY.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND AND GIVE
MEMBERS WHO ARE NOW HERE WHO
WEREN'T EARLIER AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ADD ON TO BILLS THAT WE'VE
HEARD.
MADAM SECRETARY.
I'M CONCERNED FOR SB ONE FIFTY
ONE AND SB SIX EIGHTY ONE MAYES.
WEBER.
WEBER I THANK YOU
.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND OPEN
THE ROLE.
UNTIL I MEMBERS THAT ON THE
OTHER BILLS THAT THEY MISSED
MADAM SECRETARY.
ON ITEM TO A CA SIX A BY MCCARTY --
MISS WEBBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ON ITEM FIVE SB SEVENTY
TWO BY ON BURKE [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
WEBER.
WEBER I ITEM EIGHT SB -- FIVE OH
FIVE BURKE MAYES [inaudible]
MULLIN.
WEBER.
WEBER I THANK YOU
.
FROM AT THE CHAIR YOU CAN
APPRECIATE THE THE CRAZINESS OF
HAVING THE CHAIR I WAS I WAS
DOING IT EARLIER TODAY THAT
HEARING WHEN YOU'RE ANY BILLS
HALL OF THE BUILDING.
WE DO APPRECIATE IT'S A SIR YOU
HAVE TO BILLS UP -- LET AND LET
YOU.
TO DETERMINE WHICH ONE YOU WANT
TO PRESENT FIRST.
WE'LL JUST GO AHEAD WITH SP ONE
THIRTY NINE LET'S DO IT.
OKAY SO THIS BILL.
HI HAS TO DO WITH THAT
REDISTRICTING.
AND IT REQUIRES HI.
COUNTIES OVER A CERTAIN SIZE TO
ESTABLISH AN INDEPENDENT HISTORY
COMMISSION.
WHICH ENSURE MORE FAIR
NONPARTISAN SYSTEM FOR DRAWING
THE LINES OF COUNTY.
SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICTS MEMBERS.
ALL OF US WERE ELECTED FROM
DISTRICTS.
BASED ON LINES THAT WERE DRAWN
BY INDEPENDENT ADDITION
COMMISSIONS IN.
IT'S REALLY MUCH MORE FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT IN THE PROCESS THAT
USED TO EXIST WHERE.
THE INCUMBENTS WERE DRAWN THEIR
ALLIANCE.
WE WANT.
TO PUT A SIMILAR PROGRAM IN
PLACE FOR LARGE COUNTIES.
SO AS TO ENSURE FOR A FAIR
PROCESS AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ALL ABOUT.
WITH ME TODAY I'VE GOT NICOLAS I
DON'T WHOSE FROM COMMON CAUSE
AND ALSO DOOR ROSE FROM LEGAL IN
THE VOTERS [inaudible]
PLEASE.
CHAIR BERMAN MEMBERS NICOLAS HAD
ON REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA COME
BECAUSE VERY PROUD CO SPONSORS
BE ONE THIRTY NINE TO ENSURE
FAIR AND INDEPENDENT COUNTY
RETESTING -- PROCESS AND
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST COUNTIES.
GERRYMANDERING OF COURSE HAS NO
PLACE IN OUR DEMOCRACY AT ANY
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT.
GERRYMANDERING HARMS PUBLIC
TRUST IN FAIRNESS FOR PROCESS
UNDERMINES REPRESENT OF NATURE
OF OUR GOVERNMENT.
AND PRIVATE VOTERS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO HOLD ELECTED
OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WHEN IT COMES
TO STATE IN CONGRESSIONAL
REDUCING CALIFORNIA'S DONE MORE
THAN ANY OTHER STATE TO
ELIMINATE GERRYMANDERING.
CALIFORNIA STATE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION WHICH
MOVES FROM THE PROCESSING
COMMENTS WITH NO ELECTORAL SELF
INTEREST IN HOW LINES ARE DRAWN.
IS CONSIDERED THE NATIONAL GOLD
STANDARD FOR REFORM BY ACADEMICS
AS WELL AS REFORMERS.
THIS BILL STANDS AT A PRACTICE
AND BEEN A REDUCING CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST COUNTIES LIKE THE STATE
COMMISSION SB ONE THIRTY NINE
REQUIRES COMMISSIONERS TO MEET
STRICT ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE PRINTING RECENT CAN
IT'S LOBBYIST FOR MAJOR DONORS
FROM SERVING ON THE COMMISSION.
CREATES A RANDOM SELECTION
PROCESS MUCH LIKE A JURY TO
ENSURE THE COMMISSIONERS AND UP
HOLDEN TEN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
THE CARD IS A COUNTY TAKE
AFFIRMATIVE STEPS TO ENSURE THE
COMMISSION REFLECTS THE
DIVERSITY OF THE JURISDICTION.
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION ACT
TRANSPARENCY TRANSPARENTLY
EXCUSE ME HOLD MULTIPLE HEARINGS
FOR MASS CAN BE ADOPTED.
AND PROHIBITS PARTISAN AND PRONE
COMING GERRYMANDERING AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL FOR THE FIRST TIME.
INDEPENDENT REDUCING IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE LEADS MORE
REPRESENT ABOUT COMES AND
PROMOTES TRUST IN FAIRNESS IN
THE PROCESS.
CITIES A COMMISSIONS INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMISSION
CONSISTENTLY SO THEY DO A BETTER
JOB TRYING MAPS KEEP COMMUNITIES
HOLE SPECIALLY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND ARE FAIR TO
POLITICAL PARTIES. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WERE VERY STRONG --
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND WE URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MORE LASER MERIT MORMON MEMBERS --
DOOR ROSE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
ALSO CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TESTIFIED TODAY -- OUR ARE THE
STATELY HELPED LEAD THE FIGHT
FOR INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION AT THE STATE LEVEL IN
OUR LOCAL LEAGUES HELPFULLY THE
MOVEMENT FOR INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IN CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND WHERE IT'S BEEN
IMPLEMENTED OR BEING IMPLEMENTED
IN THE CITIES AND COUNTIES.
AT THEY ARE IN THE TRENCHES
THERE IN THE TRENCHES TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S TRANSPARENCY
IN THE PROCESS THAT IS REALLY
MEANINGFUL ROBUST PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION THE PARTICIPATION
IS DIVERSE.
AND THAT THE COMMISSIONERS THAT
ARE CHOSEN REPRESENTED REFLECT
THE DIVERSITY THE COMMUNITY THAT
ARE COMING FROM -- AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WE DO ALL OF THAT
BECAUSE OF FAIR INCLUSIVE LINE
DRAWING IS REALLY CORD TO GOOD
GOVERNMENT.
UP WITH A LEGISLATIVE BODY DRAWS
ITS OWN LINES THERE IS NOTHING
SORT OF BY NECESSITY A
TEMPTATION TO DRAW THEM IN SUCH
A WAY AS TO HELP OR HURT
INCUMBENTS ARE OR POTENTIAL NEW
MEMBERS TO THE BODY.
OR TO PRESERVE POLITICAL POWER
IN ONE PARTY.
THESE ARE NOT ABSTRACT CONCERNS
WE'RE SEEING THEM WE SEEN THEM
ALL TOO OFTEN SO WE BELIEVE THAT
IT IS TIME TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP.
TO REQUIRE INDEPENDENT.
COMMISSIONS IN LARGE COUNTIES.
FOR REDISTRICTING ON COUNTY
SUPERVISOR OF DISTRICTS TO BUILD
A TRANSPARENCY INTO THAT PROCESS
AS YOU KNOW VOTERS WANT TO KNOW
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO OTE SOMEBODY IN
WHO REFLECTS OUR COMMUNITIES
INTERESTS AT LEAST A SHOT AT IT
THEY WANT TO KNOW THAT ELECTIONS
ARE CLEAN AND FAIR.
AND THIS IS A BIG PART OF THAT
WE ARE A MAJORITY MINORITY STATE.
BUT THAT DIVERSITY IS WOEFULLY
UNDERREPRESENTED AMONG OUR
COUNTY SUPERVISORS -- IN ONE
STUDY IN THE LAST STUDY WHILE
40% OF OUR POPULATION IS LATINO
X. THAT'S STUDY SHOWED THAT ONLY
10% OF OUR POPULATION.
OF OUR COUNTY SUPERVISORS ARE
LATINO X. CLEARLY A BIG PROBLEM
WITH UNDER REPRESENTATION SO BY
FIXING THE WAY THAT WE DRAW
THESE DISTRICT LINES.
WE'RE GONNA BE STE ONE STEP
CLOSER TO A TRULY REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY WHICH IS WHAT A LOT OF
OUR LAWS ARE MOVING TOWARD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- JIM WINBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO PASS
LONG THE SUPPORT OF VOICES FOR
PROGRESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEED THIS NOTICES IN SUPPORT
SING NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR TRAINERS.
PLEASE MR CHECK MORNING AT THE
CHAIR READ AND HEAR THE ANSWER.
I GET.
A JEFF NEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WONDER WHAT THANK THE AUTHOR IN
OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE BROUGHT UP --
ON THE SENATE SIDE.
YOUR MAIN REMAINING CONCERN IS
IS REALLY AROUND FUNDING --
WHILE IT MIGHT SEEM.
INCONSEQUENTIAL AND IN AS
REGARDS TO THE POLICY INVOLVED --
IT MIGHT BE HARD TO BELIEVE BUT
THREE OUT OF FOUR COUNTIES
ACTUALLY STILL HAVE LESS
DISCRETIONARY REVENUE NOW -- ON
A PER CAPITA BASIS IN REAL TERMS
THAN THEY DID BEFORE THE
RECESSION AND THEY'RE A LOT OF
BILLS IN THIS SECTION THE PUT
NEW REQUIREMENTS ON ON COUNTIES --
WITHOUT ANY ANY FUNDING ATTACHED
TO IT SO WHAT THE STATE IS
ENJOINED RECORD -- BUDGET
SURPLUSES.
THAT THREE OUT OF FOUR COUNTIES
ARE STILL STRUGGLING TO RETURN
JUST TO THEIR PRE RECESSION A
REVENUE LEVELS SO -- WE JUST
AGAIN WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
IN THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH
SOME RATHER CONCERNS BUT THE
FUNDING ISSUE IS IS A REAL ONE
AND WANTED TO PASS ALONG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SIR.
YES I'D JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT --
MY NAME IS ROLE RODRIGUEZ JUNIOR
I LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THEY
JUST LOOK THE YOUNG LADY HERE
MADE A COMMENT ABOUT -- LATINOS
HIS THAT THE REMARK YOU'RE
MAKING.
I WASN'T SURE WHAT YOU HAD SAID
BUT I THINK WHEN YO.
TALK ABOUT A SPECIFIC CLASS OF
PEOPLE. TO ME THAT IS
DISCRIMINATION.
BECAUSE YOU ARE SAYING IT'S OKAY
FOR THIS GROUP BUT NOT FOR THIS
GROUP.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT THIS COMMITTEE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU CANNOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST INDIVIDUALS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR RACE COLOR
CREED.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
DOING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU --
THIS IS A FACTUAL POINT -- I
THINK BELIEVE THE POINT WAS A
STATISTICAL DATA POINT ABOUT THE
PERCENTAGE OF LAND NEXT PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA VERSES THE
PERCENTAGE OF LIVE NEXT PEOPLE
WHO ARE ELECTED TO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- SO IS A SYNOPSIS
OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SAY
CORRECT THERE THERE ARE MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS -- I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO USE IS THAT
CORRECT.
THANK YOU SIR -- I APPRECIATE --
THAT FEEDBACK ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT RUN GO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS IN
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS WANT TO
STEAL A PHRASE I HEARD YESTERDAY
AT THE SENATE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE MEETING.
WE ARE OPTIMISTICALLY OPPOSED TO
THIS IS A BILL.
WE ARE OPPOSED BECAUSE IT'S THAT
WE'RE OPPOSED AN OLDER VERSION
OF THE BILL WE ONLY MEET ONCE A
MONTH -- IS SO -- HOWEVER THE
AUTHOR AT WITH HIS -- NEW
AMENDMENTS HI AND THE FACT THAT
HIS OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING VERY
DILIGENTLY WITH US AND THE
SPONSORS AS WELL.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE'RE OPTIMISTIC
AND MAYBE ADDRESSING SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS AT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- ROBIN FITS IN WITH
REMEMBRANCE PROJECT WE URGE A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU GRAY GALLON
REMEMBRANCE PROJECT WE URGE OF
NOVO.
THE TREES LINED TIRED GENOVA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEY HAD COMPANION I'M OPPOSED
THANK YOU SIR.
DIANA BARBA OPPOSED PLEASE VOTE
NO THANK YOU MA'AM.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SAYING ON BRING BACK
TO COLLEAGUES. FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I'VE LOST TRACK I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS ONE ALREADY HAS A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
DOESN'T.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ANY COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES
SEEING NONE NOW BRING BACK TO
THE SENDER TO CLOSE.
WE'RE LOSING STEAM HERE YEAH.
WE'LL DO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE THE DISCUSSION AYE AYE AYE I
WILL SAY I MEAN I I I DON'T.
I I ABSOLUTELY STAND THE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED BUT FOR OUR
FRIENDS IN THE COUNTIES I WILL
SAY THAT.
THAT ACCORDING THIS BILL
ANYTHING FOR THOSE COUNTIES SOME
WILL BE BETWEEN 225-000-0750.
THOUSAND IS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION -- AND AND IN ITS
WE'RE ONLY TALKING ABOUT THE
LARGEST COUNTIES THAT ARE THAT
ARE IMPLICATED BY THIS AND THOSE
ARE COUNTY SAID OF COURSE HAVE.
YOU KNOW SOME MORE RESOURCES
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGES THAT
WE'VE MADE I WE SING THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY TO LOWER THE COST
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE GRAND JURY'S
WHICH ALREADY.
SET.
OUT.
GOOD RUNNING THE PROCESS OF THE
RANDOM SELECTION OF THE MEMBERS
I WILL SAY I I'M A LITTLE
MYSTIFIED BY SOME OF THE ON THE
THE OTHER OPPOSITION BECAUSE IN
THE END OF THE DAY -- THIS IS A
BILL THAT.
DOES IT DOES A REALLY WORKS HARD.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
PARTISAN ADVANTAGE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PROCESS THAT'S WHY A
LOT OF OUR GOOD GOVERNMENT
GROUPS ARE ARE SO FIRMLY IN
SUPPORT -- AND SO I I YOU KNOW
HAPPY TO TALK TO THEM AND AND
AND LEARN LEARN THEIR CONCERNS
BUT BUT THIS IS A THIS IS A BILL
THAT -- THAT THEY PUT IN PLACE A
SYSTEM THAT I THINK WILL BE MUCH
FAIR FOR EVERYBODY -- IN IN IN
IN AND WE WE SPECIFICALLY SAID --
THAT THAT NO ONE PARTY CAN HAVE
IT HAVE A MAJORITY INCLUDING IN
A PLACE LIKE SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
THERE'S A HUGE MAJORITY OF
DEMOCRATS.
ARE SO SO WE REALLY YOUR MADE
SURE THERE BE A BALANCE BETWEEN
INDEPENDENTS REPUBLICANS
DEMOCRATS ANDOTHERS.
AND AND I THINK THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST MIGHT.
YEAH -- OVER THE LETTERS REJECT
SO SO WE REALLY ARE ARE ARE ARE
STRIVING FOR FOR VERY CAREFUL
FAIRNESS HERE HAPPY TO TALK TO
ANYONE WHO'S GOT CONCERNS THAT
AREA BUT WITH THAT I I RESPECT
FASTER.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN IN A YOU
KNOW.
GERMANY DURING IS A BIPARTISAN
EFFORT TO SUPPRESS THE WILL OF
VOTERS -- AND ELIMINATING JR
MENTORING IS A NON PARTISAN
EFFORT TO SHOO THE ROB RISE UP
THE VOICE OF VOTERS -- AND MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS APPROPRIATE
REPRESENTATION AND AND THAT --
INAPPROPRIATE FACTORS ARE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT WHEN DECIDING HOW
TO DRAW THE DISTRICTS -- I THINK
IT'S WORKED GREAT V<c.cyan>-- WERE</c>
VERY WELL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- EVEN THOUGH AT THE
TIME IT WAS OPPOSED BY BOTH.
BIG PARTIES IN CALIFORNIA BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY BOTH OPPOSE THOSE WHICH
PROBABLY TELLS YOU THAT IT WAS
THE RIGHT POLICY -- THE KIND AND
I JUST WANNA POINT WE DID HAVE
BIPARTISAN VOTES ON THE DOT ON
THE SENATE SIDE YEAH -- SO WE
HAD REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
SUPPORT I WOULD I WOULD EXPECT
SO -- SO APPRECIATE YOU CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
THAT YOU CAN -- AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THANK YOU.
THE MOST IS TO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BERMAN AYE
BERMAN AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CALDERON.
LOW LOW I'M MAYES.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER HI.
THAT BILL PASSES ON A FIVE DAY
ZERO WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
LIKE TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB.
SIX FORTY ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS IN A I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THAT CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THE HOSPITAL.
SO THIS IS A MODEST BILL I'M IT
WILL EXTEND THE TIMELINE FOR
SPECIAL ELECTION CONSOLIDATION
FROM HUNDRED EIGHTY TO TWO
HUNDRED DAYS FOLLOWING THE
ELECTION PROCLAMATION.
THIS ODD CAME TO MY MIND BECAUSE
WE HAD A SITUATION LESS ANGELES
WHERE WE WERE HAVING THERE'S A
CERTAIN PORTION OF LA THAT WAS
HAVING AN ELECTION EVERY MONTH --
THEY HAD A CITY COUNCIL READ
ELECTION IN A AND THEN AND THEN
THEY HAD A SPECIAL FOR THE FOR
FOR THE CONGRESSIONAL SEAT THAT
HAVE EVER SERRA HAD HAD VACATED
THEN THERE WAS IT.
THE GENERAL THEN THEN THEY HAD
TO DO.
THERE IS A CITY COUNCIL AND THE
SCHOOL BOARD AND THEN AGAIN
ASSEMBLY TWO ROUNDS OF ASSEMBLY
IT JUST CRAZY AND BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THAT WE WANT BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THAT THE RULES WERE WRITTEN.
ON THERE JUST WASN'T ENOUGH
FLEXIBILITY IN THE CALENDARING
TO ALLOW FOR CONSOLIDATION.
SO THIS JUST GIVES A LITTLE BIT
MORE FLEXIBILITY I WANTED ALSO
KIND OF EXPANDED OUT TO MAKE IT
SO THAT THE ELECTION COULD BE
DECLARED EARLIER BUT WE WE GOT A
LOT OF CONCERNS FROM OUR CLERKS
AND OTHERS -- BUT I IN YOU THE
DAY THIS GIVES A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY SO AS TO ALLOW FOR A
LITTLE BIT MORE COHERENCE. TO TO
TO THE SPECIAL ACTIONS THAT ARE
CALLED.
AND WITHOUT A RESPECT YESTERDAY
VOTE.
THE CENTER WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS A
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S SO YOU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SING NINE BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER VICE CHAIR YEAH
SO I MEAN YOU KNOW WE'RE HERE TO
TWO HUNDRED DAYS NOW LIKE I MEAN.
HOW MUCH OF A DIFFERENCE IS THAT
GONNA MAKE LIKE IN THE INSTANCE
OF YOUR?
YOUR YOUR QUANDARY IN LA COUNTY
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT
WOULD HAVE ALLOWED FROM FOR ONE
CONSOLIDATION IN THAT CASE -- SO
YEAH IT'S NOT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
THE MOST EARTH SHATTERING BILL
BUT IF IT SAVES.
I BOTH THE TAXPAYERS -- THE
EXPENSE ASSOCIATED WITH ONE
ADDITIONAL SPECIAL ELECTION
NEEDLESSLY -- THAT CAN ACTUALLY
ALLOW FOR A LITTLE BIT MORE TURN
OUT FROM.
MAYBE. 7% 212%.
I THINK IT WILL HAVE BEEN
WORTHWHILE AND FOR AN INDIAN THE
ONLY OTHER CONCERN THAT.
IS THE OTHER THE FLIP SIDE OF
THAT IS WHEN WE LOSE WHEN WE
HAVE A VACANCY WE WANT TO TRYING
TO GET.
SOMEONE IN THAT SEAT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND AND SOMETIMES THESE
THINGS GET DRAGGED OUT.
A WHILE RIGHT AND SO THAT'S
ANOTHER CONCERN I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH YOU AND IT IS MY CONCERN AS
WELL.
YOU KNOW THAT THE MOST THIS ONLY
EXTENDS ABOUT TWENTY DAYS -- AND
I THINK THE PUBLIC POLICY
ADVANTAGES ASSOCIATED WITH
SAVING THE COST OF ANOTHER
ELECTION -- WAYS THE TWENTY DAYS --
BUT YOU THIS IS NOT -- THE MOST
GROUNDBREAKING BILL THAT I'VE
EVER RUN BUT I I DO I BUT I
REALLY DO I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS GOOD PUBLIC POLICY AND I
THINK I THINK THE THAT'S WHAT WE
HAD.
YEAH THIRTY SEVEN ZERO VOTE OVER
THE SENATE SIDE -- THIRTY SEVEN
TO ZERO YEAH THAT'S OUT OF FORTY
INTO OR OUT OF THIRTY NINE
THAT'S RIGHT THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT WHO KNOWS MAKING SURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS REALIZE YEAH
YEAH.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
AS RIGHT SEEING NONE OF THIS IS
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I I DO APPRECIATE.
YOUR CONSIDERATION LISTEN AND
RESTRAINT YOU THE CENTER IN
LIGHT OF THE HIGH COST OF
HOLDING SPECIAL VACANCY
ELECTIONS IN THE LOW VOTER.
PARTICIPATION THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
RECENT SPECIAL ELECTIONS IT IS
SENSIBLE TO TAKE FURTHER STEPS
TO ENCOURAGE THE CONSOLIDATION
IN SPECIAL ELECTIONS WITH OTHER
SCHEDULED ELECTIONS THIS BILL
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
THAT CAN RESULT IN A LARGER
NUMBER SPECIAL ELECTIONS BEING
CONSOLIDATED.
WITH OTHER ELECTIONS FOR THAT
REASON I'M HAPPY TO RECOMMEND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
MISTER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BERMAN HI
BERMAN I'D GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NONVOTING CALDERON.
LOW.
WELL I MAYES.
MULLIN MULLIN AYE WEBER
[inaudible]
I THAT'S OUT ON A FOUR ZERO VOTE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU FIFTY SENATOR
YOU CAN ONLY AFFORD TO LOSE ONE
MORE AND KEEP YOUR RATIO THAT
YOU HAD ON THE SENATE SIDE I
KNOW.
YEAH YEAH YEAH WORKING THANK YOU
YEAH BRIDGET.
SO NOW WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
HE'S GOT THE HI BILL OF THE DAY
[inaudible]
HE'S [inaudible]
NO SIR.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING AND AND CAN
WE
WHAT THE
SO WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THE SENATOR -- OR A
SENATOR -- WHEN WE OPEN UP OTHER
ITEMS THAT ARE ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS?
MADAM SECRETARY -- WHAT WE'RE
GONNA OPEN UP THE KICKING
[inaudible]
THE WHAT
.
I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
BY SOME NUMBER LOW THE CURRENT
VOTERS THREE ZERO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MAYES.
NOT VOTING MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
GREAT.
THE BILL PASSES ON A FOUR ZERO
VOTE.
AS A WIN VOTER
.
IF WE CAN MAKE THE WHOLE IDEA.
IF MADAM SECRETARY UNTIL THE
CENTER GETS HERE LET'S -- ALLOW
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON THE
BILLS THEY MISS.
WHERE A STOP WHEN THE CENTER
GETS HERE?
HOLD ON A SECOND.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
SORRY FOR FOR PULLING YOU OUT OF
YOUR PRE EXISTING OBLIGATION.
SO WE HAVE A SENATE MCGUIRE --
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
TWENTY SEVEN WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
FIRST OF ALL START WITH AN
APOLOGY. TO ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN THE CHAIR.
WE ARE HAVING A CAUCUS ON ALL
ISSUES OF BUDGET TRAILER BILL
TODAY SO I AM SO SORRY NOT AT
ALL THANK YOU -- IN THANK YOU --
FOR YOUR PATIENCE ALL THIS TO BE
VERY BRIEF SINCE WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR -- SB --
TWENTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE TAX
RETURNS FIVE YEARS TO BE
RELEASED BY THE PRESIDENT.
VICE PRESIDENT AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY PRIMARY
ELECTION.
IN EVERY PRIMARY ELECTION --
LEADING INTO THE FUTURE RELATED
TO THE PRESIDENT VICE PRESIDENT
AND THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
WHEN THEY'RE ON THE BALLOT?
HI THE SECTOR A STATE IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THOSE ITEMS WOULD BE REJECTED ON
THE SECOND TATE'S WHAT SECRETARY
OF STATE'S WEBSITE.
AND IT WOULD REQUIRE ALL PARTIES.
TO TAKE PART WITHIN THE BILL.
AS WE KNOW.
IT'S A REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT WE
KNOW THERE ARE SEVERAL DEMOCRATS
HAVE YET TO RELEASE A RETURNS
LIKE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN.
HE TOO WOULD BE REQUIRED TO BE
IN A RELEASE THOSE RETURNS HAPPY
TO GET ANY QUESTIONS A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE MOST APPROPRIATETIME.
AND AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I REALLY APOLOGIZE ABOUT
KEEPING YOU WAITING TODAY NOT
NOT AT ALL THANK YOU SENATOR AND
THE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MARK ON BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE FOR
THE REASONS STATED WE SUPPORT
THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- I'M SORRY I
APOLOGIZE I WENT TO QUICKLY.
THE WHEN THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE YEAH MY NAME'S ALAN
CHAPMAN I'M HERE FOR INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI ANGELA CHAPMAN I'M HERE FOR
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO AND
INDIVISIBLE STATE STRONG
CALIFORNIA AND WHEN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO IN
INDIVISIBLE -- CALIFORNIA STAY
STRONG IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A DAY YET SO YOU. TWO TO THREE
WITNESSES ARE WALKING THE COME
UP FOR A TOTAL OF SIX MINUTES.
OF TIME I'LL GO AHEAD AND KEEP
THE CLOCK.
ALLA Y'ALL DECIDE WHO WANTS.
TO SET UP AT THE TABLE.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT SERVE EXITING
KEEPING THE CLOCK EVERY TIME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
THAT DO YOU WORK YEP.
PLEASE.
BEFORE I START -- TEN MINUTES
FOR PERSON OR TWO MINUTES SO
WITH A TOTAL OF SIX MINUTES I'M
GONNA LET YOU ALL DECIDE HOW YOU
WANT TO BREAK IT UP ON IT LOOKS
LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO
SPEAK -- BUT WELL THE REASON I'M
BRINGING THAT UP THE VERY FIRST
THAT THE PEOPLE WITH THE ALL
GERMAN.
HE WAS FOUR AND A HALF MINUTES
THE OTHER LADY WAS THREE AND
THREE QUARTERS.
THE OTHER SUBSEQUENT --
WITNESSES WERE ALSO WELL OVER
TIME SO AND I'M JUST.
SO WHY DON'T OKAY -- WHY DON'T
WE SAY IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'VE GOT
FOUR PEOPLE APPEAR TO SPEAK OUR
EVERYBODY GETS THREE MINUTES
WHICH WILL BE YOUR TOTAL TWELVE
MINUTES TWICE AS LONG AS USUAL
ABSOLUTELY?
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I'M RICHARD WINGER WITH THE
BALLOT.
THEY GO BALLOT ACCESS NEWS AND
ALSO THE LIBERTARIAN PARTY.
THIS BILL IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
UNDER BOTH THE FEDERAL AND THE
STATE CONSTITUTIONS.
WHEN I TESTIFIED AGAINST HIS
BILL IN THE SENATE I HADN'T
THOUGHT ABOUT THE STATE
CONSTITUTION?
BUT THE STATE CONSTITUTION IS
QUITE SIMPLE.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE WILL.
PUT RECOGNIZE CANDIDATES ON THE
BALLOT IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE DOES NOT
HAVE UNBRIDLED DISCRETION TO
DECIDE WHO IS RECOGNIZED.
ARMS TO PASS -- LAROUCHE VERSUS
YOU HAS THAT BEEN DONE.
I DON'T KNOW SO MAKE SURE IT
GETS DONE.
YEP WE'RE ON RIGHT NOW THANK YOU
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO MRS YOU
KEPT -- LYNDON LAROUCHE OFF THE
BALLOT SHE DIDN'T THINK HE WAS
RECOGNIZED AS THE WORD.
AND THE COURT DISAGREED THEY
SAID LOOK HE'S ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY BALLOT OF
TWENTY ONE OTHER STATES.
HE'S BEEN ON THE CALIFORNIA
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY BALLOT
BEFORE.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY RECOGNIZED AND SO
THAT'S THE SIXERS STATE JUST
CANNOT SAY THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS NOT A RECOGNIZED CANDIDATE.
AND I WON'T GO ON ABOUT THE
FEDERAL CONSTITUTION.
BUT I'LL JUST SAY A ONE MORE
THING THERE FIFTEEN STATES.
WHERE THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
MAJORITY IN BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR?
AND NO OTHER ONE OF THOSE STATES
HAS PASSED THIS KIND OF A BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS CALLING BRITAIN.
OF I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS ONE THIS BILL APPEARS
TO BE TOTALLY POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
IT SEEMS TO BE TARGETED AGAINST
A SINGLE CANDIDATE.
IT IS AIMED AT SUPPRESSING VOTE
OF OPPOSITION CANDIDATES IS
AGAINST EVERY ACT OF
TRANSPARENCY AND INCLUSIVENESS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE AND THIS.
CONGRESS -- THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY PURPORTS TO SUPPORT SO --
IS BENEATH YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
MY NAME IS ROLE RODRIGUEZ JUNIOR.
AND I'M HERE AS A CALIFORNIA
COORDINATOR FOR AMERICA FIRST
LATINOS TO ASK YOU TO VOTE NO ON
SB TWENTY SEVEN BECAUSE IT WILL.
DISENFRANCHISE CALIFORNIA
LATINOS BY UNLAWFULLY DEPRIVING
A PROTECTED CLASS FROM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE LIBERTY
AND FREEDOM TO VOTE. FOR DONALD
J. TRUMP.
FURTHERMORE SB TWENTY SEVEN IS A
POLL TAX.
I'M ALSO HERE AT SOMEONE WHO RAN
IN THE LAST ELECTION. FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE.
ALTHOUGH I DIDN'T WIN I GOT
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
VOTES.
FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
VETOED AN IDENTICAL BILL.
SB ONE FORTY NINE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE QUESTIONED THE
TACTICS BEHIND A NEW BALLAD
[inaudible]
QUALIFYING REQUIREMENT.
WHICH IS A DEFINITION BI.
DEFINITION A POLL TAX.
BECAUSE IT APPEARS TO SINGLE OUT
CANDIDATES THAT HAVE A DIFFERENT
VISION.
OF GOVERNING NOT TO MENTION.
IT DISREGARDS THE CIVIL RIGHTS.
A BOTH THE CANDIDATES.
AND THOSE.
WHO ARE VOTING?
IN CALIFORNIA IT IS AGAINST THE
LAW TO DO VIEWPOINT
DISCRIMINATION.
WE THINK SB TWENTY SEVEN IS.
BECAUSE IT SUDDENLY REQUIRES
FINANCIAL TAX FILINGS UNDER THE
FATE REASON.
OF MORE TRANSPARENCY IN AND
INFORMATION WHEN IN REALITY.
WE LIVE IN.
AN ERA OF THE INTERNET.
WHERE ANYONE WHO WANTS TO FIND
OUT ANYTHING GENERALLY CAN?
SO THIS FEEBLE ATTEMPT TO GIVE
MORE INFORMATION IS JUST SMOKE
AND MIRRORS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY SB TWENTY
SEVEN SPOUSE LIKE A DIFFERENT
VERSION OF A POLL TAX.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AS HE TWENTY
SEVEN FOR ANYONE WATCHING THIS.
HEARING THIS PHONE NUMBER IS
FOUR IN. FOR REPORTING CIVIL
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
[inaudible]
AND IN FINISH IN FINISHING MY
STATE MAN.
THERE ARE QUALIFICATION FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ARTICLE TWO OF THE CONSTITUTION
SECTION.
ONE CLAUSE FIVE OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
SAYS THAT THE PRESIDENT MUST
NUMBER.
ONE BEING A NATURAL BORN CITIZEN
AND NUMBER TO BE AT LEAST THIRTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE.
AND NUMBER.
THREE HAVE LIVED IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. FOR AT LEAST
FOURTEEN YEARS THOSE ARE THE
ONLY QUALIFICATIONS FOR A
PRESIDENT.
SO WHATEVER ELSE IS GOING ON IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS.
A BLATANT DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THANK YOU SIR.
EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
LATITUDE FOR OF ALL THESE
PRESENTATIONS -- I'M SIMPLY
GOING TO READ FROM ON THE SHEET
OF PAPER SO IT CAN BE MORE
SUCCINCT IN IN SHORT IF I MAY.
UP MY NAME IS STILL IN MAY AND
I'M HERE IS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONCERNED CITIZENS THE
CALIFORNIA.
DIVORCE OUR OBJECTIONS TO SB
TWENTY SEVEN IN ITS ATTEMPT TO
DEPRIVED CALIFORNIA CITIZENS OF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE FOR A
DULY QUALIFIED PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
ABSENT AND NEW UNLAWFUL AND
FRAUDULENT ELIGIBILITY
QUALIFICATION BEYOND THAT WHICH
IS PRESCRIBED IN OUR
CONSTITUTION.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THEN
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN VETOED SB
ONE FORTY NINE IDENTICAL BILL
WARNING QUOTE.
WHAT WOULD BE NEXT FIVE YEARS OF
HEALTH RECORDS A CERTIFIED BIRTH
CERTIFICATE AT CETERA?
DEPRIVATION OF RIGHTS UNDER
COLOR OF LAW UNDER EIGHTEEN USC
SECTION TWO FORTY TWO MAKES IT A
CRIME TO WILLFULLY DEPRIVE A
PERSON OF A RIGHT OR PRIVILEGE
PROTECTED BY THE CONSTITUTION OR
U. S. LAWS.
AND INCLUDES ACTS DONE BY THE
STATE OFFICIALS THE CRIME OF
WHICH INCLUDES FINES OR
IMPRISONMENT OR BOTH.
THEN THERE'S ARTICLE ONE OF THE
US CONSTITUTION WHICH
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBITS THE
PASSING OF ANY FORM OF BILLS OF
ATTAINDER BY BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATES
BECAUSE THEY NOTIFY THE TARGETED
PERSON CIVIL RIGHTS.
IN US VERSUS LOVETT SCOTUS
OPINED THAT CONGRESS HAD
EXCEEDED ITS POWER WHEN IT
ENACTED LEGISLATION THAT
DISQUALIFIED PEOPLE FROM
POSITIONS OF EMPLOYMENT I. E..
THEY CREATED A BILL OF ATTAINDER.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE US
SUPREME COURT AGAIN ADDRESS THE
BILL OF ATTAINDER CLAUSE IN US
THE BROWN.
SPECIFICALLY REJECTED A NARROW
HISTORICAL PRO WHICH IN A PINE
TO PROHIBIT QUOTE LEGISLATIVE
PUNISHMENT OF ANY FORM OR
SEVERITY AND QUOTE.
AS SPECIFIED IN USB BROWN AND IN
OPPOSITION TO THE NINTH CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS POSITION.
SCOTUS HELD THAT EXCLUSION FROM
APPOINTMENT IS A FORM OF AND
THEREFORE SB TWENTY SEVEN WILL
CERTAINLY DEPRIVE ANY
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
FROM THE OPPORTUNITY OF
EMPLOYMENT IF THEY DON'T SUBMIT
TO YOUR NEW TAX RETURN QUALIFIER
BUST.
SB TWENTY SEVEN VIOLATE CIVIL
RIGHTS IN OTHER LAWS AS WELL AS
NUMEROUS PROTECTIONS DEFINED
WITHIN THE US CONSTITUTION.
NOW FOR THE TWO OF YOU HOLD LAWS
AGREES PRESUMABLY YOU SHOULD BE
AWARE OF THE AFTER MENTIONED
LAWS.
AND PROTECTIONS THE OTHERS NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT BY VOTING TO
APPROVE SB TWENTY SEVEN TODAY.
YOU PERSONALLY -- WILL BE
VIOLATING EIGHTEEN USC SECTION
TWO FORTY TWO AND SUBJECT TO
FINES AND OR IMPRISONMENT BY
VOTING YES.
UNDER COLOR OF LAW IN AUTHORITY
SO WE STRONGLY ASK YOU. TO VOTE
NO ON SB TWENTY SEVEN OF FOR ALL
THE AFOREMENTIONED REASONS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRING IT BACK EXCUSE ME -- SING
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME'S GREG GALLON I WANT TO
VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP FOR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SIR.
I'LL TAKE THAT AS A NO ON THE
BILL.
I THINK THE ENTIRE NATION WILL
SEE THIS IS AN ATTEMPT. TO
SUPPRESS THE CONSERVATIVE VOTE
FOR ALL CANDIDATES ESPECIALLY IN
A STATE THAT HAS A TOP TWO
SECTORS SYSTEM.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS IT
MAKES CALIFORNIA LOOK LIKE A RIG
STATE I'M SORRY FROM A TOTALLY
OPPOSE AGAINST US THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GINA BELLA THE REMEMBRANCE
PROJECT.
WE THE PEOPLE RISING TRUMP
TWENTY TWENTY SEVERELY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
JEAN MACLEOD CALIFORNIA CITIZEN
THIS IS NOT A DICTATORSHIP I
OPPOSE THIS.
THANK YOU TO BEAR SPENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
IN MY OPINION YOU GUYS BUT LET
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME GET
TO YOUR HEAD SPOKE NO THANK YOU
MA'AM.
A MAN NO THANK YOU MA'AM.
DEMOCRATS STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU SIR.
TREES LINE STRONGLY OPPOSES
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS MISTER WILLIS I
REPRESENT THE HEATERS FOR TRUMP.
AND I STRONGLY DENOUNCE YOUR
PATHETIC ATTEMPT TO STIFLE MY
VOICE.
ROB ME OF MY VOTE AND
MARGINALIZE ME AS A CITIZEN GROW
UP AND TRUMP IS YOUR PRESENT ANY
WILL CONTINUE TO BE YOUR
PRESIDENT BUDDY THANK AND SIR
SIR I'M GONNA ASK.
EVERYBODY I'M I'M GOING TO
REQUEST THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
DISPLAYS ON ANY SIDE OF ANY
ISSUE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
BECAUSE WE WANT EVERYONE TO FEEL
COMFORTABLE EXPRESSING THEIR
OPINION IN THIS ROOM.
THANK YOU IF YOU CAN PLEASE KEEP
IT TO YOUR NAME AT THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT WOULD
BE GREATLY APPRECIATED.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE MORE
THAN FOUR AND A HALF MILLION.
CALIFORNIANS WHO VOTED FOR TRUMP
DON'T DISCRIMINATE US VOTE NO TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM.
BRING IT BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I'M
GONNA GO THAT THIS ONE NUMBER
MAYES AN INVESTOR GALLAGHER AND
THEN ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
PLEASE -- MAN I WISH I COULD
SUPPORT THIS TODAY -- BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY THINK.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR SOMEBODY
RUNNING FOR THE PRESENT
PRESIDENCY.
AT TO BE ABLE TO DISCLOSE THEIR
FINANCIAL RECORDS WE ALL HAVE
OUR OWN -- DISCLOSURES -- WE
HAVE OUR OWN DISCLOSURES WE WE
HAVE HERE BUT THE THE POWER OF
THE PRESIDENCY.
IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT I
THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
TO BE ABLE TO KNOW WHAT
CONFLICTS MIGHT BE MIGHT BE
THERE THE ONLY WAY TO BE ABLE TO
KNOW THAT IS WITHIN.
OF THOSE READ THOSE RETURNS --
SIR OUTSIDE INTERRUPT I'M GONNA
ASK YOU TO KEEP THAT SIGN DOWN
IT WE I I'VE ALLOW THE SIGNS
WHICH WE NORMALLY WOULDN'T ALLOW
AT ALL BUT I'M GONNA ASK.
YEAH BUT IT'S ACTUALLY NOT WE
HAVE RULES IN THE LEGISLATURE
BUT I'M GONNA ASK YOU NOT TO TRY
TO BLOCK OTHER PEOPLE WITH THE
SIGN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER MISS I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO -- I DO WISH THAT THE
THAT OUR PRESIDENT MOM BUT
WHATEVER LEASES TAX RETURNS I
THINK IT'S CREATED -- TOO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY AND AND THIS THOUGHT
THAT SOMEHOW THERE'S GOTTA BE
SOMETHING IN THERE THAT -- THAT
THAT HE WANTS TO KEEP HIDDEN SO
I I WISH THAT HE WOULD -- MY
QUESTION -- IS THOUGH I HAVE
THIS BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ACTUALLY ASKED LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL.
OF FOR A BRIEF ON THIS AND I
DON'T TO READ THROUGH ALL OF IT--
BUT THEY THERE'S A CASE CALLED
THORTON -- THAT -- THEY HAD USED
AFFECT I'VE LOST MY I LOST IT
HERE YOU HAVE IT YEAH.
HERE IT IS SAYS -- TWO POINT
THREE IS WHAT THIS IS AND AND
THEIR FATHER THEY GAVE IS -- AS
DESCRIBED ABOVE WE CONCLUDE THAT
A COURT WOULD MORE LIKELY THAN
NOT FIND IT SB ONE FOUR NINE
HANDICAPS PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES REFUSE DISCLOSURE TAX
RETURNS.
AND IT APPEARS TO HAVE THE
PURPOSE OF CREATING A
QUALIFICATION INDIRECTLY NAY
GOES ON TO SAY THAT -- THAT THE
QUALITY QUALIFICATIONS CLAUSE
THE CONSTITUTION IT WOULDN'T BE
MET I THINK THAT'S WHY THIS WAS
VETOED BY THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT AND AND
IT WOULD MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF
SENSE FOR US TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS HERE IF -- IF THIS ENDED
UP GOING THROUGH THE COURTS IN
IT BEING -- RULED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL NO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT ISN'T A MEMBER
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR THROUGH THE CHAIR -- IN
THROUGH COMMITTING PRESS FOR
THIS ONE SAY.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF THE
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AND I THINK
THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE ARE --
ISSUES AND OPINIONS ON ALL SIDES.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
POLL AFTER POLL SHOWS THAT
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF AMERICANS
WANT THE PRESIDENT NOT JUST
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD A RELEASED HIS OR
HER TAX RETURNS.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF LEGAL
OPINIONS.
ON THIS ISSUE WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO TALK TO THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF THE BILL -- AND THEN ALSO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE SCHOLARS
WHO HAVE LOOKED AT THIS BILL.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
KNOW WHERE IT STATES HAVE THE
ABILITY ON BALLOT ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS OR WE DO NOT.
SO IT'S VERY CLEAR WHERE THE
CITY CALIFORNIA HAS THE ABILITY
TO IMPOSE BALLOT ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS.
IT WOULD BE -- INCLUDING
RELEASING YOUR TAX RETURNS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT TARGETED TO ONE
INDIVIDUAL.
OR ONE CANDID.
IF IT IS EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
IN IN THIS BILL IT'S ONLY FOCUS
ON THE MARCH PRIMARY.
THE REASON WHY IT'S FOLKS IN THE
MARCH PRIMARY BECAUSE STATES
HAVE FULL AUTHORITY CALIFORNIA
PER CONSTITUTION HAS FULL
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO IMPOSE.
BALLOT ACCESS REQUIREMENTS IN
OUR PRIMARY.
WE DO NOT IN THE GENERAL BECAUSE
THAT'S UP TO THE POLITICAL PARTY.
WHETHER IT'S THE REPUBLICANS THE
DEMOCRATS THE GREENS
LIBERTARIANS YOU NAME.
AND IT IS IN THE STATE
CONSTITUTION.
LET'S DEFINE ABOUT ACCESS
REQUIREMENTS.
SIGNATURE GATHERER REQUIREMENTS
FILING FEES TO MIDDLE DEADLINES
FOR THE SECRETARY STATE.
AND RELEASING YOUR TAX RETURNS.
WE HAVE LANGUAGE WITHIN THE BILL
THIS IS IF YOU DO NOT PAY TAXES
YOU CAN STILL GET ON THE BALLOT
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO FILE FORM
DISSECTOR STATES OFFICE.
IN YOUR NAME APPEAR ON THE
BALLOT.
IF YOU DON'T FILE TAXES.
I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THERE ARE
THREE DEMOCRATS THUS FAR THEY
HAVE NOT SHARED THEIR TAX
RETURNS FOR THE PUBLIC.
THOSE THREE WOULD NOT APPEAR ON
THE MARCH PRIMARY BALLOT.
ALONG AND IF HE CHOOSES
PRESIDENT TRUMP -- AND IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT FOR THE
PAST FORTY YEARS PAST FORTY
YEARS.
EVERY PRESIDENT.
REPUBLICAN DEMOCRATIC LIKE.
HAVE RELEASE OUR TAX RETURNS.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN LOOKED AT BY
THE FORMER ETHICS ATTORNEY FOR
GEORGE W. BUSH.
BARACK OBAMA AS WELL AS LAWRENCE
TRIBE.
ALL BELIEVE AT THIS WALL WITH
PAINT WITH A STAND A
CONSTITUTIONAL ARGUMENT.
NOW.
WILL THIS BE CHALLENGED IN COURT
YOU'RE RIGHT IT WILL BE.
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT
SHOULD BE CHALLENGED IN COURT.
BECAUSE NO MATTER IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT OR YOU'RE REPUBLICAN.
YOU SHOULD PUT YOUR NATION
BEFORE YOUR POLITICS IN YOUR
PERSONAL BELIEFS.
IN HAS RELEASING OF TAX RETURNS
IN THE PAST BECAUSE CHALLENGES
FOR THOSE WHO RUN FOR OFFICE
YOU'RE RIGHT IT HAS.
BUT INCOME TAX RETURNS AS MISTER
MESA JUST SAID NO PARAPHRASING
HERE PROVIDE VOTERS WITH
ESSENTIAL INFORMATION REGARDING
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
IN DOMESTIC AND INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS DEALINGS FINANCIAL
STATUS.
IN CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
WHEN YOU ARE IN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATE WHEN YOU'RE THE
PRESENT UNITED STATES YOU ARE
ALSO THERE'S ONLY TWO OFFICES IN
THE LAND THAT ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LIES.
THE PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
ALL OF US WHOARE SITTING HERE
TODAY ARE SUBJECT TO THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LIES.
IF YOU SIT ON THE SAN JOSE CITY
COUNCIL.
THE SACRAMENTO CITY COUNCIL THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR SCHOOL
BOARD YOU HAVE TO DISCLOSE MORE
INFORMATION COMPLICATED
INFORMATION ON CONFLICT OF
INTEREST INFORMATION.
AS A LOCAL ELECTED A MEMBER OF
THE SCHOOL BOARD ANY DO AS
PRESIDENT BY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
BECAUSE YOU'RE SUBJECT TO
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LAWS.
SO I BELIEVE THAT WE WILL
WITHSTAND ACOSTA SHORTENING
THERE ARE GOING TO BE ATTORNEYS
OUT THERE THAT SAY THAT WE WON'T --
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT THEY
SHOULD BE TESTED IN THE COURTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF I JUST
CANDICE TO THE FOLLOW UP.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THIS
BEING A PARTISAN ISSUE IN FACT I
EVEN IN THIS COMMITTEE I DON'T
LIKE THE FACT WE TALK ABOUT
BEING REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT --
WE THE THE GOAL HERE IS TO TRY
TO CREATE A SOME RULES THAT
EVERYBODY HAS TO TO TO ABIDE BY.
WHAT IS DISTURBING TO ME IS THAT
IF THE?
IF THE SHE WAS ON THE OTHER FOOT
AND WE HAD A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT WHO WOULD NOT RELEASE
IS RETURNS -- I CAN TELL YOU
THERE'D BE OUTRAGE -- AMONG
SPOKES ON ON THE RIGHT.
AND SO THE THE ISSUE IS THE
PRESENT SHE RELEASES TAX RETURNS --
THE QUESTION FOR ME IS WHETHER
THIS IS CONSTITUTIONAL OR NOT --
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT THAT
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR ME -- BUT
THE FIVE IF IF THOSE FOLKS BACK
IN WASHINGTON DC WERE WATCHING --
I THINK WE ALL AS AMERICANS IS
CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE THAT THE
PRESENT I'D STATE SHOULD
RELEASES RETURNS.
IF IT'S OKAY WITH FUTURE WHAT I
WOULD SAY AND THE IN I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS IN THEIR BRING
THAT FORWARD.
WE HEARD A LOT OF FEEDBACK.
ABOUT PARTISANSHIP.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BACKING FUNNY
TODAY INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR THE
GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA.
BY THE WAY THE GOVERNOR
CALIFORNIA HAS LEAD BY EXAMPLE
RELEASE HIS TAX RETURNS.
RELEASE THE SAME INFORMATION
THAT IS READ THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED OF ANY PRESIDENT UNDER
THIS BILL.
SO NOW REQUIRED IN THIS BILL
WOULD BE THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA GAVIN
NEWSOM [inaudible]
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE.
AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THAT
IF HILLARY CLINTON HAD WON THIS
RACE.
OUT WE WOULD BE HERE PRESENTING
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT SETTING SIGN
YOUR PERSONAL BELIEFS AND BEING
A PATRIOT.
IN BEING TRANSPARENT IN
RELEASING YOUR RETURNS AND BY
THE WAY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ON OUR SIDE ON
THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIR.
YES SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR WE WORKED A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS TOGETHER HE TO
YOU KNOW.
YEAH I THINK THE PROBLEM HERE IS
THAT YOU'RE NOT DOING THIS IN A
VACUUM YOU KNOW -- AND EVEN
WITHOUT IN THE GOVERNOR IT LIKE
IT THE CONTEXT OF WAR AND
THERE'S ONLY ONE PERSON ONLY PER
ONE PRESIDENT WHO HASN'T
RELEASED.
HIS TAX RETURNS RIGHT AND SO IT
LOOKS VERY POLITICAL AND IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT'S AN EVEN
HANDED APPROACH -- AND I THINK
THAT'S THE PROBLEM LIKE IF YOU
IF YOU WERE DOING THIS IN A
CONTEXT WHERE -- YELLED ALL ALL --
ALL ALL CANDIDATES HAD.
RELEASED THEIR TAX RETURNS OR
ALL CANDIDATES HAD RELEASE OUR
TAX RETURNS THAT THAT MIGHT BE
ONE THING -- BUT WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
OPERATE IN A CONTEXT THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO GET
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT BY A COURT
ABSOLUTELY -- I ALSO THINK LIKE
WERE ALSO IN THIS CONTEXT OF
TALKING ABOUT PRIVACY.
AND HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS AND
HOW WE DON'T WANT YOU KNOW OUR
PRIVACY.
AS CONSUMERS AS CONSUMERS
CERTAINLY WHEN OUR PEOPLE SIGN
OUR INFORMATION WITHOUT OUR
CONSENT.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WE GIVE
UP ALL SENSE OF PRIVACY AS
PEOPLE WHO ARE PUBLIC FIGURES WE
DON'T GIVE UP ALL SENSE OF
PRIVACY.
WHEN WE RUN FOR OFFICE -- ALL OF
US DO FILE STATEMENTS OF
ECONOMIC INTEREST.
SO DO THE FEDERAL CANDIDATES AS
WELL SO EVERYBODY CAN SEE WHAT
THEY HAVE INTEREST IN -- BUT TO
ME MA'AM MY TAX RETURNS OR
NOBODY ELSE'S BUSINESS PERIOD.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO REQUIRE OF
SOMEBODY ELSE SOMETHING I
WOULDN'T EXPECT.
OF MYSELF -- AND CERTAINLY I I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
PROBLEMS APPEAR RELEASING YOUR
PRIVATE TAX RETURNS -- OF
TALKING ABOUT WHAT DEDUCTIONS
YOU'VE TAKEN AND AND YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY
YOU'VE MADE I MEAN I TO ME
THAT'S NOBODY'S BUSINESS -- YES
PRESIDENTS HAVE TRADITIONALLY
DONE THAT THAT'S A TRADITION NOW
IT'S NOT A LEGAL REQUIREMENT.
AND THEN LASTLY WE TALK ABOUT
THIS A LOT THIS COMMITTEE VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
THIS WOULD CAUSE VOTER
SUPPRESSION IF YOU HAVE.
LOOKED DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO
BE THE REPUBLICAN.
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE OKAY --
HE'S GONNA BE ON THE BALLOT IF
IF IN MARCH.
BECAUSE OF THIS PROVISION HE'S
NOT ALLOWED TO BE ON THE BALLOT
IT'S GOING TO MEAN THAT
REPUBLICAN VOTERS HAVE NO NO
REASON TO TURN OUT.
WHICH WHICH AFFECTS EVERY DOWN
BALLOT RACE.
AM IN IS A HUGE VOTE AND IF IT
WERE IF THE SHOE WERE ON THE
OTHER FOOT I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE BE SAYING THE SAME THING.
BECAUSE IT WOULD SUPPRESS
DEMOCRATIC TURN OUT -- AS WELL
AND SO AND AND LOOK I MEAN IF.
TO YOUR POINT IF LET'S SAY JOE
BIDEN DECIDES NOT TO RELEASE HIS
TAX RETURNS IS NOT ON THE BALLOT
IT'S GONNA BE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SHOW UP FOR
JOE BIDEN.
WHO WON'T -- BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE FOR
THE CANDIDATE THAT THEY SEE IS
IS BEST FOR PRESIDENT SO LOOK I
THINK WE SHOULD REALLY LOOK AT
THIS.
IN A BALANCED WAY AND AND AND
VOTE NO ON THIS ON THIS PROPOSAL
AND IN THE FUTURE WE CAN TALK
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CANDIDATES BUT I
THINK IN THIS CONTEXT IT JUST
REALLY LOOKS.
OVERLY POLITICAL AND I THINK IT
COULD HAVE A VERY NEGATIVE
RESULT ON VOTER TURNOUT.
IN MARCH SO THROUGH THE CHAIR
PLEASE.
THIS IS JUST BEING CANDID WHAT
WE KNOW AND WHAT WE SEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE.
THE BIGGEST TURN OUT FOR
DEMOCRATS.
IS PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
HE'S THE BIGGEST ORGANIZER FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WE'RE SEEN RECORD NUMBERS OF
DEMOCRATS TURNING UP BECAUSE A
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
IF THIS WAS ABOUT VOTER
SUPPRESSION WE'D HAVE PRESIDENT
TRUMP ON EVERY FLIPPIN BALLOT WE
COULD HEAR IN CALIFORNIA --
TRULY.
I THAT'S THE GOD HONEST TRUTH.
SO THIS IS ABOUT.
I SO THIS IS IT THIS IS ABOUT
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CALIFORNIA THIS IS ABOUT PUTTING
THE INTERESTS OF YOUR COUNTRY
FIRST AND I THINK WE NEED TO
FLIP THIS DISCUSSION. FORTY
YEARS WE'VE HAD FORTY YEARS OF
EVERY PRESIDENT.
REAGAN.
CARTER BOTH BUSHES REALLY SIR
TAX RETURNS SO THAT THE QUESTION
THAT I HAVE IS WHAT IS THE
INDIVIDUAL HAVE TO HIDE -- END
IT IS VERY CLEAR.
THAT THIS IS TARGETED TARGETED.
IN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO ALL
CANDIDATES AND WE HAVE THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ON THIS BILL.
HE IS IN THE BILL HE IS ALREADY
LEAD BY EXAMPLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE FEEDBACK WE
RECEIVED FROM MEMBERS FROM THE
OTHER SIDE AND BY THE WAY I HAVE
GREAT RESPECT FOR MISTER
GALLAGHER LOVE WORKING WITH THEM
ON ALL ISSUES OF FAR RECOVERY.
LOW EMISSION MAYES -- IN I WOULD
SAY THOUGH IS THAT WE HAVE
LISTENED TO FEEDBACK AND THAT IS
WHY YOU HAVE THE GOVERNOR WHO IS
LEAD BY EXAMPLE IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU CENTER.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BECAUSE NO YOU CANNOT
SIR.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND COLLEAGUES.
NEW DOCTOR WEBER -- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR COMMENTS
AND YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING BECAUSE IT IS SO
TRUE THAT IF OF SHOE ON THE
OTHER FOOT EVERYBODY WOULD BE
DEMANDING TRANSPARENCY.
I COULD NEVER IMAGINE OBAMA NOT
TURNING OVER HIS TAX RETURNS.
AND EVEN WITH THAT EVEN HIS
BIRTH CERTIFICATE.
REQUIRED STEEL CONSTANT
QUESTIONS AND CHALLENGES TO HIS
QUALIFICATIONS AS A PERSON WHO
RAN FOR PRESIDENT SO AND WHAT.
SO I THINK IT IT YOU KNOW IT
IT'S IT'S SHOCKING TO ME THAT
OUT.
THAT AFTER ALL THIS TIME WE'RE
STILL GRAPPLING WITH THIS ISSUE
OF UNDERSTAND WHETHER THERE'S
FINANCIAL CONFLICT IN THE OFFICE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IS THE MOST POWERFUL PERSON IN
THE WORLD WHO HAS AS WE HAVE
SEEN HAS TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL TO
DO GOOD THINGS AS WELL AS TO
PROVIDE HARM.
AND AND WHERE PEOPLE WANT TO
VOTE FOR HIM AND NOT HIS JOB IS
TO FULFILL THE QUALIFICATIONS OF
ANY OFFICE THAT HE IS RUNNING
FOR ALL OF US DO THAT WHEN WE
RUN IN A DIFFERENT DISTRICTS.
SOME OF THEM REQUIRE MORE
SIGNATURES AND OTHERS SOME
REQUIRE OTHER KINDS OF THINGS
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT AND WE MEET
THOSE QUALIFICATIONS -- I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR LEGAL
ARGUMENTS AS THERE AND ONE OF
THINGS I'VE ALWAYS DONE AND
MAYBE BECAUSE MY HUSBAND WAS A
JUDGE AND OUT HE ALWAYS TOLD ME
NEVER PRACTICED LAW WITHOUT A
LICENSE.
AND DOESN'T NEVER START TRYING
TO MAKE LEGAL ARGUMENTS AND
STATEMENTS ABOUT STUFF YOU'RE
NOT QUALIFIED TO DO.
SO IN THIS HOUSE I TRY TO SIMPLY
DECIDE WHAT IS RIGHT WHAT IS
FEAR WHAT IS JUST AND WHAT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF PEOPLE.
WE WILL ALWAYS BE SUED BY
SOMEBODY BECAUSE THAT'S JUST
WHAT PEOPLE DO EVEN WITH THE
BEST BILLS WE'VE EVER PASSED
SOMEBODY DECIDES THEY WANT TO
FOLLOW IN JUNCTION OR SOMETHING
AGAINST US.
AND THAT'S A PART OF IT SO I
NEVER TRY TO WRITE A BILL WITH
THE FEAR THAT SOMEBODY'S GONNA
SUE ME -- ALWAYS FELT THAT THE
PEOPLE SU THAT'S HOW MY HUSBAND
MADE A LIVING SO THAT WAS A GOOD
THING.
AND SO IT IT HEADED TO THE
INCOME OF THE FAMILY BUT SO I
NEVER WORRIED ABOUT LAWSUITS WE
ALWAYS WERE ABOUT WHAT'S RIGHT
WHAT'S JUSTIN WAS FEAR.
AND LET THOSE WHO IN THAT ARENA
DECIDE WHAT'S WHERE IT FALLS IN
TERMS OF THE LINES OF LAW
BECAUSE YOU COULD ARGUE BOTH
SIDES IT YOU'VE DONE -- SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT NOT JUST
FOR THIS ELECTION.
BUT FOR EVERY ELECTION AND WE
WAIT FOR THE NEXT ELECTION
WHOEVER'S PRESIDENT PEOPLE SAY
THAT'S BIAS AND WE SHOULDN'T DO
IT BECAUSE THAT THAT PERSON SO
WE'LL NEVER HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A PERSON A
PRESIDENT OR ANYBODY IN OFFICE.
THAT SOMEBODY WILL NOT SAY YOU
SHOULD NOT HAVE THIS BECAUSE
YOU'VE NOW GOT A SOUL SO
GOVERNOR YOU'VE GOT THIS AND
THAT IS TARGETED TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL MUCH MORE THAN WHAT
IS FEAR WHAT IS JUST.
AND IF WE HAD GOTTEN BEYOND THIS
DISCUSSION I CAN ONLY IMAGINE.
WHAT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN LIKE TO
HAVE HAD THAT INFORMATION THEN
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT POINT BUT
WAS STILL STUCK THE IT WITH THE
WITH THE SITUATION IS THERE?
AND WHAT I I DON'T DENY THE
POLITICS OF IT BECAUSE OF
POLITICS AS OUR IS WHAT DRIVES A
LOT OF THE THINGS HERE WE SEE
FLAWS IN OUR SYSTEM.
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT WE WELL
WE'VE ALWAYS GOTTEN PRESS OF THE
OF TAX RETURNS THAT THERE'S NO
QUOTE QUALIFICATION THAT
REQUIRES IT SO IF IT'S IMPORTANT
PEOPLE YOU RIGHT LOSS TO MAKE IT
REQUIRED I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S HOW WE COME INTO.
OF THE IDEA OF OF THE OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON HERE SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT I I I
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION GETTING TO
THE FLOOR -- AND I AND ALL THE
WORK THAT I KNOW GOES INTO IT I
APPRECIATE THOSE OF YOU WHO CAME
TODAY BECAUSE YOU APPRECIATE
YOUR CANDIDATE AND WHAT YOUR
CANDIDATE IS.
FOR I HOPE YOU ALSO WANT YOUR
CANDIDATE TO TURN OVER THE TAX
RETURNS IT BEING PRESIDENT IS
NOT A PRIVATE VISIT AND ANYONE
WHO RUNS FOR OFFICE WHO BELIEVES
THEY RETAIN ALL OF THEIR PRIVACY.
IS PROBABLY NOT AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL -- BECAUSE WE HAVE ALL
LOST A LOT OF PRIVACY WITH THIS
CONCERNING OUR CHILDREN OUR
PERSONAL LIVES OUR RELATIONSHIPS
AFFAIRS AND NOT AFFAIRS WHATEVER
PEOPLE SAY AND HAVE HAPPENS OUT
THERE.
THAT IS OPEN TO THE PUBLIC
PEOPLE FOLLOWS AROUND THEY WATCH
WHAT WE DO AND THAT'S A PART OF
IT IN AND YOU CAN CRY ABOUT IT
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL IN THE
ONLY SOLUTION IS DON'T RUN FOR
OFFICE.
DON'T BECOME AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
BECAUSE ONCE YOU DO PEOPLE GOING
TO LOOK TO SEE WHY DID YOU VOTE
A CERTAIN WAY WAS THERE ANY BIAS
WAS THERE ANY CONFLICT IF THEY
DON'T LIKE THE BOTH THAT YOU
TOOK.
AND AND WE ALL INDOOR THAT WE
ALL IN DOING THAT THE CONSTANT --
CHALLENGES AND SCRUTINY OF
EVERYTHING WE DO AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS -- WE HOPE IN THE END
THAT PEOPLE APPRECIATE WHAT
WE'VE DONE AND UNDERSTAND IT --
BUT THE REALITY IS YOU DO NOT
RETAIN ALL YOUR PERSONAL PRIVACY --
ONCE YOU BECOME AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL I HAD TO STOP GROCERY
SHOP AT NIGHT WHEN I WAS A
SCHOOL BOARD BECAUSE OF I DIDN'T
ALL THE ALL THE ICE CREAM AND
EVERYTHING I PUT IN MY BASKET
WOULD WOULD BASICALLY.
MELT BEFORE I GOT TO THE CHECK
OUT STAND BECAUSE EVERYBODY
WANTED TELL ME THEIR PROBLEM IN
THE GROCERY STORE AND AS AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL THAT WAS A PART
OF THE JOB.
AND UP AND SO -- THOSE ARE THE
THINGS WE UNDERSTAND THOSE ARE
THINGS WE WE IN DOOR AS A RESULT
IN ELECTED OFFICIALS AND YOU DO
NOT RETAIN ALL YOUR PRIVACY YOU
MAY WOULD LOVE.
TO BUT AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE YOU THEY WANT
TO KNOW WHO YOU ARE THE ONE A
WHITE MADE THE DECISIONS THAT
YOU MAKE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
BILL NOT APPRECIATED NOT BE
VOTING FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DODD WHETHER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
IT'S ON THAT DID WE HAVE A
MOTION.
YEAH WE DID AND A SECOND GRADE --
MAJESTIC CLOSE CENTER THANK YOU
SO MUCH TWENTY SECONDS OR LESS
PRIVACY IS IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS BILL THERE ARE STRICT
REACTION.
POLICIES THAT IS EMBEDDED IN
THIS BILL THAT SECTOR STATE
WOULD TAKE PART IN IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE THANK YOU CENTER.
WHY UNDERSTAND THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL AND THAT WILL LIKELY
BE CHALLENGED IN COURT I BELIEVE
WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORD AS WILL PROVIDE VOTERS
WITH MUCH INFORMATION ON THE
ETHICAL FITNESS?
OF THOSE RUNNING FOR U. S.
PRESIDENT THE HIGHEST AND MOST
IMPORTANT OFFICE IN THE LAND.
FOR THESE REASONS I'LL BE VOTING
ON THIS BILL AND RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
BE REFERRED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BERMAN.
BERMAN I GALLAGHER.
CALDERON CALDERON HIGH LOW.
WELL I NAMES.
MAYES NOT PHONING MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER.
THAT BILLS OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE
WILL WAIT FOR I WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU SENATOR.
THAT IS THE LAST BILL ON OUR
AGENDA -- WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
BILLS THAT PEOPLE NEED TO ADD ON
TO MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE GO
THROUGH THE ON CONSENT AGENDA.
SB ONE FIVE ONE IN SB SIX EIGHT
ONE MR MAYES [inaudible]
CONSENT [inaudible]
MAYES I HIGHER.
ITEM FIVE SB SEVENTY TWO MR
MAYES [inaudible]
MAYES NO.
ITEM SIX SB ONE THREE NINE
CALDERON.
CALDERON I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING.
ITEM EIGHT SB.
FIVE OH FIVE BY AMBER MAYES.
MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I ITEM NINE SB SIX FOUR
ONE ALLEN CALDERON.
NIGHT AS WELL.
MAYES [inaudible]
MAYES I THAT'S GREAT I THINK WE
MIGHT NEED.
TO DO WE KNOW IF MISTER
GALLAGHER IS PLANNING ON COMING
BACK.
HIS STUFF.
STILL OKAY.
YOUR CALL.
WILL CALL.
YEAH
.
YEAH PERFECT THANK YOU SO WITH
THAT -- THE HEARINGS ADJOURNED